START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE
WE DO NOT OF A QUORUM YET SO WE
WILL NOT CALL THE ROLL YET -- IN
ON LET ME ANNOUNCE IF YOU I'M
CHANGES ON THE AGENDA -- THERE
ARE TWO BILLS THAT ARE COLD
THERE ARE. TWO BILLS PULLED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA SO WE WILL NOT BE
HEARING THEM AND THOSE ARE SB --
SIX NINETY FOUR MR STONE --
RATHER SENATORS KNOWN.
AND SB -- FIVE CAN SENATOR JONES
AND ADDITIONALLY.
SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE BY SENATOR
DORADO IS NOW ADDED TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SO WE HAVE THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SB.
TWO THIRTY NINE SB.
TWO FIFTY SEVEN SB TWO FIFTY
NINE SB THREE NINETY NINE SB
[inaudible]
FOUR SEVENTY ONE AND DEATH.
SB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE ALL RIGHT SO
WITH THAT -- WE WILL START WITH
THE FIRST BILL PRESENTATION
SENATOR BATES
.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR IN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL ONE FORTY ONE IT ENSURES
THE SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES BY
REQUIRING THAT ALL INMATES
CONVICTED OF A SEXUALLY VIOLENT
OFFENSE.
BE ADMINISTERED A RISK
ASSESSMENT BEFORE RELEASE I AM
HAPPY ARE CERTAINLY THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE
TO CREATE THE BEST POSSIBLE
POLICY.
AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TODAY IN A
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO THE HARD
WORK OF STAFF THAT WORKED WITH
MINE.
TO BRING US HERE TODAY.
CURRENTLY BEFORE THEY ARE
RELEASED FROM PRISON INMATES
SENTENCED TO A DETERMINATE TERM
FOR A SEXUALLY VIOLENT OFFENSE
ARE EVALUATED. FOR POTENTIAL
MENTAL DISORDERS WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WE ARE ACCEPTING FROM
THE COMMITTEE SB ONE FORTY ONE
WILL ENSURE THAT ARE SIMILAR
EVALUATION IS A MINISTER TO
INMATES WITH.
INDETERMINATE OR LIFE SENTENCES
FOR SEXUALLY VIOLENT CRIMES WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY RELEASE.
THIS WILL GUARANTEE THAT INMATES
WHO HAVE A PRIOR SEXUALLY
VIOLENT OFFENSE ARE ASSESSED
DURING THE PAROLE BOARD HERING
PROCESS FOR THEIR POTENTIAL RISK
TO RE OFFEND.
THIS DOES NOT CREATE A NEW
DUPLICATIVE PROCESS OUTSIDE OF
AN INMATE'S PAROLE BOARD HEARING.
BUT INTO REYES A NECESSARY
SAFEGUARD INTO THE EXISTING
FRAMEWORK.
THE CASE IS THAT FALL INTO THIS
CATEGORY ARE NOT LARGE NUMBER.
BUT THEY ARE SIGNIFICANT THESE
ARE SOME OF THE MOST VIOLENT AND
DANGEROUS SEXUAL OFFENDERS IN
OUR PRISONS AND WE MUST ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE MENTALLY STABLE.
BEFORE THEY'RE RELEASED INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
ARE THE BILL SPONSORED BY THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND JOINING ME FROM HER
OFFICE THIS MORNING.
IS DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
PATRICK ESPINOZA.
PATRICK [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OF YOU MAY SPEAK.
GOOD MORNING I WANNA THANK THAT
THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY.
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER STAFF
AND THAT THE CBO COUNTY DA'S
OFFICE IS A SPONSOR OF SB ONE
FORTY ONE IS THE AND WE WILL
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF WHO
WORKED WITH THE SINGLE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND CDC ARE TO
WORK OUT SOME THE AMENDMENTS --
THAT THE IDEA BEHIND THE
LEGISLATION IS THAT.
SOME OF THE MOST VIOLENT
OFFENDERS WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN
STATE PRISON THEY CAN BE
ASSESSED FOR A RISK ANALYSIS
SPECIFICALLY FOR SEX OFFENDERS
AND WITH THE LEGISLATION WOULD
DO.
IS IT WOULD REQUIRE THE PAROLE
BOARD TO CONSIDER THE RESULTS OF
A COMPREHENSIVE.
VALIDATED RISK ASSESSMENT FOR
SEX OFFENDERS AND WE THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT INFORMATION
THAT SHOULD BE CONSIDERED --
WHEN THE BOARD DETERMINES
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE TYPE THE
FENDERS SHOULD BE GRANTED PAROLE?
AND WE ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE SENATOR BATES FOR FOR
CARRYING THE BILL AND HER STAFF
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER.
ANY QUESTIONS ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE I
WOULD HAVE REGARDING SB.
ONE FORTY ONE WE WOULD URGE A
AND I'VE OF THANK YOU LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MUCH LEARNED YOU HAVE
TO CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT. FIFTY
MATHIS SOME HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
GREAT.
NOW ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING LESLIE CALDWELL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE WITHDRAWING
OUR OPPOSITION.
GIVEN THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE ALSO
WITH DRYING OUR OPPOSITION AND
ARE REALLY GRATEFUL.
TO THE COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING THESE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
GREAT ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
ALL RIGHT -- WE DON'T HAVE
QUORUM SO WE CAN'T TAKE A MOTION
THAT THERE MAY BE QUESTIONS BUT
SENATOR BATES I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION. FOR
YOUR WORK WITH OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF I THINK THESE AMENDMENTS
ARE IT'S IT'S VERY GOOD AND ARE
REALLY -- APPRECIATE.
THE WE ARE ABLE TO GET IN A IN A
PLACE WHERE PEOPLE FELT GOOD
ABOUT THE BILLS YOU SEE TODAY WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION.
AND I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT IT --
AND I THINK YOUR YOU'RE OPENNG
STATEMENT IN YOUR WITNESS
EXPLAINED IT VERY WELL.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
FROM.
RIGHT WELL SO WHEN WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM.
WE WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
THE BILL.
AND A REALLY APPRECIATE -- THE
PRESENTATION THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR STAFF BECAUSE I THINK THE
AMENDMENTS.
IN THE DIRECTION WHAT MAKES SO
MUCH SENSE BECAUSE WHY HAVE A
DUPLICATIVE PROCESS.
BUT THOSE ARE THINGS THAT COME
OUT WITH GREAT STAFF WORKS ON
THANK YOU GUYS THANK SENATOR --
SO WE WILL GO NEXT [inaudible]
TO SORRY WOOD -- SO MISTER ROSS
IS NOT HERE -- MR NIELSEN SNORT
HERE MISTER MONNING SNART HERE
MISTER -- BRADFORD DOESN'T HAVE
A BILL.
AND MISTER MOORE LIKE DOESN'T
HAVE A BILL.
YES THE OFFICE IS ON HIS WAY
OKAY THEN WE WILL HOLD OFF -- TO
OKAY THAT'S GOOD.
RIGHT.
SO WE ARE WAITING SOME AUTHORS
.
THERE ARE GOING TO PROCEED THIS
IS THE BETTER.
IN MY WITNESSES ARE ON THEIR WAY
THEY SHOULD BE HERE THIS IS ITEM
FIFTEEN SB.
FIVE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR HELL SB.
FIVE FORTY FIVE WILL REQUIRE A
STATEWIDE PILOT PROGRAM FOR
FIRST TIME DO YOU WHY OFFENDERS
TO INSTALL AN IGNITION INTERLOCK
DEVICE.
THE COMMITTEE AND A FULL SENATE
UNANIMOUSLY.
APPROVED AN IDENTICAL BILL IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN SB.
TEN FORTY SIX ONCE EVERY TWO
MINUTES A PERSON IS INJURED IN A
DRUNK DRIVING CRASH IN THE
UNITED STATES.
ONCE EVERY HOUR SOMEONE DIES
FROM A DRUNK DRIVER.
IN CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR OVER ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE DIE FROM DRUNK
DRIVERS.
AND MORE THAN TWENTY THOUSAND
ARE INJURED.
SB FIVE FORTY FIVE TAKE SWIFT
ACTION. TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS
FROM DRUNK DRIVERS.
OVER HALF OF DIY OFFENDERS DRIVE
ILLEGALLY AFTER THEIR ARREST OR
DID NOT COMPLETE TREATMENT
PROGRAMS.
IN REPEAT DO YOU WHY OFFENDERS
KEEP RE OFFENDING THE ACCOUNT
FOR ABOUT ONE THIRD OF ANNUAL DO
YOU AYE CONVICTIONS.
A REPORT RELEASED BY MOTHERS
AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING FOUND
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
IGNITION INTERLOCK STOPPED A
DRUNK DRIVER NEARLY TWO POINT
SIX NINE MILLION TIMES
NATIONALLY. THIRTY THREE STATES
HAVE ALREADY ENACTED THIS THIRTY
THREE STATES HAVE ALREADY
ENACTED LAWS MANDATING AYE ID'S
FOR FIRST TIME OFFENDERS.
I HAVE SEEN SIGNIFICANT
DECREASES IN DRUNK DRIVING
DEATHS.
NEW MEXICO'S INTERLOCK LAW WAS
IMPLEMENTED.
DRUNK DRIVING FATALITIES ARE
DOWN BY 38%.
IN ARIZONA IN LOUISIANA.
DRUNK DRIVING DEATHS HAVE
DECREASED BY FORTY THREE AND 35%
RESPECTIVELY AS A RESULT OF THIS
LAW.
IN OREGON DO YOU AYE DEATHS ARE
DOWN 42% 42% IN OREGON IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETY ONE WITH NEARLY UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THE BILL CREATED A FOR COUNTY
PILOT PROGRAM IN THE COUNTIES OF
LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO ALAMEDA
AND TO LAURIE REQUIRING AYE ID'S
FOR ALL DO YOU WHY OFFENDERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
SENATE BILL TEN FORTY SIX WAS
INTRODUCED TO EXPAND THE PILOT
PROGRAM AYE ID'S REQUIREMENT FOR
ALL THE U. I. OFFENDERS
STATEWIDE.
THOUGH IT HAD RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
AN AMENDMENT TO SB TEN FORTY SIX
AT THE LAST MINUTE.
MAID ID'S FOR FIRST OFFENDERS
OPTIONAL INSTEAD OF MANDATORY.
WHICH IS INCONSISTENT WITH THE
ORIGINAL PILOT PROJECT.
THE RESULT IS THAT THE STATE
WIDE PILOT PROGRAM NOW DIFFERS
FROM THE LOCAL PILOT IT WAS
MEANT TO EXTEND.
IT IS CRUCIAL THAT WE PASSING
ALL OFFENDER AYE ID LAW
CONSISTENT WITH THE ORIGINAL
PILOT PROGRAM.
SO WE CAN APPROPRIATELY ASSESS
THE STATEWIDE IMPACT.
SOME WILL SAY DO YOU AYE
PENALTIES ARE TOO EXCESSIVE.
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER HAVE I HAVE
WORKED TO REDUCE TRAFFIC
PENALTIES AND BRING FAIRNESS
TOWARD JUSTICE SYSTEM I ALSO
LOOK FORWARD IN SUPPORTING SB
ONE FORTY FOUR THIS YEAR. TO
FURTHER REDUCE CRIMINAL FINES.
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND SAID
STAKEHOLDERS TO REDUCE EXISTING
PENALTIES AND COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH DO YOU EYES.
SB FIVE FORTY FIVE DOES NOT
INCREASE ANY EXISTING PENALTIES
FOR DO YOU AYE OFFENSES.
MY INTENT IS NOT TO EXCESSIVELY
PENALIZED IN FACT I WANT PEOPLE
TO BE ABLE TO RETURN TO EVERYDAY
LIFE MORE QUICKLY AND DO SO
SAFELY.
THE BILL OFFERS EXTENSIVE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE OPTION THE
SYSTEMS OPTIONS TO ENSURE ID'S
ARE AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
FOR ALL OFFENDERS.
THERE IS EVEN AN EARLY CREDIT
OPTION IN THE BILL.
WE'RE IF AN OFFENDER INSTALLS
AND ID EARLY THEIR SIX MONTH
CLOCK STARTS OFFENDERS DON'T
HAVE TO WAIT FOR THE DMV OR THE
COURTS.
THEY CAN PROACTIVELY INSTALL THE
ID START THEIR SIX MONTH CLOCK
AND GET ON WITH THEIR LIFE.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW PEOPLE TO
CONTINUE THEIR LIVES AND NOT BE
FORCED INTO SUSPENDED LICENSES
OR LIMITED DRIVING PRIVILEGES.
IT WILL ALSO ENSURE ALL DO YOU
WHY OFFENDERS DO NOT DRIVE DRUNK.
SB FIVE FORTY FIVE IS AN
EVIDENCE BASED APPROACH THAT
WILL KEEP OUR ROADS SAFE.
BUT DON'T JUST TAKE MY WORD FOR
THE NATIONAL TRANSPORTATION
SAFETY BOARD SUPPORTS MY
LEGISLATION STATING MISSION
INTERLOCK DEVICES ARE EFFECTIVE
IN REDUCING RECIDIVISM.
AMONG D. W. I. OFFENDERS
SOMETIMES BY AS MUCH AS 62275%.
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION HAS COLON STATES
TO IMPLEMENT MANDATORY I ID LAWS
FOR FIRST TIME OFFENDERS STATING
THAT.
THAT ALCOHOL IMPAIRED DRIVING
DECREASES BY AN AVERAGE OF 6367%.
THE INSURANCE INSTITUTE OF
HIGHWAY SAFETY FOUND THAT STATES
THAT IMPLEMENTED LAWS LIKE SB
FIVE FORTY FIVE SO DRUNK DRIVING
DEATHS DECREASED.
BY 16% BOTTOM LINE COLLEAGUES
ID'S PREVENT DRUNK DRIVING AND
SAVE LIVES.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
HERE JUST -- TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IN THE MERRY I WILL LET
YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND AND
THAT'S RIGHT.
QUALITY SENATOR -- BUT WE JUST
ESTABLISHED A CORNER WOULD LIKE
TO CALL THE ROLL BEFORE YOU
START YOUR TESTIMONY OKAY THANK
YOU MATTER.
SKINNER -- HERE SKINNER HERE
MORE LOCK.
WELL OUT HERE BRADFORD. FOR HERE
JACKSON HERE JACKSON HERE
MITCHELL MORALE WIENER.
NOW YOU CAN CONTINUE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN SKINNER
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS MERRY CLASS BACH ON
THE LIVERMORE RESIDENT AND THE
NURSE AT JOHN MUIR MEDICAL
CENTER AND WALNUT CREEK COUNTY
CALIFORNIA FOR TWENTY NINE PLUS
YEARS.
I'M A FORMER NATIONAL BOARD
MEMBER OF MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK
DRIVING.
I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MATTHEW CLASS BALK MANDATORY
IGNITION INTERLOCK THE U. I.
OFFENDER ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SB.
FIVE FOUR FIVE FIVE FORTY FIVE
I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS WAS A LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD REQUIRE ALL FIRST
TIME DO YOU WHY OFFENDERS TO
INSTALL AN IGNITION INTERLOCK
DEVICE.
THE LEGISLATION IS VERY PERSONAL.
MY SON IS MATTHEW CLASS BACH.
HE IS GONE BECAUSE A CONVICTED
DRUNK DRIVER.
CHOSE TO DRINK AND DRIVE.
THIS TIME ON A SUSPENDED LICENSE
MEANT TO KEEP HIM OFF THE
HIGHWAYS.
IN ADDITION INTERLOCKED Là LIKE
SB FIVE FORTY FIVE WOULD HAVE
SAVED MY SON'S LIFE.
EVERY DRUNK DRIVING DEATH IN
CALIFORNIA IN ANYWHERE IS
PREVENTABLE.
THE FACT COMPOUNDS THE GRIEF MY
FAMILY AND I LIVE WITH FOR THE
REST OF OUR LIVES.
MATT'S DEATH WAS A 100%
PREVENTABLE.
MATTHEW WAS A TWENTY TWO YEAR
OLD MIDSHIPMAN AT THE UNITED
STATES NAVAL ACADEMY.
WE WERE SO PROUD TO SEE HIM
PURSUE HIS LIFELONG DREAM OF
BECOMING A PILOT.
HE CONSISTENTLY MADE THE DEAN'S
LIST.
HE WAS THE FIRST SERGEANT OF HIS
COMPANY AND HIS SECOND CLASS
YEAR AND HE WAS ENGAGED FOR ONE
WEEK.
HE WAS KILLED BEFORE REALIZING
HIS DREAM.
YOU DON'T FORGET THE NIGHT THAT
CHANGES YOUR LIFE FOREVER.
I REMEMBER VERY CLEARLY THE
NIGHT OF JULY TWENTY NINTH.
TWO THOUSAND ONE MATT WAS WOMAN
SUMMER BREAK.
A DRUNK DRIVER RAN A STOP SIGN.
SLAMMING INTO THE CAR THAT MATT
MY HUSBAND TOM AND I WERE IN.
THE IMPACT FORCE US OVER A THREE
FOOT CONCRETE CONCRETE AREA
BARRIER.
WHERE WE WERE HIT BY AN ONCOMING
PICKUP TRUCKS?
TRAPPED IN THE CAR AN INJURED
MYSELF.
I TRIED TO GET TO MY SON TO
START CPR.
BUT I COULD NOT.
AS A NURSE AT A TRAUMA CENTER.
FOR TWENTY NINE PLUS YEARS I
HAVE NEVER FELT SO HELPLESS.
WHEN I HEARD AN EMT SAY THIS ONE
HAS NO PULSE I KNEW THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT MATT?
I SHARE MY STORY TODAY NOT FOR
PITY.
BUT TO MOTIVATE LAWMAKERS TO
MAKE THIS STOP.
MATT WHO WAS PREPARED TO RISK
HIS LIFE FOR HIS COUNTRY
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD DIED RIGHT
HERE ON CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY.
IT IS MATT IT IS EN MASSE
HONORED THAT I HAVE WALKED THE
HALLS OF THIS CAPITAL FOR TWELVE
YEARS TO SAVE OTHER FAMILIES.
FROM THE EXPERIENCING THE GRIEF
THAT MY FAMILY HAS EXPERIENCE.
IN HIS OWN WAY.
MATT IS SERVING OUR COUNTRY JUST
NOT LIKE HERE WE PLANNED.
WE KNOW THAT LICENSE SUSPENSION
ALONE IS NOT EFFECTIVE.
WE CAN'T JUST TAKE AWAY DRIVING
PRIVILEGES AND HOPE FOR THE BEST.
WE KNOW THAT UP 275% OF
OFFENDERS CONTINUE TO DRIVE ON
SUSPENDED LICENSES.
AND BY THE WAY.
MOST OF THOSE DRIVERS ARE
DRIVING WITHOUT INSURANCE
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED TO
HAVE INSURANCE WHEN THEY DON'T
HAVE A LICENSE.
IN ADDITION INTERLOCK USERS ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE INSURANCE.
IGNITION INTERLOCK STOP THE
REVOLVING DOOR OF REPEAT DRUNK
DRIVING.
A STUDY CONDUCTED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN BY THE
CALIFORNIA DMV FOUND THAT
IGNITION INTERLOCK ARE 74% MORE
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING THE U. I.
OFFENSES THAN LICENSE SUSPENSION
ALONE.
SB FIVE FORTY FIVE MATTHEWS LAW
WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL DRUNK
DRIVERS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
LEARN HOW TO DRIVE SOBRE TO USE
SICKNESS IGNITION AND LOCKS IT
GIVES DRUNK DRIVERS THE
OPPORTUNITY GET BACK TO THEIR
DAILY LIFE. TO GO BACK TO WORK
TO PICK UP THEIR CHILDREN TO
ATTEND DOCTORS APPOINTMENTS TO
ATTEND TREATMENT.
AS LONG AS THEY FIRST PROVIDE A
SOBRE BREATH.
AS A NURSE AT A BAY AREA TRUCK
MAGNET HOSPITALS I UNDERSTAND
THE ROLE OF TECHNOLOGY TO SAVE
LIVES.
IT IS NO DIFFERENT HERE.
WHAT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE IS
THAT THE ACCURACY OF TODAY'S
IGNITION INTERLOCK TECHNO
KNOWLEDGE HE HAS ADVANCED
TREMENDOUSLY?
OVER THE PAST DECADE AID
VIRTUALLY ELIMINATING THE CHANCE
OF CERTAIN FOODS AND CERTAIN
DRINKS ARE TO BACK HOLE WILL
TRIGGER A FOST POT FALSE
POSITIVE.
IN CALIFORNIA EVERY ADDITION
INTERLOCK MANUFACTURERS REQUIRED
TO USE FUEL CELL SENSORS WHEN
DETECTING ALCOHOL LOW LEVELS IN
IGNITION INTERLOCK DEVICES
SIMPLY PUT.
THE FUEL CELL UNLIKE THE OLD
SEMI CONDUCTOR SENSOR ONLY READS
ALCOHOL.
IT IS THE SAME TECHNOLOGY USED
BY BREATHALYZER BUT THAT THE CHP
AND ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
USE THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
TIMES AND FIELD SOBRIETY TESTS
EACH YEAR.
THE RELIABILITY OF THE
LIFESAVING POTENTIAL OF IGNITION
INTERLOCK IS THE REASON
WIDESPREAD USE OF IT INTERLOCKS
IS RIMAC RECOMMENDED BY EVERY
HIGHWAY SAFETY ORGANIZATION.
AS WELL AS THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND VARIOUS
TRAFFIC TRAFFIC SAFETY GROUPS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR ALLOWING ME
TO SPEAK TODAY I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE VOTE YES ON MATTHEWS LAW.
WE CANNOT AFFORD TO WAIT ANOTHER
YEAR TO PASS A COMMONSENSE LAW
THAT WILL STOP THE HORRIFIC 100%
PREVENTABLE TRAZ STRATEGIES
BECAUSE BY DRUNK DRIVING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A SECOND WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN SKINNER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS LEO AUTONOMOUS SAFETY
ADVOCATE FOR THE NATIONAL
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY BOARD.
THE NTSB IS AN INDEPENDENT
FEDERAL AGENCY CHARGED BY
CONGRESS TO INVESTIGATE TRAFFIC
CRASHES DETERMINE THE PROBABLE
CAUSES AN ISSUE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO IMPROVE SAFETY.
I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE FOUR FIVE MATTHEW CLASS
BACK MANDATORY IGNITION
INTERLOCK FOR DIY OFFENDER ACT
OF TWENTY NINETEEN AND ALCOHOL
AND OTHER DRUG IMPAIRMENT IS ON
THE N. T. S. B.'S TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY MOST
WANTED LIST OF TRANSPORTATION
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THE NTSB
RELEASED A STUDY REACHING ZERO
ACTIONS TO ELIMINATE ALCOHOL
IMPAIRED DRIVING.
WE RECOMMENDED A COMPREHENSIVE
SET OF NINETEEN TARGETED
INTERVENTIONS.
NTSB TOOK A BOLD FRESH LOOK AT
THIS ISSUE IN AN EFFORT TO HIM
AND IMPAIR DRIVING.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDED
REQUIRING A MANDATORY USE OF
IGNITION INTERLOCK FOR ALL
OFFENDERS CONVICTED OF IMPAIRED
DRIVING.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES FIRST TIME
OFFENDERS COMPRISE THE MAJORITY
OF D. W. I. CONVICTIONS.
BUT BY THE TIME THEY'RE
CONVICTED THE SO FOR SO CALLED
FIRST OFFENDERS HAVE DRIVE IN
HAVE DRIVEN UNDER THE INFLUENCE
OF ALCOHOL EIGHTY TIMES.
INTERVENTION HAS TO START EARLY
ON THE FIRST CONVICTION.
THE LIKELIHOOD OF SUFFOLK
SUBSEQUENT OFFENSES REDUCE
CRASHES AND SAVE LIVES.
IGNITION INTERLOCK FOR ALL
OFFENDERS PROVIDE A SWIFT AND
CERTAIN PUNISHMENT FOR CONVICTED
IMPAIRED DRIVERS.
ONCE INSTALLED IGNITION
INTERLOCK STOOD HER IMPAIRED
DRIVERS FROM GETTING BEHIND THE
WHEEL AND ENDANGERING THEMSELVES
AND OTHERS ON THE ROAD.
RESEARCH OVER THE LAST TWO
DECADES HAS FOUND THAT IGNITION
INTERLOCK DEVICES ARE EFFECTIVE
IN REDUCING RECIDIVISM AMONG DO
YOU AYE AND DWI OFFENDERS
SOMETIMES BY AS MUCH AS 62275%.
ACCORDING TO ONE ESTIMATE.
IF ALL DRIVERS WITH AT LEAST ONE
ALCOHOL AND DRUG IMPAIRED
DRIVING CONVICTION WITHIN THE
LAST THREE YEARS PRIOR TO THEIR
CRASH HAD USED A ZERO B. AC
IGNITION INTERLOCK.
APPROXIMATELY ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED DEATHS COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED IN ONE YEAR.
MOST AMERICANS THINK THAT WE
HAVE SOLVED THE DRUNK DRIVING
PROBLEM IN THE COUNTRY THE FACT
IS WE HAVE NOT. TO THE CONTRACT
COULD TO THE CONTRARY
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND OR
ONE THIRD OF ALL HIGHWAY DEATHS
INVOLVE IMPAIR DRIVING.
AND THAT NUMBER HAS REMAINED
STUBBORNLY CONSTANT FOR THE PAST
TEN YEARS IN THE UNITED STATES.
THAT IS ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
LOST LIVES IN PREVENTABLE
CRASHES.
BASED ON THE LACK OF PROGRESS
REDUCING ALCOHOL IMPAIRED
DRIVING OVER THE LAST TWO
DECADES.
IT IS CLEAR THAT MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE TO PUT AN END TO THESE
PREVENTABLE TRAGEDIES.
THE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT IGNITION
IGNITION INTERLOCK TECHNOLOGY
CAN AND SHOULD BE EMBRACED IN
THIS BATTLE AT EVERY LEVEL AND
THIS IS WHY NTSB SUPPORTS SB.
FIVE FOUR FIVE THERE IS NO
ARGUMENT THAT ADDRESSING THIS
LEADING KILLER ON AMERICANS
ROADS AMERICA'S ROADS REQUIRES A
BOLD MULTI FACETED APPROACH THAT
INCLUDES PREVENTING PREVIOUSLY
CONVICTED IMPAIRED DRIVERS.
FROM STARTING AND OPERATING
pCONSUMED A MEASURABLE AMOUNT OF
ALCOHOL.
ALLOWING A SECOND CHANCE COULD
MEAN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE
AND DEATH.
THE NTSB URGES CALIFORNIA TO
STRENGTHEN ITS ADMISSION
INTERLOCK Là.
THOUSANDS OF LIVES WILL BENEFIT
FROM YOUR ACTION I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
WHILE THOSE WITNESSES COME TO
MIKE I'M GOING TO HAND THE GAVEL
TO MY VOICE.
AND A LACK I HAVE TO DEPART THE
COMMITTEE FOR A LITTLE BIT FIVE
THE HEARING WILL CONTINUE THANK
YOU.
MR MEMBERS RAINY PERRY ON BEHALF
OF PORAC AND WE SUPPORT PEOPLE
GETTING THEIR LIVES BACK EARLY
THANK YOU.
JOHNSON CLAIMED TO HAVE THE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO ALSO IN SUPPORT.
AMY BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MAYBE WE CAN MAKE SOME ROOM AT
THE TABLE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESIGNATION HERNANDEZ SOME HALF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION
COMPLUTENSE ATTORNEYS IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE ALSO WORKING PUBLIC
DEFENDER OFFICE WE ARE OPPOSED.
TO THE BILL.
A FEW THINGS BACKGROUND --
CENTER HILL AND I HAVE BEEN IN
THIS POSITION BEFORE I THINK FOR
THE LAST TEN YEARS OR SO WE HAVE --
BEEN DISCUSSING THE WIFE OUR
PUBLIC POLICY HOW TO HANDLE IT
IN PARTICULAR ANALOG DEVICES SO
THERE'S BEEN AN ONGOING
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE --
CERTAINLY WE'RE DEALING WITH
SOME VERY SERIOUS ISSUES -- SOME
VERY SERIOUS TRAGEDIES -- THAT
ARE OBVIOUSLY -- REGRETFUL.
THAT BEING SAID WHAT WE HAVE --
NEGOTIATING DISCUSSED OVER THE
YEARS -- WAS SENT TO THE PILOT
PROJECT -- AND ONE PIECE OF THE
PILOT PROJECT WAS IN FACT A
STUDY.
A AND AS THE COMMITTEE NOW SAYS
POINTS OUT.
ACCORDING TO THE PILOT PROJECT
THE THE MANDATORY USE OF IRAQ OF
ICE ON FIRST OFFENSES DID NOT
HAVE A STATISTICAL IMPACT.
ON INCREASE OR DECREASE OF
REPEAT AND D. Y. FENCES IF I
REMEMBER CORRECTLY OR BELIEVE MY
MY BEEN REFERENCING CRASHES SO.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WAS
REALLY KEY IN FACT WE HAD I DO
REMEMBER HAVING TESTIMONY IN
COMMITTEE WHEN WE WERE WAITING
FOR THE REPORT HOW WE PUSH BACK
A BILL WAITING FOR THE REPORT --
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO SEE -- WHAT
THE EVIDENCE IS GOING TO BE IN
THE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT A
MANDATORY A LOCK IN A FIRST
OFFENSE -- DID NOT HAVE THE IF
THE DESIRED EFFECT AS I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT KEEP IN MIND
THE OTHER THING AND I'M GLAD --
THE PROPONENTS MENTION OREGON.
ONE THING THAT I HAVE BEEN
SAYING OVER THESE YEARS AND
SOMETIMES I GET CRITICIZED FOR
AND I TAKE THE CRITICISM.
BUT DO YOU EYES AND ALCOHOLISM.
REQUIRES A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH IS PROPONENTS INDICATED.
IN CALIFORNIA CLOSE 250% OF
ARRESTS FOR THE WISE OR NOT THE
DRIVERS WHAT I'VE BEEN ASKING
FOR SO IS A FULL.
YOU KNOW FULL SPECTRUM APPROACH
WE WANT TO REDUCE DEVICE WE NEED
MORE FUNDING FOR ALCOHOL
PROGRAMS IN THESE COMMUNITIES
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE CULTURALLY
RELEVANT -- THE TALK ABOUT
OREGON ORGANS CITIZENS ARE VERY
INTERESTING THEY ALSO HAVE A DO
YOU AYE DIVERSION PROGRAM.
IN OREGON WHICH WE DO NOT HAVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT IS ALSO
AN IDEA THAT I KNOW SENATOR HILL.
AND I HAVE IT'S COME UP DURING
OUR DISCUSSIONS AND DEBATES AND
PRIOR BILLS.
SO THEY'RE TAKING A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH I'M ALL.
FOR LET'S LOOK AT THE REAL
PROBLEM LET'S LOOK AT TRYING TO
REDUCE ALCOHOLISM REDUCE ALCOHOL
RELATED INCIDENTS WERE ALL FOR
THAT.
MANDATORY ANALOG DEVICES
ACCORDING TO THE THE STUDY
DIDN'T WORK HERE.
WE SHOULD MOVE FOR THE OTHER
THING ABOUT THE STATEWIDE PILOT --
THAT WAS TESTED OUT THAT AMEND
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN BY ACCIDENT
THAT AMENDMENT HAPPEN BECAUSE
THEY WERE YEARS OF DEBATE ON-WHETHER OR NOT A MANDATORY.
INTERLOCK DEVICE SHOULD BE USED
FOR THE FIRST TIME AND WHAT WE
FOUND IN STUDIES IS THAT WHEN IT
IS AN OPTION.
WHEN IS INCENTIVIZE TO INSTALL
INTERLOCK DEVICE IT IS MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE?
THEN IF IT'S IF IT'S MADE
MANDATORY THE LAST THING I'LL
MENTION THIS WHAT WE'VE BEEN
HEARING FOR ATTORNEYS IN FROM
THEIR CLIENTS.
THAT DESPITE THE WELL THE THE
BEST OF INTENTIONS OF CENTER
HILL ON THE PRIOR BILLS AND
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THE
INTERLOCK DEVICES ARE AFFORDABLE
AND THERE'S A SLIDING SCALE.
THE REALITY IS IN STATISTICS
BEAR IT OUT AND STUDY BEARS IT
OUT.
THAT COMPLIANCE IS RELATIVELY
LOW BECAUSE DRIVERS CANNOT
AFFORD IT.
AND COMPANIES ARE STILL NOT
PROVIDING A WAY TO PAY FOR IT
MAKE IT AFFORDABLE AND EVEN.
EVEN LOOKING AT PAYMENT PLANS WE
END UP WITH DRIVERS WHO MAY NOT
OWE MONEY TO THE COURT OR WILL
THEY STILL OWE MONEY THE
CORPORATE ALSO -- MONEY TO THESE
PRIVATE COMPANIES TO INSTALL THE
INTERLOCK DEVICES SO THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED AS WELL AND
CENTER HILLS ARE SENSITIVE TO
THAT HAS WE HAS TRIED TO ADDRESS
THAT BUT THEN THIS BILL IN THE
FOR THE PRIOR BILL SO.
IT'S NOT THIS BILL IS NOT AS
SIMPLE AS IT APPEARS ON ON THE
SURFACE YES WE WANT TO REDUCE
THE Y. OFFENSES ABSOLUTELY WE
WANT TO REDUCED U. I. TRAGEDIES
ABSOLUTELY BUT WE'VE HAD THIS
DEBATE FOR NUMBER OF YEARS.
WE SETTLED ON A CERTAIN APPROACH
AND AGREED ON A CERTAIN APPROACH.
AND THIS CHANGES THAT APPROACH --
THAT IS AND IT IS CONTRARY TO
WHAT THE STUDY SHOWS THAT WE
COMMISSION HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
FOR THOSE REASONS REPOSE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS.
YOU MISTER HERNANDEZ MISS CALLED.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
MISTER AND THEN THIS IS THE
PRETTY MUCH TOUCHED ALL THE
POINTS THAT I WOULD -- TOUCH ON
AND HAS MUCH MORE THE HISTORY
THEN I DO PERSONALLY HOWEVER --
FIRST I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT.
I TO IN MY ORGANIZATION WE ARE
DEEPLY SADDENED BY THE DEATH AND
THE INJURIES THAT PEOPLE SUFFER.
DUE TO DRUNK DRIVING.
AND I AGREE WITH THE SPEAKER
FROMTHE NTSB THAT INTERVENTION
MUST START EARLY.
EARLY IS NOT AFTER SOMEONE HAS
BEEN CONVICTED OF A G. A D. Y.
EARLY AS LONG BEFORE THAT WE
NEED THE MONEY TO GO TO
EDUCATION FOR YOUNG PEOPLE. FOR
TREATMENT FOR ALCOHOL AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE THAT'S WHERE WE
NEED TO FCUS NOT ON HAVING
SOMEONE PUT IN A VERY EXPENSIVE
INTO THEIR CAR A LOT OF THE OUR
CLIENTS AS PUBLIC DEFENDERS
DON'T EVEN HAVE THEIR OWN CAR.
THEY'RE DRIVING SOMEONE ELSE'S
CAR.
SO THIS REQUIREMENT OF THE
INTERLOCK UP WILL NOT MAKE A
CHANGE FOR THEM SECONDLY.
DRUNK DRIVING OFFENSES THE FIRST
TIME YOU'RE SPENDING THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS IN FINES AND FEES AND
AND INSURANCE IF YOU GO GET IT
AND ALL THESE THINGS -- AND A
LAWYER IF YOU CAN AFFORD A
LAWYER BUT MOST CANNOT MOST COME
TO THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE.
THOSE CLIENTS OF MINE HAVE TO DO-COMMUNITY SERVICE TO PAY FOR
THEIR PHONE LINES THEY UP
SOMETIMES GET CREDIT FOR MANY
MANY DAYS IN JAIL THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN.
INCARCERATED BUT THEY GET THAT
CREDIT AGAINST THEIR PHONE LINES
SO EVEN IF THEY'RE ONLY REQUIRED
TO PAY 10%.
OF THE COST OF THE INTERLOCK
DEVICE.
THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT JUST LIKE A
MISTER LANDER SAID THEY JUST
CAN'T AFFORD IT -- I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE REFERRAL TO
MANY OF THE STUDIES -- DUE
RESPECT TO THE SPEAKERS AND TO
THE SENATOR MANY OF THESE
STUDIES REFERRED TO DON'T JUST
LOOK AT FIRST TIME DO YOU --
LIKE SO YOU CANNOT RELY ON THOSE
STATISTICS. TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT FIRST TIME DO YOU WHY.
I'VE.
BEEN IN CRIMINAL DEFENSE FOR
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS I HAVE SEEN
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF FIRST
TIME.
DRUNK DRIVERS AND I HAVE NOT.
VERY OFTEN SEEN THEM COME BACK
THE FIRST TIME DRUNK DRIVERS I
OFTEN FEEL LIKE.
ALMOST ANYBODY COULD GET.
THEIR FIRST TIME DRUNK DRIVERS
DRIVING OFFENSE -- AND I KNOW
THAT'S NOT POLITICALLY CORRECT
TO SAY BUT I HAD THIS IS WHAT
I'VE SEEN WITH MY FRIENDS.
MY OWN FAMILY -- AND MY CLIENTS.
IT'S THE PEOPLE THAT GO ON TO
THEIR SECOND THAT REALLY NEED
THE HELP AND THAT'S WHERE WE
NEED.
THE TREATMENT THE EDUCATION AND
THE ANALOG DEVICES NOT GOING TO
CHANGE THAT -- OFTEN I AM AN
ALLIANCE WITH THE COURTS
DECISIONS WHEN THEY'RE
EXERCISING THEIR DISCRETION --
BUT I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO TAKE THAT
DISCRETION AWAY FROM THE COURTS.
IF ANYTHING THEY ARE VERY VERY
SERIOUS ABOUT.
DO YOU AYE CASES AND IF THEY
BELIEVE THAT THIS DEVICE IS
APPROPRIATE FOR FIRST TIME DRUNK
DRIVING.
OFFENDERS THEY WILL IMPOSE THIS
CONDITION AND I ASK YOU NOT TO
TAKE THAT DISCRETION AWAY FROM
THE COURT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
CALDWELL ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
THANK YOU.
AND FIRST I WANT TO EXTEND MY
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILIES WHO
ARE HERE BECAUSE THEY HAVE LOST.
LOVED ONES TO DRUNK DRIVING.
OF I I CAN I I HOPE I NEVER HAVE
TO KNOW BUT I CAN ONLY IMAGINE.
AND CERTAINLY -- WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO EDUCATE AND
PREVENT THIS FROM HAPPENING SO
UNNECESSARY AND YET SO
DEVASTATING SO.
ARE THAT'S THE FRAMEWORK FROM
WHICH I'M COMING SO I'M -- I
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS IF I MAY
AND I'D LIKE TO ASK THE N. T. AS
A PERSON AS WELL AS THE THE
DEFENSE SIDE OF THIS IF.
IF I COULD -- OF A LOT OF WHAT
WE'RE SEEING TODAY IS IN CHARGE
OF DRUNK DRIVING IT'S PEOPLE WHO
ARE.
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF
EVEN MEDICATIONS.
OF THAT FOR PEOPLE DRIVING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE OF ILLEGAL DRUGS
CANNABIS -- GOD ONLY KNOWS WHAT
ELSE IS OUT THERE IN THE MARKET
TODAY I CAN'T KEEP TRACK BUT IS.
IS YOUR RESEARCH YOUR STUDIES
INDICATE THAT THESE ARE EQUALLY
AS MUCH PROBLEM AND THAT THIS
DEVICE WILL.
AFFECT THE ABILITY OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF OTHER
INTOXICANTS OUT WILL BE
PRECLUDED FROM DRIVING A CAR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION.
I'M THE DATA THAT WE HAVE AROUND
DRUG IMPAIRED DRIVING IS NOT
ACCURATE BECAUSE THE REPORTING
IS INCONSISTENT ACROSS THE STATE.
HOWEVER WE DO KNOW ANECDOTALLY
THAT IT IS ON THE RISE -- BUT WE
DON'T HAVE THE HARD NUMBERS TO
SAY THAT THIS IS EQUAL TO
ALCOHOL IMPAIRED DRIVING WE DO
HAVE THE HARD NUMBERS FOR
ALCOHOL IMPAIRED DRIVING.
AND THAT IN CALIFORNIA IS ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED SIXTEEN
OF FATALITIES IN CALIFORNIA FOR
ANY AMOUNT OF ALCOHOL IN THE
SYSTEM.
IN ANY AMOUNT MEANING YOU COULD
HAVE A POINT NO ONE YET POINTA
ONE ALL THE WAY UP ONE THOUSAND
HREE HUNDRED SIXTEEN FATALITIES
IS THERE ANY REASON TO BELIEVE
IT APPOINT A ONE THESE PEOPLE
ARE DRIVING IMPAIRED.
ALTHOUGH -- EXCUSE ME IMPAIRMENT
BEGINS AT THE FIRST RANK.
IT BEGINS WELL I I KNOW THAT I I
STARTED MY CAREER AS A
PROSECUTOR AND AT WHEN THE BLOOD
ALCOHOL LEVEL -- ACTUALLY HAD
JUST COME DOWN FROM A POINT. ONE
FIVE TWO POINT ONE ALL IN OUR
POINT.
OH EIGHT SO YOU SUGGESTING THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE. ZERO TOLERANCE
FOR ALCOHOL THE NUMBER ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED SIXTEEN
IS A HIGH NUMBER BUT OUR OUR LAW
NOW SAYS THAT THAT YOU'RE
IMPAIRED AND APPOINT A WAITER
BUFF.
FEDERAL LAW ON NTSB HAS A
RECOMMENDATION TO LOWER THE B.
AC TO POINT OH FIVE OR LOWER.
SO THAT THAT IN AND OF ITSELF
MIGHT HAVE THE IMPACT YOUR
SEEKING HERE IN REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF DEATHS BY.
BILL WHO ARE IMPAIRED AS A
RESULT OF ALCOHOL.
IT WOULD HAVE A BROAD DETERRENT
TO BRING DOWN THE OF FATALITIES
IF YOU'RE TO LOWER THE BE A C.
CORRECT -- BUT THEY'RE STILL
WILL BE PEOPLE WHO CHOOSE TO
DRIVE IMPAIRED AND THAT IS FOR
THE IGNITION INTERLOCK WOULD
COME INTO PLAY IN TERMS OF
DETERRING THEM FROM GETTING
BEHIND THE WHEEL AFTER THEY'VE
CONSUMED ALCOHOL.
ACCEPTED PHASES POINTED OUT MANY
OF THEM DON'T HAVE CARS TO THE
DRIVING FRIENDS CARS.
I'M WONDERING IS ARE SOME KIND
OF TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE.
WHERE WE COULD IDENTIFY THEM NOT
BY?
THE YOU KNOW THAT DEVICE BUT THE
OF THUMB PRINT THEY'RE GONNA BE
DRIVING SOMEBODY ELSE'S CAR IS
OR IS THERE SOMETHING OUT THERE
THAT MIGHT HAVE A BETTER.
AFFECTED DETERRING PEOPLE
GETTING BEHIND THE WHEEL WITH A
IN ANY LEVEL OF IMPAIRMENT THERE
IS TECHNOLOGY THAT IS.
BEING DEVELOPED FOR SPECIFICALLY
ALCOHOL IMPAIRED DRIVING IF THE
DRIVER [inaudible]
DRIVER THIS.
D. A. D. S. S. -- AND I CAN'T I
SORRY CAN'T RECALL -- YES DADS
IN IT WASN'T NAME BY MOTHERS
AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING IT WAS
NAMED BY THE AUTOMOBILE ALLIANCE
AND ITS DEFECTIVE -- DAD'S
EFFECTIVE ALCOHOL DETECTION
SAFETY SYSTEM AND IT IS USES
SKIN SPECTROSCOPY LOOKS MUCH
LIKE WE USE IN THE HOSPITAL FOR
PULSE OX READING.
AND I WAS ACTUALLY AT AND NET SO
WHEN THEY UNVEILED THE CONCEPT
CAR AND IT WAS IT HAD COME OVER
WITH FROM SWEDEN.
IT USES -- TERROR ONE PROVIDERS
TO IT'S IT'S MUCH.
MORE.
SENSITIVE THAN WHAT WE HAVE
TODAY EVEN IN THE THE SOBRIETY
FIELD TEST THANK YOU VERY SO
PERHAPS NOT JUST IDENTIFYING ONE
FORM OF TECHNOLOGY.
BUT IN AS THE BILL PROCEEDS
PERHAPS EXPANDING ITS FOR THAT
WE USE THE BEST AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY WOULD SEEM TO ME. TO
TO AND ALSO SO THAT WE CAN
INCLUDE PEOPLE WHO WILL NOT
NECESSARILY BE DRIVING THEIR OWN
CARS A BECAUSE I THINK THAT.
THAT'S A CONCERN -- AND IN FACT
MIGHT EVEN INTENTIONALLY.
FIND SOMEBODY ELSE'S CAR TO
DRIVE AND AND AND WHAT HAVE YOU
BUT THAT BEING SAID ALSO -- IN
YOUR RESEARCH -- THE ARGUMENT
THAT AS MADE THE ODD PEOPLE WHO
TEND TO OF HAD JUST ONE DRUNK
DRIVING -- YOU KNOW PERHAPS WE
CAUGHT A COME TO JESUS MOMENT
WHEN THEY STOP -- THEY REALIZE
THEY SHOULDN'T BE DRIVING WHAT
ARE THE STATISTICS ON THAT.
I'M SORRY CAN CAN USE -- IS.
WE HAVE ALCOHOLICS TO DRIVE.
AND I THINK THEY'RE THE BIGGEST
RISK THAT WE HAVE ON THE ROAD I
THINK WE ALL AGREE.
AND THE FACT THAT IT THE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT ADDRESSING
ALCOHOLISM IN ADVANCE SO THAT.
WE DEAL WITH THE PROBLEM RATHER
THAN AT THE END OF THE ROAD IF
YOU WILL YEAH WHEN THEY'RE BONTA
BUSTED FOR DRUNK DRIVING.
CATCH THEM SO WE DO WITH
ALCOHOLISM UP FRONT BUT THERE
ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD A
SINGULAR ARREST FOR DRUNK
DRIVING BECAUSE THEY THEY
CONSIDER THEMSELVES SOCIAL
DRINKERS AND THEY'VE HAD MORE
ALCOHOL.
THE THAN A POINT OH EIGHT BLOOD
ALCOHOL WOULD ALLOW AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE LESS LIKELY TO
RECEIVE TO RECIDIVIST OR TO
REPEAT AND I'M WONDERING WHAT
THE STATISTICS ARE A IS THAT IS
THAT ACCURATE BASED UPON THE
RESEARCH DONE BY YOUR
ORGANIZATION I DON'T HAVE
STATISTICS ON THAT RIGHT NOW BUT
I CAN GET THAT TO YOU.
THE PERHAPS A THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE CHAIR IF THEY'RE
STILL DOES SOMEBODY HAVE THOSE
STATISTICS.
MISTER HERNANDEZ THANK YOU
MISTER -- IF I RECALL AND THIS
IS BASED ON THE DMV STUDIES AND
AND AGAIN I WOULD JUST CAUTION
THAT I'M DOING OFF OF MEMORY
THAT I LOOK AT THE STATISTICS
FAIRLY OFTEN.
BY RECALL I BELIEVE IT IS
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TWO AND 3% THE
RE OFFEND IN THE FIRST YEAR.
AND THEN I THINK IT GOES
SOMEWHERE INTO CLOSE 212% AGAIN
IT COULD BE A LITTLE BIT OFF ON
THIS OVER I BELIEVE A SEVEN YEAR
PERIOD. SEVENTY EIGHT YEAR
PERIOD I COULD BE A LITTLE BIT
OFF ON THAT BUT IT IT'S
SOMEWHERE AROUND THERE IT MIGHT
EVEN BE A LITTLE BIT LOWER ON
THAT FIRST YEAR BUT I'M I'M.
THAT'S THE BEST OF MY
RECOLLECTION BUT THESE ARE
PEOPLE OF FIRST TIME OFFENDERS
CRACKED.
SO THAT THEY FIRST THE FIRST
TIME CONVENTIONAL DERRICK I'VE
HEARD OF THIS SENATOR JACKSON
HAVE BEEN THAT IF YOU.
BY THE TIME YOU GET THAT FIRST
DO YOU I KNOW YOU PROBABLY
DRIVEN ANYTIME ANYTIME I
UNDERSTAND WRONG.
BUT THEY HAVEN'T GOTTEN CAUGHT
NOW YOU'RE CAUGHT IN IMUS AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WHEN
PEOPLE.
HAVE THAT MOMENT WHEN THEY BEEN
CAUGHT -- IN LESS THEY ARE
ALCOHOICS THEY ARE LIKELY TO
REASSESS THEIR BEHAVIOR AND ARE
LESS LIKELY TO RE OFFEND I'M
JUST A IS THAT TRUE OR FALSE.
FALSE I BELIEVE THE MAN THAT
KILLED MY SON HAD -- FIVE
PREVIOUS -- SUSPENSIONS AND HE
WAS DRIVING ON A SUSPENDED
LICENSE AT NIGHT AT POINT OH
NINE SIX BUT MY IN POINT IS THAT
THAT HE HAD HAD PROBABLY SEVERAL
OTHER.
DO YOU Y. ARRESTS AND
CONVICTIONS SO I I WAS A
CONVICTED OKAY BECAUSE THE THE
OUR LEGAL SYSTEM HE WAS A YOUNG
MAN TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD.
AND THEY FELT THAT HE NEEDED
HELP AND HE DIDN'T TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF GETTING THAT HELP.
AND WHEN I STE FIRST STARTED
COMING UP HERE TWELVE YEARS IT
WAS SENATOR BOB HUFF THAT TOLD
ME AS DRACONIAN TO DO THIS AND I
SAID IT'S DRACONIAN TO ALLOW FOR
PEOPLE DAY.
I UNDERSTAND I I'M JUST AND I I
APPRECIATE WOULD YOU SAY I JUST
WANT TO TRY TO GET THAT ANSWER
BECAUSE I I I SUPPORT I SUPPORT
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO I I
APPRECIATE YOUR EXPERIENCE HERE
I JUST WANT TO GET. TO TO THE
WHETHER OR NOT WHEN SOMEONE HAS
BEEN CONVICTED.
OF A OR MAYBE JUST POPPED ONCE
OR TWICE FOR DRUNK DRIVING IF
THOSE PEOPLE ARE NOT ALCOHOLIC
CLEARLY THIS YOUNG MAN HAD A
SERIOUS PROBLEM.
BUT IF THEY'RE JUST PEOPLE WHO
DON'T.
REALIZE THAT THEY ARE IMPAIRED
YOU KNOW WE CALL PEOPLE YOU HAVE
TO BE DRUNK PEOPLE DON'T THINK
THEY DON'T RECOGNIZE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BE DRUNK.
JUST IMPAIRED AND THAT'S AN
EDUCATION PROCESS THAT WE
PROBABLY SHOULD DO BUT PEOPLE
WHO ARE ARRESTED WHO ARE ONLY
QUOTE UNQUOTE IMPAIRED.
WHAT IT WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THOSE
PEOPLE WITH ONE ONE
CONFRONTATION WITH THE LAW? ONE
DRUNK DRIVING CONVICTION ARE
LIKELY TO REPEAT.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S BEEN ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS I'M JUST I JUST
WANT TO GET THAT ANSWER.
IF WE COULD -- BECAUSE I KNOW
WHEN YOU HAVE TWO OR MORE YOU
KNOW YOU THE THESE ARE PEOPLE
BASICALLY ARE UNABLE TO CONTROL --
OR MAKE PROP MAKE GOOD DECISIONS
I THINK IS THE BEST WAY TO
DESCRIBE IT HERE'S PEOPLE OF
HAD A ONE DRUNK DRIVING.
MANY OF THEM WILL MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS I UNDERSTAND AND MANY
OF THEM WON'T BUT I'M WONDERING
WHAT PERCENTAGES ACT THAT'S ALL
I'M TRYING TO FIND OUT.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE THAT
THAT INFORMATION.
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
AND MISTER HERNANDEZ HAVE YOU
FOUND IT ON YOUR IPHONE YET --
YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE IN FACT I
WAS REMINDED OF ONE OF THE
STATISTICS WE HAVE IS IT.
IS IT ONE THIRD RE OFFEND. ONE
THIRD YES OKAY.
BUT WHAT IS SET THROUGH IN
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
YES.
THE RATES ARE LOW.
ALRIGHT WELL IF.
WE ARE NOT WAS ORIGINALLY
WRITTEN.
FOR SO T. THE TWENTY FIVE OR 30%
STILL A BIG NUMBER THAT THAT
GOES TO YOUR CONCERNS.
ARE WELL I AM ARE THE ONLY OTHER
QUESTION IS -- I'M CONCERNED
THAT WE HAVE NOT DEVELOPED -- AN
EFFECTIVE WAY TO IDENTIFY PEOPLE
WHO ARE DRIVING IMPAIRED BECAUSE
OF THE USE OF RUGS -- SO
SOMEONE MIGHT BE TAKING
MEDICATION OF ONE DRINK THE
BLOOD ALCOHOL COME OUT A POINT --
THREE BUT THEY ARE IMPAIRED AND
IF WE'RE LOOKING AT TRYING TO
SAVE LIVES WHICH I THINK IS THE
GOAL FOR ALL OF US IT SEEMS TO
ME.
THAT WE'VE GOT TO WE'VE GOT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT A LOT OF
IMPAIRMENT IS.
SUBSTANCE RELATED AND I'M
WONDERING IS THERE ANYTHING
GOING ON NOW WITH THE NTSB I
MEAN WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO JUDGE MARIJUANA FOR
FORTY YEARS.
SO AND NOW MARIJUANA IS LEGAL
LICENSE -- HOW ARE WE GOING TO
FIGURE OUT OF PEOPLE ARE
IMPAIRED DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF OF CANNABIS ANOTHER
NOW LEGAL DRUGS YEAH WE -- NTSB
DOES HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO
THE NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP
A WAY.
TO DETERMINE THE LEVEL OF
IMPAIRMENT UNTIL WE HAVE THAT WE
REALLY.
CAN'T DO MUCH IN TERMS OF
ARRESTS OR ANYTHING I MEAN WE
HAVE THE WE ALSO HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF DRUG RECOGNITION
EXPERTS -- SO THAT -- THEY HAVE
A LAW ENFORCEMENT HAVE A HIGHER
LEVEL OF TRAINING TO DETECT AND
DETERMINE IF AN INDIVIDUAL IS
IMPAIRED BY DRUGS ANY TYPE OF
DRUG.
AND WE HAVE -- RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THAT SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
THOSE ARRESTS FOR DRUG
IMPAIRMENT BUT IN TERMS OF
HAVING US LIKE A BIRD BUT BE A
C. FOR DRUG IMPAIRMENT THAT IS
WE ARE UNABLE TO DO THAT AT THIS
POINT.
IN YOUR ROOM IF I COULD LINE
ABOUT ACTION TO ME WE HAD THE
SAME PROBLEM FORTY YEARS WE DID
AND AND AS YOU KNOW IT AND YOU
WITH YOUR HELP LAST YEAR.
THERE IS WORK BEING DONE WITH I
THINK IS UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO
OR SANDY AT UC SAN DIEGO WITH
THE HIGHWAY PATROL THEY'RE NOW
CONDUCTING THE STUDIES.
AND THIS THE THE RESULTS OF THAT
SHOULD BE BACK BY THE MIDDLE OF
THIS YEAR IN FACT WE'RE LOOKING
AT MAYBE AMENDED SOME
LEGISLATION TO TRY AND INCLUDE.
WHEN THEY DETERMINE WHAT THAT
LEVEL OF IMPAIR WHAT THAT LEVEL
IS THAT CREATES THAT IMPAIRMENT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND THEN WE
CAN?
WE CAN TRY TO PREVENT THAT SO
SUPPORT THIS AYE IF I MAY JUST
CLOSE BUT I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
CONSIDER -- ALTERNATIVE METHODS
BEST AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY THAT
WILL ALSO MOVE WITH THE ARE WITH
THE PERSON -- AND ALSO CONSIDER
THAT IF WE'RE REALLY GOING TO
TRY TO GET THESE PEOPLE OFF THE
ROAD WE'VE GOT TO IDENTIFY
PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST DRIVING
IMPAIRED AS RESULT ALCOHOL.
TO SENATOR JACKSON IF I MAY ADD
TO THAT AS A TRAUMA -- ARE IN
NURSING THE TRAUMA CENTER WE DO
TRAUMA CAM PANELS ON OUR CRASHES
THAT COME IN.
THERE ARE TWENTY DIFFERENT DRUGS
THAT WE TEST.
FOR AND IT'S NEGATIVE POSITIVE
NEGATIVE POSITIVE UNTIL YOU GET
TO ALCOHOL AND THERE'S A LEVEL
THERE IS NO -- MEANT LEVEL FOR
ALL THE DIFFERENT DRUGS THAT WE
HAVE SO WE HAVE TO HAVE PER SE
LAWS THERE I DON'T THINK THERE
WOULD BE ANY WAY.
THAT WE COULD GET AN IMPAIRMENT
LEVEL ON EACH DIFFERENT THE
HUNDREDS OF DIFFERENT DRUGS THAT
WE HAVE.
SO PER SE LAWS MAY BE WHAT WE
NEED AND I DO KNOW THAT
TECHNOLOGY IS BEING DEVELOPED --
TO BY SOME OF THE COMPANIES TO
MEASURE THE LEVEL OF DRUG THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
LONG ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON
IGNITION INTERLOCK DEVICES.
SENATOR BRADLEY YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I WANT THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR THIS MEASURE.
BUT AS YOU AND I DISCUSSED I
HAVE SOME CONCERNS BECAUSE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE DMV REPORT THEY
SAID IT WAS.
THEY WOULDN'T EXTEND THE PILOT
PROGRAM AND THEY FOUND IT TO BE
COUNTER PRODUCTIVE.
THOSE -- STATEMENTS BY THE DMV
THAT STATED THAT AND ALSO
REMOVING THE JUDGE'S DISCRETION
I TALKED TO SOME OUR FRIENDS AND
YOU AND I HAD OUR DISCUSSION
WHERE JUDGES AND THEY STATED
PREFERRED THE DISCRETION OF
DECIDING INDIVIDUALLY VERSUS A
MANDATORY.
REQUIREMENT FOR THE TECHNICIAN
Là.
BUT WE HAVE THIRTY TWO OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE GONE THIS
DIRECTION AND THEY HAVE IT
MANDATORY FOR ALL OFFENSES SO IF
IF THEY FOUND.
I WOULD HAVE EXPECTED IF THEY
THERE WAS A BETTER WAY THEY
WOULD HAVE A DEVELOPMENT AT THE
TIME BUT I DON'T THE THE WORDING.
THE DMV REPORTS ALSO SHOWED A
STRAW INCLUDING A STRONG AND
RELIABLE ASSOCIATION BETWEEN AYE
ID'S FOR FIRST TIME OFFENDERS
AND REDUCE DO YOU WHY.
I'M QUOTING THAT.
SO I THINK THAT SOMEONE IN.
IS NOT CONCLUSIVE THAT IT DID
NOT HELP AS WE CAN SEE IT DID
SHOW STRONG RELIABLE ASSOCIATION
WITH THE REDUCTION.
AND HOW WOULD THAT NUMBER IS
WHETHER IT'S TEN FIFTEEN A
HUNDRED PEOPLE THERE IF IT'S 10%
OF THOSE THOUSAND THE WORKING.
LIVE THAT SIGNIFICANT IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN ANOTHER LEVEL
THAT WAS RAISED IN TERMS OF THEY
ALSO MADE IT MADE COMMENTS IN
THE ACCIDENTS WERE NOT RUDE OR
IN THOSE COUNTIES WITH THE PILOT
PROGRAM THERE WAS AN INCREASE OF
ACCIDENTS IN THOSE IN THOSE
PILOTS WELL.
IT DIDN'T TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION AT ALL THE MILES
DRIVEN AND HIS CERTAINLY IF IN
THOSE COUNTIES IT.
A LOT MORE MILES DRIVEN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THAN SOME OF THE
OTHER COUNTIES THAT WE HAVE IN
THE STATE IN THOSE MILES MORE
YOU DRIVE THE MORE ACTION SURE
GOING TO BE INVOLVED IN.
SO THE I I DON'T SEE THAT THE
THE STUDY THE PILOT WAS IT
SHOULD CERTAINLY SHOWED LAST
YEAR.
ANOTHER.
AND CONCLUSIVE ENOUGH FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO VOTE SEVEN ZERO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS SEVEN ZERO
ON THE FLORIDA VOTE THIRTY NINE
ZERO WITH THE WAY IT WAS
ORIGINALLY -- WRITTEN AND THE
WAY IT IS TODAY THAT AMENDMENT
CAME AT THE END AND STILL
WITHOUT.
A CLEAR IDENTIFICATION OF THAT
SO I DON'T KNOW IF.
THE STUDY IS NOT.
THE STUDY THAT WAS DONE BY THE
DMV IS NOT CONCLUSIVE IN
DETERMINING THAT THERE'S IT AND
IT DOES SHOW THAT IT DID REDUCE
RECIDIVISM.
THAT THAT TO ME IS THE KEY
[inaudible]
AND FOLLOWING A LINE OF
QUESTIONING FROM MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CHINA BARBER -- AS RELATES
TO FIRST TIME OFFENDERS -- SHE
USED THE TERM.
A COME TO JESUS MOMENT I THINK
IT'S OF SOBERING MOMENT.
FOR THE FRIENDS THAT I'VE HAD
THAT HAVE BEEN ARRESTED.
FOR THE FIRST TIME DIEM BE.
THEY DON'T OUR A DR IMPAIRED
ANYMORE A WHAT IT WAS A SOBERING
AWAKING EXPERIENCE FOR THEM.
AND NOW WHAT TNC MOST OF THEM
THAT SAY HEY NOW THEY'RE GOING
ON IN THERE AND HAVE A DRINK
THEY DON'T DRIVING.
THEY TAKE.
KERR SERVICES SO THAT TO GROWING --
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO NO I'M
GONNA GO OUT I'M ABSENT COCKTAIL
NO MATTER HOW MANY I'M GONNA
TAKE KERR SURE SO -- I I JUST.
IF THE SHIP WITH AN ATTITUDE AND
AND I AND I AND I KNOW WHAT
PERSON FROM THE FOLKS WELL I
TALKED TO THE TO I DON'T DRIVE
ANYMORE.
IF I HAVE A DRINK.
THE BUT THIS THIS THERE ISN'T
JUST QUOTED CHAU 30% A THIRD A
THIRD [inaudible]
DO.
THE PEOPLE YOU KNOW ARE THE TWO
THIRDS OF TO HE'S JUST GOING TO
HAVE TO WAIT AND IF THAT
THURSDAY DOES.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
AND IF THEY DO NOT PUT ANA
IGNITION INTERLOCK DEVICE AFTER
THEY'RE CONVICTED.
THEY HAVE A YEAR OF LICENSE
SUSPENSION WHERE THEY'RE GOING
TO BE -- THEY WOULD HAVE TO GET
A RESTRICTED LICENSE.
SO THAT THAT ARTIST OF IN THERE
THAT'S THAT'S THE OTHER PENALTY
THAT THEY WILL HAVE RATHER THAN
THAT.
AND I KNOW YOU WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE COST AND AS WE SPOKE
YESTERDAY BECAUSE OF THE SLIDING
PAY SCHEDULE AND IF THERE IS A
PROBLEM THAT -- WAS WAS
MENTIONED -- RELATED TO THE
COMPANY'S DOING WHAT THEY
COMMITTED TO DOING OUR PART OF
THE AGREEMENT IS THEN WE WILL
MAKE SURE THAT AND THERE IS
ENFORCEMENT -- ASPECTS TO THE
BILL BUT THE COST COULD BE NO
MORE THAN -- SEVEN DOLLARS A
YEAR AND INSTALLATION COULD BE
NO MORE THAN TEN TWELVE DOLLARS
FOR THE PRICE I MEAN SEVEN
DOLLARS A MONTH AND TWELVE
DOLLARS FOR INSTALLATION -- SO
THIS GLIDING SCALE DOES
ACCOMMODATE THAT FOR THOSE THAT --
THE CAMPUS THAT SECOND DO YOU
EYES A LOT MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
SEVEN DOLLARS A MONTH AND WE'RE
THESE COMPANIES AND INSTALLERS
JUST ONE COMPANY OR MULTIPLE GUN
MOTOR.
COMPANY TO THE SERVICE
[inaudible]
IN DIFFERENT [inaudible]
AT A ARE LISTED ON THE DMV
WEBSITE.
AND THEN IT'S APPROVED.
RATE THEM MISTER HERNANDEZ I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE AN ANSWER FOR
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
EVERYTHING MISTER CHAIR -- SO I
PULLED UP THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
DO YOU AYE STATISTICS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT MOTOR
VEHICLES -- AND IT SHOWS THAT AS
I INDICATED ON DURING THE AFTER
THE FIRST YEAR.
OF ISSUE AYE OFFENSE -- THE
RECIDIVISM RATE IS BETWEEN FOUR
AND 5% -- FOR THAT'S THE ROUTE
REPEAT AND THEN AFTER ABOUT FOUR
YEARS AGO IS UP TO ABOUT 15% NOW
THIS COVERS THE PERIOD.
OF OFFENDERS FOR TWEEN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND SO THAT
WAS BEFORE SOME OF STRONGER DO
YOU I LAWS WERE IN PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE INDICATORS OF
THAT THE RECIDIVISM.
RATE IS ACTUALLY DECREASING
SUBSTANTIALLY.
IN CALIFORNIA SO -- ANYWAY I
POINT YOU TO THAT REPORTS TO
HONOR PAGES BUT IF YOU LOOK AT I
BELIEVE PAGE -- FIFTY FIFTY FIVE
SOME AROUND THERE IT HAS OF
STATISTICS TAKE A LOOK AT IT --
BUT THAT'S WHAT IT IS FOR THE
FIRST FOUR YEARS ABOUT 5% 425%
THE FIRST YEAR.
AND THEN IT GOES UP TO ABOUT 15%
OF ABOUT FOUR YEAR FORTY FIVE
YEAR PERIOD -- CELLS ALSO BEFORE
THE RAPID EXPANSION OF UBER AND
LEFT FLASHES ABSOLUTELY AND ALSO
BEFORE SOME OF THE STRONGER DO I
LAWS THAT HAVE BEEN PASSED OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS IN Q.
INCLUDING THE PILOT PRO.
PROGRAM SO OTHERS.
PIC RESURGENT RESTRICT THIS
SENATOR WINNER DID YOU HAVE.
YES NO QUESTION.
I THANK YOU A SURVEYS CHAIR ON A
MAP AND SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL
AND I THINK I HAD ASKED TO BE A
CO AUTHOR SO WELCOME ON AT SOME
POINT.
AND OF THOSE BEING AMENDED --
AND I AND I TALKED ABOUT THIS
ACTUALLY IN THE G. OKAY MAYBE
FOR OF NEVER TALKED ABOUT IN
THIS COMMITTEE THAT WHEN I WAS
SIX YEARS OLD -- IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX ALL DATE MYSELF -- A
OP MY AUNTS MY FATHER'S ONLY --
A SIBLING WAS ARE KILLED BY A
DRUNK DRIVER -- IN NEW JERSEY.
AND IT WAS -- I WAS VERY YOUNG
AT THE TIME BUT I STILL -- WILL
NEVER FORGET AT HER.
FUNERAL MY GRANDMOTHER.
YOU'RE JUST BREAKING DOWN
COLLAPSING AT THE GRAVE SITE --
FOR THE LOSS OF HER -- OLD HER
OLDEST -- AND IT -- IMPACTED OUR
FAMILY PERMANENTLY -- AND THE
TRAGEDY WAS ESPECIALLY ON TOP OF
THAT HORRIFIC TRAGEDY THE EXTRA
TRAGEDY.
WAS A BACKGROUND THE LAWS.
ON ARE PRETTY EYES WERE JUST A
PATHETIC AND THE THE GUY WHO DID
THIS TO MY TO MY AUNT'S IN MY
FAMILY TO MY UNCLE TO MY COUSINS
MY FATHER TO MY GRANDMOTHER --
TO ME TO MY SISTER TO ALL OF US --
GOD BASICALLY A SLAP ON THE
WRIST AND HI AND SO WE'VE MADE A
LOT OF PROGRESS IN SAN AND THE
LAWS ARE A LOT TOUGHER NOW AND
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY I'M SURE HAVE.
HAD A I KNOW IT'S HAD A POSITIVE
IMPACT IN TERMS OF RECIDIVISM --
THE RIDE SCHERING -- CLEARLY ISA HELP IN GIVING PEOPLE OPTIONS --
BUT IT'S NOT EVERYTHING AND IF
WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL TOOL --
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO WE KNOW HAS.
HAS GOTTEN INTO A CAR.
AND AND ENGAGE IN DRUNK DRIVING
SAYS IS NOT TRYING TO BE
PRODUCTIVE ABOUT WHAT A RANDOM
PERSON WILL DO THIS IS ABOUT
SOMEONE WHO HAS ALREADY ENGAGE
AND DO YOU LIVE -- I'M PROBABLY
IF IF THE PERSON HAS ALREADY
BEEN ARRESTED.
THEN I'M GONNA GAS THAT PERSON
WAS PINE UP THE ONLY TIME THE
PERSON HAS GOTTEN INTO A CAR
DRUNK.
SO WE KNOW THAT THIS IS SOMEONE
WHO PRESENTS A RISK FACTOR AND
WE CAN TAKE AN ACTION.
THAT IS NOT.
YOU KNOW PUTTING SOMEONE IN JAIL
THEM THERE MAY BE A SEPARATE
THING BUT SO SOME THAT'S NOT
BEING PUNITIVE.
BUT IS BEING PROPHYLACTIC AND
ALLOWING THE PERSON TO DRIVE
THERE WERE NOT GOING TO JUST
TAKE AWAY YOUR YOU COULD JUST
TAKE AWAY THE LICENSE SO YOU CAN
NEVER DRIVE AGAIN AND IMPACTS
SOMEONE SCHOOL OR OR WORK OR
MORE SO WE'RE GONNA LET YOU
DRIVE.
WE'RE GOING TO GET YOU GOING TO
HAVE THAT PRIVILEGE.
BUT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO THIS
ONE THING -- I THINK IT'S
ACTUALLY A VERY IMPORTANT
TECHNOLOGY -- AND AND I I DON'T
SEE WHY WE WOULDN'T DO THAT SO I
FULLY SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER -- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS WIENER.
I WOULD LOVE TO BE SENATOR
SKINNER HEARD I THE MEDIA LET ME
LET ME TAKE THIS BEVERAGE.
SORRY CENTER WIENER MY APOLOGIES --
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS -- I HAVE A
FEW.
WERE QUICK WHEN CENTER HILL --
THE FIRST IS THE COST IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED A FEW TIMES.
WHAT IS A COST TO PUT IT?
BY AIDID FOR INSTALLATION IS
SEVENTY FIVE FOR OF TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS THE COST PER
MONTH IS -- ABOUT -- I THINK
IT'S THREE DOLLARS A DAY COULD
BE SO TO COULD BE ABOUT FIFTY TO
SEVENTY FIVE EIGHTY DOLLARS PER
PER MONTH. FOR THE SIX MONTHS
AND THEN THAT WOULD THAT COST IS
ON A SLIDING SCALE IF YOU ARE
FROM CAN FROM 1100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL UP.
THE COST IS 10% IF YOU'RE A 100%
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL UP
290% THERE IS A GRADUATION OF
COST ALL THE WAY UP TO THE FULL
RETAIL AND THAT IS ALL FUNDED BY
THE MANUFACTURERS OF THE OF THE
PRODUCT AT THE 4100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
A TO A LOCAL TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR A YOU'D
PAY 90% OF THE COST BUT JUST
SEVENTY FIVE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS TO INSTALL THE
LOWEST INCOME PERSON IS.
A STARK YOU I'M I'VE BEEN LAYS A
FAIR.
AND LETTING EVERYBODY JUST
TALKED BUT I THE CHAIR WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE.
THINGS GO THROUGH THE CHAIR SOLD.
THANK YOU -- YOU MENTIONED SIX
MONTHS.
YES THAT'S THE REQUIREMENT IN
THE SIX MONTHS CAN START.
THE MINUTE YOU GET ARRESTED
BECAUSE YOUR LICENSE IS TAKEN
AWAY FROM UNISYS BENDED LICENSE
SO IF YOU HAVE A SUSPENDED
LICENSE.
THIS ALLOWS YOU TO HAVE THAT
INSTALLED ON YOUR VEHICLE AND
YOU CAN START THAT SIX MONTH
CLOCK RIGHT THEN.
AND THAT ALLOWS YOU TO DO WHAT
YOU COULD MITCHELL WOULD HAVE TO
HAVE IT FOR SIX MONTHS WE DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE IT FOR SIX MONTHS
AND IT'S TAKEN IT'S AN ESSAY ON
IT.
OVER WITH A SECONDOFFENSE WOULD
BE ONE YEAR THEN WHAT IF YOU OWN
MULTIPLE CARS.
WITHIN YOU DON'T USE THE CAR
THAT HAS THE ID.
THEN.
AND THEN YOU'RE THEN YOU'RE
YOU'RE CAUGHT DRIVING.
UNDER THE INFLUENCE WHAT ARE THE
PENALTIES YOUR BREAKING THE LAW.
THE LOSS SAID YOU HAVE TO DRIVE
A VEHICLE WITH MY ID THAT SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MERRY OF THE
LAW SAYS YOU HAVE TO DRIVE A
VEHICLE WITH AN ID.
AND IF YOU DON'T BURKE BROUGH
BREAKING THE LAW IT WHAT IS THE
PENALTY WHILE THE PENALTY THE
JUDGE THAT RISK IS REVIEWING
YOUR CASE IN THAT HANDLES YOUR
YOUR YOUR CERTAIN CASE THAT'S
WHY THEY ALSO GET A READING WHEN
YOU DRIVE.
EVERY TIME YOU START THAT
VEHICLE BY BLOWING INTO IT THAT
IS RECORDED IN ITS RECALIBRATED
EVERY MONTH TO SEE EXACTLY HOW
YOUR WHAT YOUR BEHAVIOR HAS BEEN
OKAY OKAY. FOR THEY WOULD CATCH
YOU THE MEMBERSHIP YES OKAY
HOWEVER IT IS BUT IT IS A IT
DOES RECORD THAT.
AND IT'S REVIEW AND WE'RE HAVING
MAYBE ON THE FUTURE SELF DRIVING
TECHNOLOGIES SO IF YOU WERE TO
GET INTO A CAR THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE TO DRIVE WOULD YOU STILL
HAVE TO HAVE AN I ID.
I DO NOT DRIVE A SO I WOULD NOT
THINK YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN ID
OKAY THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS DO I HAVE A A MOTION
US SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- CEDAR
HILLS DID YOUR LAST POINT
CONFUSE ME A BIT -- SO THE SIX
MONTH CLOCK STARTS.
THE POINT AT WHICH YOUR LICENSE
IS SUSPENDED.
KIND OF WHAT'S THE VALUE OF THE
POINT IS.
A AN ADDITIONAL KIND OF CHECK ON
YOUR BEHAVIOR WHY WOULD YOU HAVE
THE CLOCK STARTS TICKING WHEN
I'M NOT EVEN ALLOWED TO DRIVE MY
CAR WELL YOU THE CLOCK STARTS
BECAUSE YOU'RE.
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO DRIVE IF YOU
HAVE AN ID INSTALLED YOU CAN
THEN DRIVE YOUR VEHICLES FOR
YOUR LICENSE IS NOT SUSPENDED.
YOU GET A SIX MONTH PERIOD WHERE
YOU CAN IN THIS IS THE CHALLENGE
WITH MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE U.
EYES THEY LOSE THEIR LICENSE BUT
THEY STILL HAVE TO GO TO WORK
FOR I STILL HAVE TO TAKE THEIR
KIDS.
SO THIS WOULD THEN BECOME IN
LIEU OF LOSS OF LIFE IS FOR A
THREE MONTH PERIOD IS THIS THIS
WOULD SATISFY THAT REQUIREMENT --
AND YOU ARE ALLOWED TO CONTINUE
YOUR BUSINESS AND AND DO THINGS
AND THE CLOCK TICKS AND AFTER
THAT SIX MONTHS YOU'RE YOU'VE
COMPLETED THAT PART OF WHATEVER
PUNISHMENT THE COURTS HAVE
DETERMINED.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO I HAVE A MOTION.
CENTER MORALE MAKES A MOTION --
MADAM SECRETARY WHEN WE TAKE A
ROLL.
MOTION IS THE PASTOR PROBES
SKINNER.
WARLOCK HI MORE LIKE AYE
BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
I WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
IT WAS THE VOTE IS.
OKAY THE POLICE FORCE ZERO AND
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SENATORS.
HILL THANK YOU MA'AM -- CENTER
WITH.
NIELSEN HAS BEEN PATIENTLY
WAITING.
OKAY.
OKAY HE LEFT -- THIS. TWO WEEKS
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE TO PRESENT
AT THIS POINT.
SENATOR NIELSEN YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THIS WOULD BE.
FOR SB [inaudible] FOUR TWO NINE
FORTY NINE THE LAUNDRY OKAY
[inaudible] FORTY THE GERMAN
MEMBERS.
THIS ALLOWS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE BIG [inaudible]
CONTACTING.
I. N. S..
IN ORDER [inaudible]
TO THAT DEFY.
AND WHEN AN UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANT HAS BEEN CONVICTED OF
DO YOU HI.
NOW THIS IS A VERY SPECIFIC
[inaudible]
AND NARAL [inaudible]
OPPORTUNITY.
IT IS CONSISTENT.
WITH SENATE BILL. FORTY TWO THAT
WAS CARRIED.
BY OUR FORMER PRO TEM
[inaudible]
AND THAT.
LEGISLATION LIMITED.
THE ABILITY.
THE ONE FORTUNATE TO CONTACT I
AN S..
IN MANY INSTANCES NOW WHY WOULD
WE WANT TO BE.
AN EXCEPTION IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE [inaudible]
IT.
CAME JUST COMES TO MIND
[inaudible]
THAT.
AS THIS LONG HEARING PROCEEDED
HERE JUST BEFORE [inaudible]
HOUSE SERIOUS.
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE
[inaudible]
CAN BE.
IN A DECEMBER.
A YEAR AGO [inaudible]
OFFICER SAYING.
LOST HIS LIFE. FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO HAD AN OUTSTANDING WARRANT.
FOR HIS ARREST.
RELATED TO THE I. D. Y. CHARGE.
HE HAD A PRIOR D. Y..
AND IN COLLUDED HAVE PHYSICAL
INJURY. TO ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL.
I CAN'T ABSOLUTELY SAY THAT THIS.
WOULD HAVE SAVED.
OFFICE THINGS LIVE.
BUT THE POINT IS THAT COULD HAVE.
WITH THE OUTSTANDING WARRANT.
HE COULD HAVE BEEN SUBJECTED TO
PROSECUTION [inaudible]
INDOOR DEPORTATION.
SO I DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE'RE
SINGLING ANYTHING OUT AND AND
THE AUTHOR OF THAT LEGISLATION.
IN FACT SAID IN THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT.
IF THERE WERE ACTIVE WARRANTS ON
THIS INDIVIDUAL.
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WERE NOT
STOP BY SB FIFTY FOUR FROM
REPORTING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TWO
I AN S. [inaudible]
WHEN CONDITIONS?
AS THOSE EXIST.
AND THE GOVERNOR WHO SIGNED THAT
LEGISLATION [inaudible]
ALSO FIND.
THE POLICE TO THE SHERIFF.
COULD HAVE TOLD IMMIGRATION.
SERVICE ABOUT THIS INDIVIDUAL.
THAT HE AD BEEN ARRESTED AND
ACTUALLY CONVICTED TWICE OF THE
WHY.
AND THERE WAS A WARRANT. FOR HIS
ARREST.
SO I WILL ARGUE THAT THIS IS
TOTALLY CONSISTENT WITH OUR
CURRENT LEGISLATION.
BUT IT DOES PROVIDE.
THE STATUTORY TOOL. FOR ONE
FORTUNATE. TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY INDIVIDUALS.
THE COULD BE A DANGER.
SIMPLY PUT THAT'S THE BILL.
AND I DID NOT BRING ANY
WITNESSES I JUST SUBMIT THE BILL
FOR THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
AND IN HOPES THAT JILL.
HAVING BEEN REPORTED.
THAT HE HAS THESE CONDITIONS
THAT IS LIFE.
THESE CONVICTIONS [inaudible]
AND REMAINS [inaudible]
THE DANGER.
THAT'S I SUBMIT THE BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON -- WHY
YOU DID NOT BRING WITNESSES LET
ME SEE IF THERE IS ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
RIGHT SEEING NONE LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE -- IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
I AND GRAHAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
SB FIFTY FOUR WAS ENACTED
BECAUSE ENTANGLEMENT OF LOCAL
PUBLIC SAFETY DOLLARS AND WITH
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION UNDERMINED
THE PUBLIC CONFIDENCE AND
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES SAFETY AND
WELL BEING.
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS PAID A HIGH
PRICE WHEN WE PARTICIPATED IN
ISIS CONTROVERSIAL ON FAILED
SECURED COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
ACROSS THE STATE SIXTY FIVE
MILLION ANNUALLY AND HAD LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
DETAINING AND TRANSFER IN PEOPLE
TO ICE.
SB FIFTY SB THIS BILL UNDERMINES
THE BALANCE STRUCK BY SB FIFTY
FOUR WHICH EXEMPTED FOR
PROTECTIONS CERTAIN QUALIFYING
CONVICTIONS. FOR EXAMPLEFELONY
DO YOU EYES WERE INCLUDED IN
THIS LIST OF EXEMPTIONS.
BUT THIS BILL ADDS AND
MISDEMEANOR DERIVE FENCES TO THE
LIST OF EXEMPTIONS AND PLACES
BOTH TYPES OF DIY IS OUTSIDE THE
TIME RESTRICTIONS OF CURRENT LAW.
AS SUCH THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
COOPERATION BASED ON DECADES OLD
CONVICTIONS WHICH DO NOT REFLECT
A PERSON'S REHABILITATION OR
CHANGE LIFE CIRCUMSTANCES.
THIS DOES NOT ALIGN WITH
CALIFORNIA'S COMMONSENSE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMS.
IT ALSO INJECTS UNNECESSARY
CONFUSION INTO A HIGHLY
TECHNICAL AREA OF LAW.
THE TERM USED IN THE BILL
COOPERATION IS BROAD FAKE AN
UNDEFINED MESSAGE COULD RESULT
IN COOPERATION.
BEYOND WHAT IS AUTHORIZED BY
CURRENT LAW.
IT ALSO TIES COOPERATION TO A
PERSON UNLAWFUL PRESENCE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THIS IS A HIGHLY COMPLEX AREA OF
LAW.
AND OFFICERS RIGHT NOW UNDER
CURRENT LAW ARE BARRED FROM
ENQUIRING ABOUT A PERSON'S
IMMIGRATION STATUS THIS WAS PUT
INTO LAW BECAUSE BEFORE THIS
TOOK PLACE.
RACIAL PROFILING AN ACCURATE
ASSESSMENTS AND HARASSMENT OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR WARRIOR
CONDUCTED AS A RESULT OF
PEOPLE'S PERCEIVED IMMIGRATION
STATUS FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BECAUSE RESPONSE WHICH ARE THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
CAN YOU TAKE A WITH PEOPLE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG OPPOSITION.
UNDER A RIVER WITH A CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
STRONG OPPOSITION.
PLEASE THE TRUTH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG OPPOSITION.
EDDIE CARMONA WHERE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIANS ARE CRIMINAL ACT IN
STRONG OPPOSITION.
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSESIN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEING NINE LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ISCUSSION ON THE
PART OF ANY -- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
I'M.
CENTER NIELSEN I THINK THAT --
HAS ALREADY BEEN -- BROUGHT OUT
IS THAT SB.
FIFTY FOUR ALLOWS LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO INTERACT WITH
THEIR IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES
RELATED TO FELONY DE WEISS -- SO
THIS BILL.
IS.
THIS BILL PRIMARILY -- ONE COULD
SAY AMENDS SB FIFTY FOUR OR AT
LEAST -- INTERFERES WITH WHAT
WAS APPROVED IN SB.
FIFTY FOUR AND AS THIS AS A
PERSON THAT SUPPORTED THAT BILL
WHICH IS NOW LAW -- I M..
NOT COMFORTABLE RECOMMENDING A
FIVE VOTE ON YOUR BILL.
BECAUSE I FEEL THAT IT IS NOT
NECESSARY THAT WE SB.
FIFTY FOUR IS BY ITS NATURE
LIMITED DUE TO CERTAIN FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES THAT THE STATE
CANNOT INTERFERE WITH AND
PRIMARILY WHAT THE STATE DID IN.
IN THE APPROVING SB FIFTY FOUR
IS BSICALLY.
ENCOURAGE OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
NOT VOLUNTARILY COOPERATE.
WITH IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES AND
MINOR OFFENSES SO -- I A I'M NOT
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TO
INITIATIVE.
ON IN IF THERE IS ANY OTHER
COMMENT OR QUESTION CENTER
TOMORROW.
RIGHT SO WE HAVE.
A MOTION SENATOR JACKSON YEAH
CHEST CHESTER AN OBSERVATION
HERE -- I SURE THE THE SURE IS
CONCERNED.
BUT WE HAVE A GRAHAM NOW THAT IS
ACTUALLY.
WITHOUT ANY LEADERSHIP THAT IS
CHAOTIC AND RUNNING AMOK DHS IS
WITHOUT A SECRETARY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ICE DIRECTOR OF FEMA
DIRECTOR SECRET SERVICE DIRECTOR
INSPECTOR GENERAL DIRECTOR.
I MEAN HOW IN THE WORLD CAN WE
EVER EXPECT TO HAVE ANY KIND OF
COHESIVENESS -- IN THIS THE HOW
WE DEAL.
WITH OF PEOPLE WHO ARGUABLY ARE
HERE ILLEGALLY WHEN THERE'S NO
ONE AT THE HELM.
AND INTEREST ABSOLUTELY ASTOUNDS
ME.
THE CHAOS THAT THAT EXISTS NOW
IN THIS PROGRAM FEDERALLY AND IN
ANY OTHER ND FOR THAT REASON
ALONE YOUR RESPECTIVE OF WHERE
WE ARE -- I WOULD CERTAINLY NOT
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS THERE IS
NO THERE THERE THERE'S NO
LEADERSHIP IT IS CHAOS IT'S LIKE
A BANANA REPUBLIC WHEN IT COMES
TO THESE SSUES SO.
I APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
A DRUNK DRIVING BUT UNTIL WE
HAVE SOME.
GROWN UPS IN THE ROOM -- I
CERTAINLY COULD IMAGINE
SUPPORTING THIS KIND OF AN
EFFORT.
AND THE JUST WANTED TO SHARE
THAT WITH THE JUST ASTONISHING
THAT THERE'S NO LEADERSHIP
ANYWHERE IN THIS ISSUE -- ONE
MOMENT SIR.
ANYONE ELSE.
SENATOR NIELSEN WELL I WOULD
JUST WAY IN PERSON MET AGAIN I
BELIEVE THAT YOU COULD DO THIS
AS YOUR CLOTHES SINCE I DON'T
SEE EITHER OF THOSE TO DO THAT.
THE I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH SB.
FIFTY FOUR AS STATED.
BY THE AUTHOR.
AND IT IS AND THE FIRM'S ANOTHER.
TO AND PUTS THE SPOTLIGHT.
ON THIS PARTICULAR.
TYPE OF AND IT DIDN'T
INDIVIDUALS WITH THIS TYPE OF
HISTORY [inaudible]
AND IT WAS FAR AS MANY YEARS AGO.
SO THAT MEANS THAT.
YOU'VE DONE SOMETHING WHATEVER.
AND YOUR HONOR ON TEN YEARS PASS.
DOES NINE DOESN'T OBVIATE.
THAT BEHAVIOR.
AND IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
YOU DIDN'T COMMIT.
FUTURE CRIMES WE DID NOT GOT.
APPREHENDED.
AND THIS IS ABOUT COOPERATION
FOR THE PURPOSE OF APPREHENDING.
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
THAT'S ON THE RECORD.
AND THAT DOES INDICATE INDICATE
[inaudible]
FUTURE DANGERS.
I WOULD ASK.
BUT I WILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN SO I
WILL ASK FOR THE ROLL CALL THAT
ALSO NOTE -- WE'RE NOT HEARING
YOUR OTHER TWO BILLS BECAUSE
THEY'RE ON CONSENT.
OKAY SO THIS IS THE ONLY ONE
THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE FORMAL
HEARING ON FAT AND HAPPY THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO HAVE YOUR OTHER TWO
BILLS ON CONSENT TODAY -- AND
LET'S DO A ROLL CALL. FIFTY
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
NOPE SKINNER NOW MORE LOCK.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD.
JACKSON NO JACKSON NO MITCHELL.
MITCHELL NOW MORALE.
HI WELL I WIENER WIENER NO.
THANK YOU. THIRTY THE I ACCEPT
THE MEMBERS WHO SUGGESTED TO THE
BILLS THAT ARE ON CONSENT.
THANKS SO MAKING FACTORY OKAY
GREAT SO THAT BILL IS -- FAILS
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR OUR
MISSING MEMBERS SO THEY CAN OUT
ON AND WE WILL.
NOW -- HOPEFULLY A SENATOR MONEY
WILL BE HERE ANY MINUTE WE CAN
START THAT.
BILL.
WHAT'S TAKE A MOTION ON CONSENT
[inaudible]
FOUNDER.
EXCELLENT SO WE'LL HAVE A ROLL
CALL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SKINNER BY SKINNER AYE MOORLACH
LIKE MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
JACKSON JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
MITCHELL AYE MORALE [inaudible]
WIENER.
I'VE BEEN HERE I'VE.
RIGHT CONSENT CALENDAR WILL BE
HELD OPENED FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
HAD TO BUT IT HAS SUFFICIENT
VOTES AT THE MOMENT.
AND WE ARE WAITING FOR AN AUTHOR.
DOES THAT.
MEAN FOR BILL.
WE COULD REPLACE WAS WORKING
WITH A I WANT TO GO AHEAD.
GO AHEAD CENTER MITCHELL.
THIS IS A ITEM EIGHTEEN SB.
SEVEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES IN HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB SEVEN
SIXTEEN WHICH WILL TAKE A
CORRECTIVE STEP TOWARDS ENSURING
THAT INCARCERATED YOUTH.
WHO ALREADY HOLD A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA HAVE ACCESS TO A COLLEGE
EDUCATION OR CAREER VOCATIONAL
TRAINING?
A QUALITY EDUCATION HAS THE
POWER TO RE DIRECT THE LIVES OF
ANY YOUNG PERSON ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO'VE BEEN TOUCHED BY THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
EDUCATION VOCATIONAL TRAINING
DEVELOPED OCCUPATIONAL SKILLS
LEAVES THE PRODUCTIVE CAREER
PATHS WHICH IN TURN REDUCES
RECIDIVISM AND FUTURE
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA LAW DOES
NOT REQUIRE JUVENILE FACILITIES
PROVIDE POST SECONDARY PROGRAMS
FOR THESE USED AND THAT'S THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL.
STATUTES ONLY REQUIRES THAT THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
DIVISION OF JUVENILE FACILITIES
TO PROVIDE A FULL HIGH SCHOOL
CURRICULUM TO YOUTH AND KATHY
WHO HAVE NOT COMPLETED HIGH
SCHOOL.
ALTHOUGH THERE'S NO STATUTORY
OBLIGATION FOR C. WITH PROVIDE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION PROGRAM
FOR HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES IN
CUSTODY.
STATE REGULATIONS DO REQUIRE
COUNTY PROBATION TO ENSURE THAT
ALL YOU THEIR FACILITIES ARE
TREATED EQUALLY WITH REGARD TO
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
ADDITIONALLY THE USE BILL OF
RIGHTS STATES THAT YOUTH IN DJ
AT THE STILL OF THESE HAVE THE
RIGHT. TO RECEIVE A QUALITY
EDUCATION.
THE YOU BILL OF RIGHTS DOES NOT
PLACE AN AGE OF GRADE LEVEL
LIMITATION ON THESE RIGHTS WE
ARE AWARE OF THE CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL AND ARE HAVING ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH INVESTED
PARTIES. TO ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS RAISED -- IN THE
ANALYSIS VERY BRIEFLY THEY TALK
ABOUT THE SCOPE OF THE LANGUAGE
BECAUSE THE BILL SAYS A FULL
ARRAY OF SERVICES WE GET THAT
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE MY GOAL IS
FOR THIS BILL. TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN OFFERING -- AT A RATE OF OF
ACADEMIC OR JOB READINESS
CLASSES THAT GOVERNMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE KENNEDY PROVIDES
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM TO GET TO SOME
LANGUAGE THAT WE THINK WILL.
MEET THE GOAL OF THE BILL BUT
ALSO BE REALISTIC.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE THE TOOLS
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE NEED IN ORDER
TO BECOME SUCCESSFUL AND CAN
TRULY MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY
UPON THEIR RELEASE WITH ME TODAY
I HAVE DANIELLE KASEY SO
COMPOSTED AT THE COLLEGE OF SAN
MATTEO.
AND LUCY CARTER POLICY ADVOCATE
AT THE USE LAWCENTER.
THANK YOU WITNESSES PLEASE
PROCEED.
HELLO MY NAME IS DANIEL CARCILLO
SO CUMPLE I'M A FORM A CURSORY
STUDENT -- AT THE COLLEGE OF SAN
MATTEO.
I SPENT A LOT OF MY TEENAGE
YEARS INCARCERATED WHEN I WAS
INCARCERATED I LEARNED THE VALUE
OF EDUCATION WHETHER IT WAS HIGH
SCHOOL PURSUING MY GT OR SIMPLY
LEARNING BASIC SKILLS.
WHEN I WAS AT THE BOYS RANCH I
RECEIVED MY GED I WAS?
SIXTEEN EARLY AFTER I TURNED
SEVENTEEN I WAS FINISHING UP MY
SENTENCE IN THE JUVENILE HALL.
MOST OF MY DAYS DURING THOSE
SEVEN TO EIGHT MONTHS WERE SPENT
NOT LOOKING FOR TOO MUCH.
I FEEL LIKE THAT TIME COULD HAVE
BEEN SPENT CONTINUING MY
EDUCATION AND PREPARING ME -- TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH MY LIFE WHEN I
GOT OUT.
INSTEAD I GOT OUT A LITTLE
BEFORE MY EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY --
AND I WAS UNPREPARED FOR THE
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE AND NOT READY
FOR THE TRANSITION BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY.
I HADN'T GAINED ANY SKILLS OR
KNOWLEDGE OF WAS IN THE HALL.
NOW I AM PART OF PROJECT CHANGE
WHICH DOES OFFER COLLEGE COURSES
IN JUVENILE HALL AND OF US ALSO
TUTORED -- USED TO HAVE -- TOOK
IN OUR COLLEGE CLASSES INSIDE
THE JUVENILE HALL AFTER MY
RELEASE -- WITH SB SEVEN SIXTEEN
EVERY HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATE IN
CUSTODY WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
COLLEGE CLASSES TO HELP PAVE
THEIR PATH TO SUCCESS AND FOR
THIS REASON TO ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITH.
HI AND LUCY SELSEY BILL CARTER
IN THE POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE
YOUTH LAWCENTER.
YOU'VE HEARD MR CASSIE OF A
COMPOST HAS TO MONEY.
ABOUT THE SEVEN TO EIGHT MONTHS
THAT HE SPENT IN CUSTODY WITH
NOTHING TO DO ACADEMICALLY WITH
THE COMPLETED HIGH SCHOOL G. ET.
HIS EXPERIENCE IS NOT UNIQUE.
THERE'S A GROWING PERCENTAGE OF
YOUTH IN CUSTODY IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES WHO HAVE THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMAS OR EQUIVALENCY.
AB TWENTY THREE OH SIX WHICH
BECAME LAW ON TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN ALLOWS YOUTH WITH
JUVENILE JUSTICE EXPERIENCE. TO
COMPLETE THEIR DIPLOMA WHEN THEY
MEET THE STATE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS. FOR GRADUATION THE
PASSAGE OF THIS LAWS RESULTING
IN MORE AND MORE YOUTH IN
CUSTODY WHO HAVE THEIR DIPLOMAS
BUT NO ACCESS TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
THE PERCENTAGE IS AS HIGH AS 50%
OR MORE IN THE STATE RUN
FACILITIES WE HEAR ANECDOTALLY
THAT IS 10215% IN SOME COUNTY
FACILITIES BUT I RECENTLY
VISITED.
ONE WHERE FIVE OF THE EIGHTEEN
YOUTH IN CUSTODY HAD THEIR
DIPLOMAS AND NO EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING FOR THEM.
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THERE
ARE FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAVE OR ARE DEVELOPING.
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
PROGRAMS FOR YOUTH IN CUSTODY.
THESE MODEL PROGRAMS ARE FOUNDED
ON CLOSE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
PROBATION.
AND OR THE DJJ AND THE HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS OFFERING
THE AND THEY OFFER ONSITE AND
ONLINE CLASSES AND THEY FIGURED
OUT HOW TO DO THIS SAFELY USING
TECHNOLOGY.
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE WANT TO
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO RE
ENVISION THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FUTURES.
BY SUPPORTING UP SENATE BILL
SEVEN ONE SIX YOU'RE HELPING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE YOUTH HAVE
ACCESS TO RIGOROUS POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES TO DO
JUST THAT.
THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES A
PROVISION THAT ENSURES THAT
YOUTH WERE STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL.
CAN ALSO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
PROGRAMMING THROUGH CONCURRENT
ENROLLMENT FOR THESE REASONS THE
YOUTH LAWCENTER ASKS FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RATHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BENCHER MEMBERS A RAINY PERRY
WITH PARK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD ORNING CAM STONE STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS IN
SUPPORT.
MORNING MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
NOT RIGHT THE END OF OUR
ANALYSIS INDICATED THERE WERE.
THERE WAS NO FILED OPPOSITION
THOUGH AS THE SENATOR.
UNDER THE AUTHOR NOTED.
THERE ARE -- WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE DEFINITION OF THE
SERVICES PROVIDED BUT AS YOU.
NOTED CENTER MITCHELL YOU'RE
GOING TO BE WORKING ON THAT
BECAUSE CLEARLY -- THERE WILL BE
AN ISSUE IN APPROACH WHERE THE
BILL WOULD GO NEXT IF IT'S
SUCCESSFUL HERE -- I AM IN SORT.
SORRY EDUCATION AND DOUBLE FIRST
RIGHT DOUBLE REFERRED POT BUT
THEN IT WILL GO TO APPROACH --
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FOR MANY OTHER MEMBERS.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
CENTER MORLOCK LET'S DO A ARE.
YOU MAY CLOSE INDIVIDUAL THANKS
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
RIGHT ASK FOR LIVE OUT.
AND THEN I WILL THANK YOU FOR
THE AYE BUT WE'LL DO A ROLL CALL
AND SEE IF YOU GET THOSE THINGS
ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE HERE WE GET
THOSE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
ADD.
SKINNER.
HI SKINNER AYE MOORLACH R. WERE
LIKE I BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE
MOREAU.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
I WILL KEEP IT OPEN -- BUT IT'S
LOOKING GOOD RIGHT NOW.
ACTUALLY WE NOW HAVE SENATOR
MONEY THANK YOU FOR WAITING.
AND THIS IS ITEM -- TWELVE SB.
FOUR THREE THREE I AM.
PROUD OF HIM.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I HAVE A COUPLE OF
WITNESSES GETTING SITUATED HERE
BUT I WILL BEGIN -- I'M HERE
TODAY 2% SENATE BILL FOUR THREE
THREE WHICH WILL ESTABLISH A
THREE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM FOR
THREE TO FIVE COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA. TO CREATE OFFICES OF
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT IN DIVERSION.
THESE OFFICES WILL BE MODELED IN
PART AFTER LOS ANGELES COUNTY'S
NEWLY CREATED OFFICE OF YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT AND DIVERSION.
AND ALLOW PARTICIPATING COUNTIES
TO EXPLORE PUBLIC HEALTH
CENTERED APPROACHES TO YOUTH
JUSTICE ISSUES.
WHEN YOU THINK CALIFORNIA
ARRESTED FOR LOW LEVEL OFFENSES
IN FORCE INTO INVOLVEMENT WITH
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM?
THEY'RE OFTEN INFLICTED WITH
FURTHER HARM IN AN INCREASED
RISK OF RECIDIVISM.
JUSTICE INVOLVED YOUTH ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY CHILDREN OF
COLOR.
FOSTER CHILDREN AND YOUTH WHO
IDENTIFY AS LGBT Q. AND ARE
OFTEN IN OFTEN COME FROM
BACKGROUNDS WHERE THEY'VE BEEN
EXPOSED TO ABUSE ABANDONMENT
NEGLECT TRAUMA AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
THAT INFLUENCE THEIR BEHAVIOR.
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS NOT
PREPARED OR DESIGNED TO ADDRESS
THESE HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENT
ISSUES IN RESEARCH RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN.
THAT A RIMINOLOGICAL APPROACH
TO DEALING WITH JUSTICE INVOLVED
YOUTH TYPICALLY DOES NOTHING TO
ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING ISSUES.
THAT DRIVE A YOUNG PERSON TO
OFFEND.
SB FOUR THREE THREE WILL ALLOW
MORE NO MORE THAN FIVE
INTERESTED PILOT COUNTIES TO
BEGIN TO ADDRESS THESE YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT ISSUES.
THROUGH TRAUMA INFORMED
CULTURALLY RELEVANT PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT ARE AGE
APPROPRIATE AND THAT EMPHASIZE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
THE PILOT OFFICES OF YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT VERSION WILL ACT AS
THE CENTRAL POINT OF
COORDINATION FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND COUNTY AGENCIES AND WILL
WORK TO BLAND EXISTING COUNTY
HEALTH SERVICES.
AND COMMUNITY BASED INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS TO BETTER ADDRESS THE
EFFECTS OF TRAUMA SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
ON JUSTICE INVOLVED USE.
MEMBERS THIS MEASURE IS A
VOLUNTARY AND TIME LIMITED PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WILL ALLOW A
HANDFUL OF COUNTIES TO EXPLORE
NEW PATHWAYS IN ADDRESSING YOUTH
JUSTICE ISSUES THROUGH A PUBLIC
HEALTH LANDS.
ACID YOU JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
OUR JUSTICE INVOLVED YOUTH.
WITH COUNSELING AND SERVICES
INSTEAD OF HAND CUFFS IN JAIL
CELLS.
IN -- CHEN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND MADAM CHAIR
WITH YOUR PERMISSION WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I HAVE TWO IN ONE ON STAND BY
CERTAINLY.
PROCEED WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OF MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK.
MY NAME IS AMY COHEN I AM HUNGRY
TRAIN CHILD PSYCHIATRIST WITH
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
IN COMMUNITY PSYCHIATRY.
TREATING FAMILIES IN CHILDREN IN
HIGHLY STRESSED INFORMATICS
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE CHILDREN I TREAT MOST OFTEN
PRESENT WITH PROBLEMS OF
BEHAVIOR BEHAVIOR SOMETIMES
DANGEROUS TO THEMSELVES AND
OTHERS.
I'VE ALSO SERVED AS LEAD
PSYCHIATRIST ALAMEDA COUNTY
JUVENILE HALL WHERE I CREATED A
CONSULTATION SERVICE FOR
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGES.
COLLABORATED WITH PROBATION
COLLEAGUES AND WORK DALY AND
DIRECTLY WITH HUNDREDS OF
INCARCERATED CHILDREN.
I'M HERE TO URGE YOU TO PASS SB.
FOUR THIRTY THREE TO ESTABLISH
ROBUST DIVERSION PROGRAMMING FOR
HIGH RISK CHILDREN AND YOUTH
WITH THE PURPOSE OF KEEPING THEM
OUT OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
PROGRAMMING WHICH WILL UTILIZE
THE MOST APPROPRIATE AND
EFFECTIVE LEADERSHIP AND
RESOURCES.
THE MERE ENTRY OF USE INTO THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM INTO A
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM OF
CONTAINMENT AND CONTROL.
HAS BEEN SHOWN BY COUNTLESS
STUDIES TO PRODUCE ITS OWN
ADVERSE AND TRAUMATIZING AFFECTS.
CHILDREN WHO ARE INCARCERATED
OFTEN DETERIORATE
PSYCHOLOGICALLY AND MAYBE LESS
AMENABLE TO SUBSEQUENT EFFORTS
AT REHABILITATION.
ENTRY OF CHILDREN INTO THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IMMEDIATELY
REDUCES THEIR CHANCES IN LIFE.
CHILDREN WHO ENTER THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM ARE MORE LIKELY TO REMAIN
THERE.
INDEED CHILD INCARCERATION IS
THE SINGLE GREATEST RISK FACTOR
FOR ADULT INCARCERATION.
EFFECTIVE DIVERSION IS A COMPLEX
CHALLENGE AND I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO PLACE THE ADMINISTRATION
OF DIVERSION SERVICES AND THE
HANDS OF THOSE WHOSE EXPERTISE
QUALIFIES THEM TO TACKLE THIS
COMPLEXITY.
WE SHOULD BE PROFESSIONALS
ALREADY TASKED WITH THE HEALTH
AND WELFARE OF CHILDREN THOSE
FROM THOSE AND SOCIAL SERVICES
AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
THESE ARE THE PROFESSIONALS WHO
CAN SHAPE PROGRAMMING AROUND THE
UNDERSTANDING THE CHILDREN AT
RISK HAVE OFTEN HAD NO ACCESS TO
THE EDUCATIONAL AND VOCATIONAL.
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND FAMILY
SUPPORTS AVAILABLE TO MORE
AFFLUENT COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT THIS PAUCITY OF
SERVICES OFTEN SETS THEM UP FOR
FAILURE
PROFESSIONALS WHO BRING TRAINING
FOCUS AND EXPERTISE TO A
SPECIALIZED UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
TO CONNECT TO RESTORE AND
INSPIRE KIDS.
HOW TO TURN AROUND THOSE HEADING
DOWN A BAD PATH?
I SIT BEFORE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY.
IT IS MY PROFESSIONAL OPINION
BOLSTERED BY SCHOLARLY DATA THAT
NOT ONLY THE HEALTH OF OUR YOUTH
BUT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
IS BEST SERVED BY COMMITMENT TO
A THOUGHTFUL AND ROBUST
DIVERSION PROGRAM OVERSEEN BY
THOSE WHOSE EXPERTISE IS IN
PROMOTING THE HEALTHY
DEVELOPMENT OF CHILDREN AND
YOUTH.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANNA
JOHNSON AND I WAS A SCHOOL
TEACHER FOR FOUR YEARS IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AT IRVINE
PROMISE ACADEMY IN THE FRUITVALE.
WAS A TITLE ONE PUBLIC SCHOOL WE
DO NOT HAVE A LIBRARIAN WE DID
NOT HAVE A COUNSELOR OR ACADEMIC
OR A THERAPEUTIC COUNSELOR WE DO
NOT HAVE A SCHOOL NURSE WE DID
NOT HAVE -- ANY SORT OF SUPPORTS
OUR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM WAS CUT
AND WE RELIED HEAVILY ON
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES TO
SUPPORT THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
WHILE EXPERIENCING CUTS TO THE
LOCAL LIBRARY AND OTHER THINGS.
AND THAT WAS -- THAT WAS A WHILE
AGO BEFORE I BEGAN WORKING AT
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW BUT WHAT MY COLLEAGUES COULD
DO WHEN THEY NEEDED HELP WITH
THESE BEHAVIOR WAS RELY ONLY ON
A DEAN OF STUDENTS.
OR SOME PUNITIVE APPROACH WHICH
DIDN'T REALLY ADDRESS WHAT WAS
GOING ON WITH THE HUNGER THE
CHILD WAS EXPERIENCING WITH THE
IT THE EXPERIENCE OF VIOLENCE
THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE OF
EXPERIENCE ON THE WALK TO SCHOOL.
IT ACTUALLY WAS JUST NOT A SAFE
PLACE AND WE WORKED REALLY HARD
TO MAKE IT SAFE -- BUT THAT WAS
JUST ON A LOCAL LEVEL BY THE
TIME WE GOT EVERYTHING IN PLACE
THAT WE NEEDED AT THAT SCHOOL WE
FINALLY HAD EVERY CHILD WALK THE
STAGE FOR GRADUATION.
BUT IT TOOK THREE YEARS TO SET
THAT UP -- WE'RE ASKING FOR A
SAME APPROACH ON THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL WHERE WE KNOW COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY UNDER
SERVED AN UNDER FUNDED AND UNDER
RESOURCE.
AND WE WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE THIS
CHILD DEVELOPMENT UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT DOES A CHILD NEED TO
SUCCEED AND BE HEALTHY AND SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS TO
SET UP THAT PLAN.
AND TO USE LOCAL RESOURCES THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN PROPERLY
INSUFFICIENTLY SPENT ON CHILDREN
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THE COME UP TO THE MIKE.
AIR CARRIERS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JACKIE ONE WITH
GRAYSON AND CAL PARTING
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN -- IN STRONG
SUPPORT BECAUSE WE SHOULD NOT
CRIMINALIZE POVERTY.
LIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA I
APOLOGIZE THAT WE DIDN'T GET OUR
LETTER AND ON TIME BUT WE'RE
SUPPORT OF AT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ AND ASW
CALIFORNIANS PART.
AFTER MORE TEAR FROM FIVE COMING
VESTING KIDS REPRESENTING OVER
THREE HUNDRED PLEASE SHE SERVES
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ACROSS THE
STATE AND SUPPORT.
THANK ENTITIES YOUTH ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THOSE WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COLLISION A STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN I GO FOR THE JUSTICE
COALITION FOR STRESS AT THE AGE
OF TWELVE I COULD REALLY USE
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL.
VIDEO BORN AP CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
NAME IS GLORIA GONZALEZ AND I
WAS A PART OF CREATING THIS IN
LOS ANGELES AND I JUST STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO BE ABLE -- TO GIVE
YOUNG PEOPLE ACCESS TO THIS.
THE ROBBERS WITH THE JUSTICE
COALITION AND IF WE HAD THIS IN
PLACE WHEN I WAS YOUNG WHAT IS
SAY ME FROM JUVENILE RECORD I
MADE MY LIFE A LOT EASIER STRONG
SUPPORT THANK -- IRVING OPERAS
YOU THE JUSTICE COALITION I DID
THREE YEARS IN PRISON AND OUT I
TOTALLY SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE IT
WOULD TOTALLY WOULD HELP ME IF I
WOULD HAVE THIS EARLIER IN MY
LIFE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KRISTIN DEANGELO SEX WORKERS
OUTREACH PROJECT SACRAMENTO AND
SEX WORKERS OUTREACH PROJECT
BEHIND BARS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL -- JAMES BIRCH HERE
REPRESENTING THE ANTI POLICE
TERROR PROJECT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE GIVENS OF
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WE WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS INNOVATIVE APPROACH TO
IT WE BELIEVE IT'S A PUBLIC
HEALTH APPROACH TO MAKING SURE
THAT THESE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
ARE SERVED.
WE HAVE A SUPPORT IN CONCEPT
POSITION WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH AUTHORS OFFICE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE PILOTS CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED AND BASED ON THAT
THE PROVISIONS IN THE GUIDELINES
THAT ARE SET FORTH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY -- OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AND GIVE THEM A CHECK ONE OF THE
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D DANIEL SANCHEZ WITH
THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TODAY IN IN
OPPOSITION I DO WANT TO THANK.
SENATOR MONNING -- AND AND HIS
STAFF IMMENSELY -- FOR MANY MANY
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS ON
THIS BILL AND SO -- WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO TALK
AND SO I JUST WANT TO EXTEND OUR
APPRECIATION -- WE HAVE SHARED
WITH THE AUTHOR AND AND THE
SPONSOR -- CERTAINLY OUR
AGREEMENT ON KIND OF A PUBLIC
HEALTH APPROACH TO EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT I THINK
MANY OF THE THINGS THAT -- WERE
RAISED HERE BY THE SPONSORS AND
SUPPORTERS WE ARE VERY VERY MUCH
AN AGREEMENT AND AND PROBATION
IS VERY MUCH COMMITTED -- TO
FACTORS SUCH AS POVERTY TRAUMA --
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
HUNGER THESE ARE ALL VERY VERY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES --
THAT CERTAINLY IF ADDRESSED
EARLY CAN LIMIT THEM FROM COMING
INTO CONTACT WITH OUR JUSTICE
THE AREA IN WHICH WE DISAGREE ON
IS AND AND WHERE WE HAVE A LOT
OF CONCERNS IS REALLY THE
APPROACH THAT THIS BILL TAKES --
IN COMBINING EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT AND DIVERSION UNDER
A NEW COUNTY ENTITY. TO PROVIDE
FOR THESE DIVERSION SERVICES --
PROBATION OVER MANY MANY DECADES
HAS INVESTED AND BUILD LINKAGES
AND PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER
COUNTY DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICES -- WE'VE WORKED --
EXTENSIVELY WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TOWARD THIS END
AND SO WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT DATA
TO SHOW THE PRECIPITOUS DECLINE
ON THAT WE'VE HAD IN JUVENILE --
ARREST RATES DETENTION RATES AND
ALSO DIVERSION FROM THE FRONT
INTO THE SYSTEM AND THAT'S AN
AREA WHERE ARE ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED -- TO OUR PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN EVALUATED AND
DETERMINE TO BE EVIDENCE BASED
AND SO ARE CONCERNED WITH MOVING
AWAY FROM THIS WOULD BE THAT
WE'RE GONNA.
BE STEP AWAY FROM OUTCOMES -- AN
INTRODUCTORY THAT WE KNOW IS
WORKING -- I THINK PART OF THE
CONCERN FOR US IS HAVING --
AGAIN KIND OF DUAL ENTITIES AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL DOING BOTH
DOING DIVERSION WORK -- AND THIS
NEW ENTITY SET UP IN A WAY THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY --
INCORPORATE PROBATION I THINK WE
EQUATE THIS TO A SIMILAR
CONSTRUCT IN WHICH YOU HAVE TO
STATE AGENCIES THAT WOULD BOTH
HAVE THE SAME MISSION A
RESPONSIBILITIES AND AT THE END
OF THE DAY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE NOT ANY.
LOTS OF EFFICIENCIES -- A
DECLINE IN DELIVERY OF SERVICES
ARE THINGS THAT WOULD IMPACT THE
YOUTH -- THAT THAT POTENTIALLY
NOW WOULD WOULD KIND OF COME
UNDER THESE THESE TWO ENTITIES --
I THINK ONE OF THE STATED GOALS
OF THE BILL IS TO MINIMIZE
CONTACT WITH THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND WE BELIEVE IN
A AN IMPORTANT WAY TO DO THIS
WERE TO HAPPEN TO HAVE THIS BILL
FOCUS ON TE EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT SO.
BEFORE THEY'RE EVEN ARRESTED
BEFORE THEY'RE COMING INTO THE
SYSTEM FOCUS ON AGAIN ALL OF THE
ASPECTS THAT A FOR SUCCESSFUL
THERE KEEP THEM FROM EVEN COMING.
NEAR OR INTO.
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM I THINK EEN
AS A PILOT AGAIN BECAUSE OF KIND
OF THESE DUPLICATIVE PARALLEL --
COUNTY ENTITIES WERE CONCERNED
AGAIN -- THAT THERE'S
POSSIBILITIES OF KIND OF THE
ABILITY TO ADDRESS BEHAVIOR --
FOR YOUTH IN THE WAY THAT I
THINK WE ALL WANT TO SEE -- SO
AGAIN FOR US I THINK A BILL THAT
FOCUSES ON THE FRONT END YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT OF ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE TALKED ABOUT -- WOULD
MEET THE GOALS AND ULTIMATELY
WOULD HAVE THE IMPACT OF OF
SERVING IN KIND OF A DIVERSION
CAPACITY WITHOUT IT CREATING --
A DUPLICATION OF COUNTY EFFORTS
FOR NOW HAVING TO ENTITIES BOTH
WORKING ON DIVERSION AND INSTEAD
CONTINUE TO ALLOW PROBATION TO
WORK WITH OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS
AND COMMUNITY -- COUNTY AGENCIES
TO BEST DELIVER SERVICES AND
HAVE THIS FOCUS ON THE VERY
FRONT END OF THE SYSTEM -- SO
WITH THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY
OPPOSED AND AND AGAIN LOOK
FORWARD TO FUTURE CONVERSATIONS.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS CENTER
MORE LACK MANAGER -- THE SANCHEZ --
YOU'RE YOU'RE SAYING THAT YOU
ALREADY GOT METRICS THAT ARE
SHOWING YOUR VERY VERY
SUCCESSFUL SO I'M JUST CURIOUS
CENTER MINING.
WHAT MORE CAN WE DO THAT THIRTY
BEING DONE?
WITH THE KERN.
WELL IT'S A FAIR QUESTION AND I
ALSO WANNA OFFER MONEY.
RESPECT FOR THE WORKER PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS ARE DOING CERTAINLY
IN MY DISTRICT THERE'S BEEN SOME
WONDERFULLY INNOVATIVE EFFORTS --
TO LOOK AT THE DIVERSION SIDE
THAT SAID WHAT WE'RE LOOKING OUT
WITH THESE PILOT PROGRAMS.
IS AN INNOVATIVE APPROACH
THROUGH A PUBLIC HEALTH GATEWAY
WHERE THE CHILD IS NOT
STIGMATIZED BY BEING PART OF A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM -- THAT
DOES INVOLVE OFTEN BARS AND
DETENTION FACILITIES EVEN WHERE
THERE IS COLLABORATION WE ALSO
BELIEVE I BELIEVE STRONGLY THIS
WOULD NOT PRECLUDE IN THESE
PILOTS COLLABORATION WITH THE
PROBATION OFFICERS AND
DEPARTMENTS IN FACT I THINK IT'S
SUCCESS.
WOULD BE ROOTED IN BUILDING
THOSE PILLARS OF COLLABORATION
WE THINK WE CAN LEARN SOME BEST
PRACTICES FROM THE PUBLIC A HELP.
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH -- IN AS
THE PROBATION -- DIVISIONS HAVE
SAID GETTING TO THE FRONT END OF
WHAT'S LANDING CHILDREN IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM -- IS
EXACTLYWHAT THESE PILOTS CAN DO
LOOKING AT SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
FAMILIES EARLY IDENTIFICATION --
WHERE THERE'S PARTNERSHIPS WITH
SCHOOLS WITH PROBATION
DEPARTMENT -- AND HOPEFULLY
BEFORE THERE'S CONTACT WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT -- WE THINK LOS
ANGELES IS MAKING GOOD HEADWAY.
LOS ANGELES COULD ALSO BE A
BENEFICIARY.
AS POTENTIALLY ONE OF THE PILOTS
WERE WE WE LEARN FROM THEM AND
DEVELOPING THE OTHERS.
SO THIS WILL BE A GRANT PROGRAM
IT WILL AND IT WILL BE TAKEN UP
IN APPROPRIATIONS -- WHICH OF
COURSE THIS IS THE POLICY
COMMITTEE IT WOULD REQUIRE
BUDGET ALLOCATION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION THERE WERE WHAT
KIND NUMBERS WE'RE LOOKING AT
BECAUSE WE'RE LOOKING AT A
DEPARTMENT RIGHT A WHOLE NEW.
ACTUALLY WE'RE LOOKING AT BUT
YOUR SING WITH EXISTING COUNTY
SERVICES -- WE'RE SEEKING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS WE THINK THAT
WOULD BE SUFFICIENT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THE PILOT. THREE TO
FIVE COUNTIES VOLUNTARY IT'LL BE
THE COUNTIES THAT STEP UP IN
WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS.
FUNDING.
THANK YOU THANK THANK YOU --
THANK YOU CENTER MORE LIKE
[inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
I I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL I
WOULD NOTE THAT.
IS WE HAVE AN INTERESTING
CIRCUMSTANCE NOW WHERE -- THE
NUMBER OF JUVENILES IN OUR
COUNTY FCILITIES IS AN OUT ALL
TIME LOW AND HAS BEEN GOING DOWN
FOR TWENTY YEARS TO THE POINT
WHERE WE HAVE COUNTIES IN ONLY A
FIVE PEOPLE.
IN THERE TOO LITTLE FACILITIES
WHERE AS WE HAVE MADE WE THE
STATE MADE HUGE INVESTMENTS.
IN FUNDING THE COUNTIES TO
EXPAND THESE FACILITIES WHICH
ARE NOW COMPLETELY UNDER
UTILIZED.
AND AND INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH
WELL.
OF HUGE.
THE LARGE PORTION OF THAT DROP
IS DUE TO THE FACT THAT.
CRIME RATES AMONGST JUVENILES IS
DOWN.
THE OTHER PORTION IS BECAUSE WE
DO DO DIVERSION PROGRAMS BUT
INTERESTINGLY.
WE HAVE AND WE I DON'T HAVE
EXACT NUMBERS YET BUT I'VE BEEN
ASKING FOR DATA.
THERE ARE MORE YOUNG PEOPLE IN
FOR MISDEMEANORS THAN I THINK
MOST OF US WOULD BE PLEASED WITH.
AND WE NEED TO LOOK AT WHY.
AND IT MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE%
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE THE
PRESENCE OF DIVERSION PROGRAMS
ARE NOT THERE COULD BE OTHER
FACTORS.
BUT CERTAINLY AS HE'S CRIME
RATES GO DOWN I THINK WE I DON'T
THINK WE REALLY ENVISIONED THESE
FACILITIES PRIMARILY FOR
MISDEMEANOR.
AND I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THE STATE.
JUVENILE FACILITIES WHICH ARE.
POPULATION IS DOWN ALSO ARE FOR
CLEARLY SERIOUS SERIOUS
OFFENDERS -- BUT REALLY LOW
LEVEL YOU KNOW WE WOULD HOPE
THAT WE WOULD BE -- HANDLING
THEM IN WAYS OTHER THAN HOLDING
THEM.
SO -- WHETHER THIS BILL HELPS US
TO GET AT TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE MISDEMEANOR
LOW LEVEL MISDEMEANORS IN OUR
COUNTY FACILITIES -- I WOULD
HOPE SO -- SO AS I INDICATED I
AM SUPPORTIVE BUT I ALSO AM IN
TERMS MY HAT AS BEING THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR.
LOOKING VERY CAREFULLY AT WHAT
THE STATE IS GIVING TO COUNTIES
IN RELATIONSHIP TO JUVENILES
BECAUSE OF HOW FEW JUVENILES ARE
NOW IN COUNTY FACILITIES.
AND THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT IS
BEING SPENT PER JUVENILE IS VERY
VERY HIGH IN SANTA CLEAR THE
RECENT NUMBERS WERE. FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND ABOUT --
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTEEN SOMEWHERE
UP WERE OVER FIVE HUNDRED K. PER
JUVENILE -- ANYWAY SO THESE ARE
ALL THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT BUT CERTAINLY THE OBJECTIVE.
OF INTERVENTIONS WITH JUVENILES
SO THAT.
WE CAN PREVENT THEM FROM.
WHICH IS THE WE CAN.
PUT THEM ON A GOOD PATH IS IS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND THIS IS
A PILOT SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
IT.
CENTER MORE LACK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- COMING
FROM COUNTY LAND.
AND APPRECIATING WHAT PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS DO AND LOOKING AT
THE DATA AND SEEING HOW
SUCCESSFUL THEY HAVE BEEN.
I'M I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS AND
REMINDING OF OF ADDING MORE COST --
AND IT OUT I WANT TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS FOR SOME INCREDIBLE
DATA THAT THAT WE HAVE A AND
BECAUSE COUNTIES TEND TO HAVE
DEPARTMENTS THAT OPERATE IN
SILOS.
IT WOULD BE NICE TO SEE SOME
MORE CROSS TRAINING IF I COULD
USE SOME KIND OF TERM.
WHERE WE WORK TOGETHER BETWEEN
THE DEPARTMENTS HELP IT CETERA --
IN MAYBE IT FIRST START WITH
DEVELOPING A PROGRAM AND DO SOME.
CROSS POLLINATION FIRST BEFORE
WE SET UP OF A PILOT PROGRAM
ZABI OPPOSE TODAY.
BUT I'LL BE WATCH UNDERSTAND OF
THROUGH THERE IF I COULD JUST
RESPOND TO THAT I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERN BUT I THINK.
THE STATISTIC SHARED BY THE
CHAIR POINT.
TO NOT ONLY SUCCESS OF PROBATION
AND JUVENILE JUSTICE SERVICES TO
A POINT BUT ALSO THE THE HIGH
COST OF THAT PATH OF FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND PER
INCARCERATED USE.
IF IF FOR A FRACTION OF THAT
WERE INVESTED IN SUCCESSFUL ON
PUBLIC HEALTH SOCIAL
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS A FEW
YEARS AGO I WORKED WITH.
THEN ATTORNEY GENERAL COMMA
HARRIS ANA LOOKING AT USE WHO
WERE FOUND TO BE TRUANT IN
PROSECUTIONS OF PARENTS FOR
TRUANT USE.
IN GETTING THEM OUT OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
WHERE THERE'S CHRONIC TRUANCY
THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE GOING ON
LET'S TRY TO FIND OUT WHAT'S
GOING ON AND I THINK THIS BUILDS
ON THAT SAME PHILOSOPHY.
AND I THINK A BROADER PHILOSOPHY
IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM OF
SEEING.
MANY OF THE STARTERS IS BEING
SOCIAL MEDICAL ISSUES NOT CRIME
PER SE NOT CRIMINAL INDIVIDUALS
SO -- I THINK.
THIS DOESN'T CONTEMPLATE
BUILDING SILENCE I THINK THE
PILOTS THAT ARE SUCCESSFUL THAT
WE CAN LEARN FROM WILL BE THOSE
THAT INTEGRATE EXISTING SERVICES.
DRAWN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH LINK
FAMILIES TO BEHAVIOR HEALTH
WHERE APPROPRIATE -- MAYBE IT'S
AS SIMPLE AS PRIMARY CARE MAYBE
THROUGH THE SCHOOL SYSTEM THE
VISION OF THESE PILOTS IS THEY
DEVELOP BEST PRACTICES TO SEE IF
THERE'S SOMETHING.
THAT PROBATION THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AND SCHOOLS CAN LEARN
FROM SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
INITIATIVE HERE WE THINK IN THE
LONG RUN COST SAVING.
IN MAYBE SO I SIT THERE SENATOR
MITCHELL HAS IT AND THEN --
UNLESS THERE'S OTHER DISCUSSION
AFTER YOU ANSWER SENATOR
MITCHELL'S IF THERE IS AN ANSWER
YOU CAN CLOSE GO AHEAD CENTER
MITCHELL AND THAT I THE BILL HAS
ALREADY BEEN CANCELED THANK YOU.
QUICK QUESTION SENATOR MINING IS
THIS -- WORKING IN CONCERT.
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S ON BUDGET
PROPOSAL WITH REGARD TO MOVING.
ON DJJ INTO -- HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY YOU SEE THESE.
WELL IN CONCERT YES IN FACT --
WE ARE LOOKING -- AT MOVING THIS
TO HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES THE
CURRENT BILL DRAFTED.
IS UNDER PUBLIC HEALTH OKAY
WE'RE LOOKING AT MOVING IT INTO
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
THAT IS THE CURRENT PLAN BASED
ON CONVERSATIONS TODAY
MINISTRATION GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M OF THE BILL.
RIGHT TO THE MOTION BEFORE US IS
TO PASSED RULES SENATOR MORNING
DO YOU WANT.
TO CLOSE.
I JUST THINK THE COMMITTEE.
FOR INSIGHTFUL QUESTIONS I WANT
TO THANK OUR WITNESSES LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
PROBATION AND OTHER.
STAKEHOLDERS IN OUR COUNTY SO I
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION LET'S TO
ROLL CALL.
SKINNER BY SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
ROCK NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I'M AROUND.
WIENER I MEAN OR I SORRY WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN -- BUT IT
LOOKS GOOD.
BUT WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN AND
WILL NOW GO TO ITEMS SIXTEEN SB
FIVE EIGHTY MISTER WELL
[inaudible]
IT'S KIND.
BREITBART WHILE SENATOR WORKS ON
THE WAY LET'S DO MOTION ON
SENATOR BATES BILL.
YES YES I KNOW HE'S COMING TO
THE TABLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUT WE WANTED TO DO A MOTION ON
BATES BILL THAT WE KNEW WE
DIDN'T HAVE A QUORUM IN THE ROOM
ALSO.
ALRIGHT SO LET'S -- IT'S DO PASS
AS AMENDED.
I'M SENATOR BATES SO WE WILL DO
A ROLL CALL ON THAT.
THE PAST AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER ALL RIGHT
SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD.
I FOR AYE JACKSON MITCHELL.
THE BATES AS AMENDED.
MITCHELL AYE MORRELL WIENER.
WIENER HIGH.
GREAT SO WILL HOLD THAT OPEN
ALSO AND WE WILL NOW HAVE
SENATOR WHAT PRESENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SB FIVE
EIGHTY THE ANIMAL CRUELTY AND
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION ACTS.
THIS IS A BILL THAT WILL HELP
DIFFERENT PREVENT SOME OF THE
MOST HORRIFIC AND TRAGIC
ACCIDENT ACTS OF CRUELTY AND
VIOLENCE.
THERE IS A PROVEN LINK BETWEEN
ANIMAL ABUSE AND AND LATER
VIOLENCE TOWARDS PEOPLE.
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT.
THOSE WHO ABUSE ANIMALS GOING TO
COMMIT MUCH MORE SERIOUS ACTS OF
AGGRESSION AND VIOLENCE LATER IN
LIFE. 90% OF ALL MASS MURDERS
71% OF THOSE CONVICTED OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN 50% OF A
CONVICTEDRAPIST ALL STARTED%
WITH ANIMAL ABUSE.
SO IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
INTERVENE EARLY AND PREVENT
ANIMAL ABUSE OFFENDERS FROM
PROGRESSING TOO MUCH WORSE AND
MORE SERIOUS OFFENSES.
THE SB FIVE EIGHTY WILL REQUIRE
THE MOST SERIOUS ANIMAL ABUSE
OFFENDERS TO UNDERGO A MENTAL
HEALTH EVALUATION.
AND TO UNDERGO ANY NECESSARY
COUNSELING OR TREATMENT AT THE
DISCRETION OF THE JUDGE.
THIS BILL ALSO PERMITS JUDGES TO
SIGN A NUMBER OF APPROVED HUMANE
EDUCATION COURSES FOR OFFENDERS
GRANTED PROBATION FOR LESS
SERIOUS OFFENSE. TO LESSEN THE
LACK LIKELIHOOD OF RECURRENCE.
SB FIVE EIGHTY MAINTAINS
JUDICIAL DISCRETION TO SIGN THE
APPROPRIATE TREATMENTS
COUNSELING OR EDUCATION AS
NECESSARY -- INTO ANIMAL ABUSE
OFFENDERS PREVENT FUTURE CRUELTY
AND VIOLENCE TO BOTH ANIMALS AND
PEOPLE.
I AM AWARE THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND WE'VE
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH THEM AND
WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING LETTER --
LATER AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS IN THAT THE
EVALUATION WILL ONLY BE USED FOR
THIS SPECIFIC -- PURPOSE.
ALSO WE'RE WORKING TO IDENTIFY
THE MOST APPROPRIATE STATE
AGENCY TO CERTIFY THE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
AND WE'VE BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS
WITH BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND THESE
DISCUSSIONS ARE ONGOING TO WHICH
IS THE MOST APPROPRIATE BODY. TO
TO MANAGE THIS WITH THE
PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE LYNSEY LARISA WITH
THE ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE FUND TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
CERTAINLY GO AHEAD YOU CENTER
WILK -- GOOD MORNING CHAIRPERSON
AND COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ONE TWO
HOURS AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE FUND.
AND ARE MORE THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IF
SUPPORTERS AT SENATE BILL.
FIVE EIGHTY THE ANIMAL CRUELTY
AND VIOLENCE INTERVENTION ACT
EMPOWERS COURTS OF KEY TOOL TO
HELP REHABILITATE CONVICTED AND
ABUSERS IN ORDER TO CHANGE
BEHAVIOR AND TO ACTUALLY PREVENT
FUTURE VIOLENCE TOWARD ANIMALS
AND PEOPLE BEFORE IT HAPPENS.
AS SENATOR WEALTH MENTIONED OVER
THE PAST TWO DECADES THERE'S
BEEN NUMEROUS STUDIES SHOWING
THIS LINK BETWEEN ANIMAL
VIOLENCE AND VIOLENCE HUMANS.
I'M IN FACT MOST WOMEN ENTERING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS
REPORT THAT THEIR VIEWS ARE ALSO
KILLED OR HARMED OR THREATENED
TO KILL HER FAMILY PAT.
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS LINK
EXISTS THIRTY TWO STATES
CURRENTLY HAVE LEGISLATION THE
OTHER PERMITS -- REQUIRES SOME
LEVEL OF MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELING AS PERFORATION UNDER
SENTENCING IN CASE OF ANIMAL
ABUSE INCLUDING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I BELIEVE THAT SB FIVE EIGHTY IS
IMPORTANT EXCEPT FOR CALIFORNIA
IN COMBAT IN THE CYCLE OF
VIOLENCE ALSO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY REHABILITATIVE AND
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES. TO HELP
OFFENDERS FROM RE OFFENDING.
SB FIVE EIGHTY DOES TWO
IMPORTANT THINGS INSURERS
OFFENDERS OF ANIMAL CRUELTY
CRIMES THAT HAVE A HIGH
CORRELATION TO UNDERLYING MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
RECEIVE THE MENTAL HEALTH
EVALUATION AND GIVE JUDGES AN
APPROPRIATE TOOL LARGEST SIDE
WHICH EVALUATION WHICH
COUNSELING IF ANY IS THE
APPROPRIATE COUNSELING.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH UNDER FIVE
NINE SEVEN H..
AND THIS MAY BE OVER INCLUSIVE
AND MAY INCLUDE OFFENDERS THAT
WILL BENEFIT FROM MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELING WE ALSO ARE NOT SURE
AT THIS POINT WHERE THOSE
OFFENDERS ARE GOING.
OR IF THAT COUNTS IS APPROPRIATE.
WITH FIVE EIGHTY MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WILL BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH THE OFFENDER.
AND YOU LOOK AND A CLINICIAN CAN
MAKE A KEY RECOMMENDATION ABOUT
THE MOST APPROPRIATE AND
EFFECTIVE TYPE OF THERAPEUTIC
INTERVENTION.
SB FIVE YOU WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE JUDGES WITHIN A
VALUATION REPORT.
THE JUDGE TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION WITH THE INPUT OF A
PROFESSIONAL AS TO WHAT TYPE OF
COUNSELING IF ANY MAKES SENSE
FOR A PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL.
RESEARCH IN THE FIELD HAS SHOWN
PROMISING RESULTS WITH THAT TYPE
OF COUNSELING KNOWN AS MORAL
WRECK RECONNAISSANCE.
THERAPY MRT WHICH HAS A SEEKS TO
DECREASE RECIDIVISM AMONG BOTH
JUVENILE AND ADULT CRIMINAL
OFFENDERS BY INCREASING MORAL
REASONING THROUGH VARIATION OF
THE WELL KNOWN.
CBT COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL THERAPY
APPROACH.
WELL THIS IS RELATIVELY NEW
FIELD OF STUDY THERE HAS BEEN
EVIDENCE THAT THIS TYPE OF
THERAPY DOES REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
I MARTINEZ UP AS ONE TYPE OF
TREATMENT AVAILABLE BUT ANIMAL
ABUSE CAN BE CONNECTED TO A WIDE
VARIETY OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS.
AND THERE'S A WIDE MEN -- ARRAY
OF PROFESSIONALS THAT CAN HELP
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM.
WITH THE RANGE OF UNDERLYING
ISSUES MANIFESTING IN THE CRIME
OF ANIMAL ABUSE IT'S LOGICAL FOR
THE REHABILITATION OF THE
OFFENDER AND FOR THE PROTECTION
OF THE PUBLIC THAT A MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL IS INVOLVED
IN THE PROCESS WITH THE COURT --
THIS BILL ALSO WILL GIVE JUDGES
COMMUNICATION COURSES AS CENTER
WEALTH MENTIONED. TO THE BROADER
SPECTRUM OF ANIMAL CRUELTY
CRIMES WELL SOME OFFENDERS MIGHT
HAVE UNDERLYING MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES SOME OFFENDERS CAN BE
BETTER READABILITY IT THROUGH
HUMANE EDUCATION.
THIS IS THE CASE WHEN THERE ARE
THINGS LIKE NEGLECT WHERE
SOMEBODY JUST MIGHT NOT KNOW.
WHAT THEY'VE DONE WRONG AND
WITHOUT THIS EDUCATION THEY'RE
LIKELY TO RE OFFEND
THESE COURSES WILL ENCOURAGE
EMPATHY AND PROMOTE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEED FOR
COMPASSION RESPECT FOR ANIMALS.
AND AGAIN THIS IS A COMPLETELY
AT THE JUDGE'S DISCRETION WE DID
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
COMMITTEE'S CONCERNS LAST YEAR
AND MAJOR THIS BILL A LOT OF THE
JUDGES HAVE MORE DISCRETION IN
BOTH OF THESE TREATMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY AND I RESPECTFULLY
URGE IN EITHER THE THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE
ARE WITHDRAWING OUR OPPOSITION
GIVEN THEM OUR DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR [inaudible]
GREAT.
I'M IN CENTER WORK ON A NOTE
THAT TIME.
YOU ARE -- GOOD TO BE PERSISTENT.
AND BECAUSE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE WE DO KNOW THAT.
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE CRUEL TO
ANIMALS AS YOU HAVE POINTED OUT
ARE AND TEN TO THEN OUTSIDE
DISPLAY OTHER -- BEHAVIORS THAT --
CAN BE CRIMINAL IN NATURE --
WE'VE HAD BILLS -- YOU HAVE
BROUGHT US BILLS BEFORE THAT
WERE MUCH BROADER AND HARDER FOR
EXAMPLE FOR ME IS THAT YOUR TO
SUPPORT.
BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
NARROWING THAT YOU'VE DONE ON
THIS BILL I THINK YOU'VE HIT.
ON A GOOD BALANCE.
AND SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING.
AND LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BY MY
COLLEAGUES.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
ON BEHALF OF MY RESCUE DOG THAT
WAS LEFT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
DESERT TIED UP TO BUSH COULD BE
EATEN BY A COYOTE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW ANYBODY CAN DO
THAT SO ON BEHALF FOR HER.
HOUSE FOR A NIGHT SO.
THANK YOU SO -- TWELVE SO THIS
IS THE MOTION IS PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LET'S DO A ROLL
CALL.
SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE MOORLACH
MOORLACH AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MOREAU WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
ALRIGHT WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN
BECAUSE WE'RE MISSING SOME
MEMBERS BUT IT'S LOOKING GOOD.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE WITHOUT
ANOTHER AUTHOR HERE SENATOR
WIENER DO YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD.
ON SB
-- ONE FORTY FIVE THAT'S
RIGHT [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
YEAH OKAY.
THE CARD WITHOUT.
YEAH AND OUR STAFF WILL.
DON'T WORRY WE WILL MAKE SURE TO
HEAR FROM YOUR WITNESSES IF YOU
WANT TO START [inaudible]
RIGHT GREAT.
OKAY I THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
HIS [inaudible]
BIGGEST -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CEREMONY THANK YOU ARE YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING.
WITH US ON THIS BILL --
COLLEAGUES -- SB -- ONE FORTY
FIVE WILL FINALLY PUT AND AND TO
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHLY --
DISCRIMINATORY -- AND ANTI LGBT --
TREATMENT OF SPECIFIC SEX ACTS
BY OUR SECOND STATES SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY -- BY ENSURING
THAT ALL FORMS OF INTERCOURSE
ARE TREATED THE SAME UNDER THE
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY.
AS OPPOSED TO THE WAY IT IS NOW
WHERE AS WERE -- VAGINAL --
PENILE INTERCOURSE IS TREATED
MUCH LESS HARSHLY THAN OTHER
FORMS OF INTERCOURSE IT'S
IRRATIONAL -- IT HAS ABSOLUTELY
THERE'S NO WAY OF REALLY
EXPLAINING IT -- AND IT RESULTS
IN INCREDIBLY BIZARRE -- AND
UNFAIR AND DISCRIMINATORY OUR
RESULTS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW.
IF -- AND ADULTS HAS --
CONSENSUAL.
VAGINAL INTERCOURSE WITH A MINOR
AGE FOURTEEN TO SEVENTEEN THIS
IS NOT BROUGHT TIME ANYONE UNDER
THE AGE OF FOURTEEN AND ABOUT IT
THOUGH IT IS NO MORE THAN TEN
YEARS OLDER.
THAN THE MINOR AGE -- FOURTEEN
TO SEVENTEEN THE OFFENSE IS NOT
A REGISTER ROLL OFFENSE.
THE COURT HAS THE DISCRETION TO
DECIDE BASED ON THE FACTS OF THE
CASE WHETHER TO PUT SOMEONE ON
THE REGISTRY.
BUT THE COURT IS NOT REQUIRED TO
DO SO.
THAT IS CURRENT LAW IN
CALIFORNIA.
ON THE OTHER HAND.
IF TE SAME EXACT SITUATION
OCCURS AN ADULT HAS SEX WITH A
FOURTEEN TO SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
AND IS NO MORE THAN TEN YEARS
OLDER.
BUT IF THE INTERCOURSE INSTEAD
OF BEING VAGINAL IS SOMETHING
ELSE A ORAL OR ANAL SEX.
I'VE BEEN THE COURT IS MANDATED
TO PLACE THE OFFENDER.
ON THE REGISTRY.
NO MATTER WHAT.
THESE THE REASON THAT THIS
DISTINCTION EXISTS OF COURSE IS
THAT WHEN THE SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY WAS CREATED IN THE
NINETEEN FORTIES -- ALL FORMS OF
ENTERS INTERCOURSE OTHER THAN
VAGINAL INTERCOURSE WERE ILLEGAL --
WALLED IN ALL THOSE OTHER FORMS
OF INTERCOURSE WERE LEGALIZED IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES THE
REGISTRY WAS NEVER CHANGE -- SO
AS A RESULT -- WE SEE VERY.
PROBLEMATIC RESULTS FIRST OF ALL
THIS INTENSELY DISCRIMINATES
AGAINST LGBT YOUNG PEOPLE
BECAUSE BY AND LARGE WHEN LGBT
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE HAVING SEX --
THEY CANNOT HAVE PENILE VAGINAL
SEX.
AND SO WE HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
IT'S AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD BOY.
HAS VAGINAL SEX WITH A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD GIRLFRIEND IT'S A CRIME.
BUT HE IS NOT A CORE IS NOT
REQUIRED TO PUT HIM ON THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY.
BY CONTRAST IF AN EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLD BOY HAS INTERCOURSE WITH HIS
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD BOYFRIEND.
THE COURT MUST PUT HIM ON THE
REGISTRY AND POTENTIALLY RUIN
HIS LIFE.
OF THESE LAWS ARE A RELIC OF
CALIFORNIA'S HOMOPHOBIC
[inaudible]
PAST.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST LGBT PEOPLE
WHO ARE IMPACTED.
IF YOU ARE AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
BOY.
HAVING SEX BATTLE SUCKS WITH
YOUR SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
GIRLFRIEND YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO
IN THE REGISTRY.
IF SHE PERFORMED ORAL SEX ON HIM.
HE'S REQUIRED THE COR HAS NO
DISCRETION MUST PUT HIM ON THE
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY.
SO IN ADDITION TO DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST LGBT PEOPLE THIS CREATES
THIS BIZARRE IRRATIONAL -- JUST
AWFUL DISTINCTION THAT HAD
SERVES NO PUBLIC POLICY PURPOSE.
THIS LAW WILL SIMPLY.
GET RID OF THAT DISTINCTION TO
TREAT ALL FORMS OF INTERCOURSE
IN THIS.
AGE BRACKET THE SAME WAY THAT WE
HAVE LONG TREATED.
VAGINAL INTERCOURSE PERIOD WE'RE
NOT CREATING A NEW STRUCTURE.
WORKS AS TREATING ALL FORMS OF
INTERCOURSE ON A NOTE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX THE HAWKS ARE CASE
ORRECTLY STRUCK DOWN THIS
DISTINCTION AS AN EQUAL
PROTECTION VIOLATION. FOR
REASONS I WILL NEVER UNDERSTANDS
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
OVERTURNED THAT DECISION.
AND DECIDED THAT IT WAS OKAY TO
DISCRIMINATE HAVE ENORMOUS
RESPECT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT COURT WAS DEAD
WRONG AND IT'S THIS
LEGISLATURE'S JOB TO CORRECT
THAT -- SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE -- WE HAVE A
BROAD COALITION SUPPORTING THIS
BILL.
INCLUDING THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S CAL CASA WHICH
ADVOCATES FOR VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
A AND A BROAD COALITION OF LGBT
ORGANIZATIONS WITH ME TODAY
TESTIFIED.
NOW IS A BROADLY MCCARTY FROM
THE LOS ANGELES DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE ARE DOING AS
WELL BY DOWN PHYLLIS SADO.
ON TAMMY MARTIN FROM QUALITY
CALIFORNIA OUR SPONSORS ARE THE
LOS ANGELES DISTRICT ATTORNEY
AND QUALITY CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
GREAT SO WE'LL HAVE TO WITNESSES
TALKED WITH THE YOU KNOW.
TAKE A LITTLE TIME IN THE OTHERS
JUST.
ADD ON THE GO AHEAD WHICHEVER IF
YOU WANT TO START.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIRPERSON
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME -- I'VE SPOKEN -- TO MANY
OF YOU BEFORE -- ON MY TIERED
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRATION BILL
WHICH SENATOR -- WIENER WAS THE
AUTHOR OF I ACTUALLY FEEL THAT
IS RATHER SURPRISING THAT I'M
HERE SPEAKING TO YOU ABOUT.
THIS BILL.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE WE WENT IN
A TIME MACHINE AND PULLED
SOMETHING OUT THAT I CAN'T EVEN
BELIEVE STILL EXIST ON THE BOOKS
OF OUR PENAL CODE -- I GIVE A
LOT OF SPEECHES ABOUT THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRATION LAWS IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH WERE WRITTEN IN.
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN AND THEY
WERE RETROACTIVE.
TO NINETEEN FORTY FOUR I FEEL
LIKE SOMEBODY HAD A TIME CAPSULE
IN HIGH SCHOOL IN THE FORTIES
AND PUT THIS LAW IN IT AND WE
JUST OPENED IT.
SHOCKED THAT IT ACTUALLY EVER
WAS ON THE BOOKS -- I AM A
TWENTY FOUR YEAR VETERAN OF THE
LA DA'S OFFICE.
I AM A CURSE SEX CRIMES
PROSECUTOR.
I ACT AS OUR EXPERT ON SEX
OFFENDER RECIDIVISM SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRATION CHILD SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
AND MULTI DISSIMILAR MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS -- IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I CAN TELL YOU FROM A PRACTICAL
STANDPOINT.
THAT.
WE HAVE TO DO OUR JOBS WITH SOME
EFFICACY [inaudible]
AND WHEN I HAVE A CASE COME IN.
THAT FALLS UNDER THESE CODE
SECTIONS AND I HAVE NON
PREDATORY BEHAVIOR AND I
VOLUNTARY SEX ACTS BETWEEN. TWO
YOUNG PEOPLE [inaudible]
THE I'M NOT GOING CHARGE.
THESE OFFENSES [inaudible]
BECAUSE THE COURT GOT IT RIGHT.
IN HARSHER.
THEY GOT IT RIGHT THE FIRST TIME
THEN THEY GOT IT RIGHT OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN COURT
RULING AFTER COURT RULING.
THAT IN FORCING REGISTRATION ON
THESE OFFENSES IS FLAT OUT OF
VIOLATION OF EQUAL PROTECTION.
NOW THE JOHNSON CASE RELIED ON
AN IRRATIONAL TECHNICALITY
HAVING TO DO WITH EQUAL
PROTECTION REVIEW.
IN OVERTURNING HARSHER HIGHER.
BUT THERE WAS NOTHING IN THE
SPIRIT OF THAT RULING.
THAT MAKES ANY SENSE.
IT OVERTURNED IS SAYING WE CAN
FIND A DISTINGUISHABLE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THESE ACTS
AND PENILE VAGINAL INTERCOURSE
AND THAT IS.
THAT ONE CAN RESULT IN PREGNANCY.
AND THE OTHERS CANNOT.
SEEMS RATHER COUNTERINTUITIVE
DOESN'T IT.
YOU CAN IMPOSE WHAT IS ACTUALLY
UNDER THE CODE SERIOUS BODILY
INJURY.
ON STAT RAPE.
AND IT'S NOT REGISTRABLE BUT
OFFENSES THAT CANNOT RESULT IN
THAT.
RECEIVE WHAT IS ESSENTIALLY A
HARSHER PENALTY.
THE DAY IN FACT -- REGISTRABLE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK.
AT THE ACTUAL PURPOSE OF THE
REGISTRY REMEMBER IT'S NOT THE
PUNISHMENT FOR THE CRIME.
IT'S A PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE THAT
HAS TO DO WITH CRIME SOLVING AND
KEEPING TRACK OF PREDATORS.
WHEN YOU REQUIRE SOMEBODY TO
REGISTER FOR AN OFFENSE THAT IS
NOT PREDATORY THAT THE PERSON
HAS LITTLE TO NO RISK OF RE
OFFENSE?
YOU START A CHAIN REACTION.
NUMBER ONE THAT STARTS WITH THE
PROSECUTION OF THE CASE.
TRIALS ARE FAR MORE LIKELY
BECAUSE SOMEONE IS NOT GOING TO
PLEAD TO THESE OFFENSES.
GIVEN THE REGISTRATION IF
SOMEONE IS CONVICTED.
YOU HAVE SOMEONE GOING IN AND IT
TAKES THE EXACT SAME AMOUNT OF
TIME TO REGISTER SOMEONE FOR ONE
OF THESE OFFENSES.
AS IT TAKES TO REGISTER A SERIAL
RAPIST OR SERIAL CHILD MOLESTER.
THAT MEANS A POLICE OFFICER IN
EVERY CITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS SITTING SPENDING
THEIR TIME.
REGISTERING ONE OF THESE NO RISK
OFFENDERS RATHER THAN FOLLOWING
AROUND A NEWLY RELEASED SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATOR.
OR DOING COMPLIANCE CHECKS WHICH
THEY SHOULD BE DOING FOR OTHER
HIGH RISK REGISTRANT IT IS BEEN
pENFORCEMENT RESOURCES ON SEX
OFFENDERS.
IS DEVOTED. TWO REGISTRANT JUST
THE PAPERWORK. FOR NO RISK TO
LOW RISK OFFENDERS.
IT ISN'T SIMPLY A MATTER OF
FAIRNESS.
IT'S A MATTER OF PUBLIC
[inaudible]
SAFETY.
I WILL CLOSE WITH ONE EXAMPLE
WHILE I WORKED IN A CHILDREN'S
ASSAULT CLINIC CALLED STEWART
HOUSE OUT OF THE RAPE TREATMENT
CENTER SANTA MONICA. ONE OF THE
LAST CASES I HANDLED.
WAS THAT OF A PARENT CALLING THE
POLICE.
BECAUSE HER DAUGHTER WHO WAS A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD SENIOR IN
HIGH SCHOOL ON THE BASKETBALL
TEAM.
WAS IN A CONSENSUAL RELATIONSHIP.
WITH A FELLOW HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT.
AND THAT HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT SHE
WAS.
EIGHTEEN THE MOTHER WAS DEVOUTLY
RELIGIOUS.
AND SHE FELT THAT BECAUSE HER
DAUGHTER WAS IN A SAME SEX
RELATIONSHIP.
IT MUST HAVE BEEN THE FAULT OF
THE EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD.
THEREFORE SHE CALLED THE POLICE.
AND THAT CASE WAS INVESTIGATED.
AND THAT EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD BAN
HAS.
POLICE DOCUMENTS POLICE REPORTS
RECORDING THIS ALLEGED CRIME.
THE MOTHER THEN CALLED THE UC
SCHOOL.
WHERE THE GIRL HAD GOTTEN A FULL
SCHOLARSHIP?
AND BECAUSE THE GIRL HAD USED
ARE YOU SEE E. MAIL THAT SHE
RECEIVED FOR HER NEXT INCOMING
FRESHMAN YEAR.
IN SENDING AN INNOCUOUS EMAIL TO
THE DAUGHTER.
MANAGED TO GET THE SCHOLARSHIP
RESCINDED.
DO YOU SEE SCHOOL.
SO THE DAUGHTER [inaudible]
AND AND THE DAUGHTER.
IT WAS THE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
WAS ACTUALLY THE PERSON WHO
ASKED THE EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD OUT
ON THEIR FIRST DATE.
THEY WERE IN A LOVING
[inaudible]
COMBINED RELATIONSHIP.
AND IT WAS ONLY BECAUSE OF THIS
MOTHER'S RELIGIOUS BELIEFS.
AND THE FACT THAT SHE THOUGHT
SHE COULD PREVENT HER DAUGHTER
FROM BEING GAY.
BY TAKING OUT HER REVENGE ON
THIS EXEMPLARY EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD.
THAT EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS LIFE WAS
ALREADY RAW AND I COULDN'T STOP
THE SCHOLARSHIP FROM BEING
RECENT IT I COULDN'T STOP HER
FROM GETTING IN TROUBLE AT
SCHOOL AND THEY WERE LOOKING AT
EXPELLING HER.
THE ONE THING I WAS ABLE TO STOP.
WAS THAT SHE WAS NOT PROSECUTED
SO SHE DIDN'T BECOME A SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY.
AND IF I HAD NOT BEEN ABLE TO
STOP THAT.
THE REST OF HER LIFE WOULD HAVE
BEEN RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WHICH FOR
TWENTY YEARS HAS LED THE EAGLE
IN THE STATE'S FIGHT FOR FULL
LGBT Q. EQUALITY.
WE ARE PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY AS
A CO SPONSOR OF SB.
ONE FORTY FIVE WHICH WILL
ADDRESS ONE HIGHLY
DISCRIMINATORY WAY THAT OUR
STATE'S LAWS STREET LGBT Q.
YOUNG PEOPLE.
WHO ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
CRIMINALIZED EVEN FOR A
CONSENSUAL ACTIVITY?
A TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN NATIONAL
STUDY OF FORTY THOUSAND
STATUTORY RAPE RECORDS FOUND THE
INCIDENTS INVOLVING SAME SEX
SEXUAL ACTS WERE SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE LIKELY TO RESULT IN A REST.
AND MORE SO WHEN WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF A ROMANTIC
RELATIONSHIP.
THOSE RESULTS LED THE STUDY'S
AUTHORS TO CONCLUDE THAT THE
ARRESTS WERE DRIVEN BY INVALID
FACTORS SUCH AS PARENTS'
DISCOMFORT WITH THE MERE THOUGHT
OF THEIR CHILD BEING IN A SAME
SEX RELATIONSHIP.
WHEN YOUNG LGBT Q. PEOPLE WHO
ARE ENGAGED IN CERTAIN TYPES OF
VOLUNTARY INTERCOURSE ENTER THE
COURTS IN THIS CONTEXT?
JUDGES UNDER CURRENT LAW ARE NOT
GRANTED THE SAME DISCRETION TO
DETERMINE.
BASED ON THE FACTS OF THE CASE
WHETHER THEY SHOULD BE REQUIRED
TO REGISTER.
LAWS THAT UNJUSTIFIED WE TREAT
CERTAIN TYPES OF INTERCOURSE AS
MORE EGREGIOUS.
THAN OTHERS OFTEN KNOWN AS
SODOMY LAWS HAVE BEN ENACTED
AND INVALIDATED THROUGHOUT OUR
NATION'S HISTORY.
THEY PRIMARILY TARGET PRIVATE
INVOLUNTARY ACTS BETWEEN PEOPLE
OF THE SAME GENDER AND ARE
MOTIVATED BY A DESIRE TO PREVENT
NON POCREATIVE SEX AND SEX
OUTSIDE OF MARRIAGE.
SIMILARLY THE OUTDATED LAWS THAT
SB ONE FORTY FIVE THAT SEEKS TO
AMEND HAVE A DISCRIMINATORY
IMPACT ON YOUNG LGBT Q. COUPLES.
THEY ALSO HOWEVER PUT ALL YOUNG
COUPLES WHO ENGAGE IN CERTAIN
TYPES OF VOLUNTARY INTERCOURSE
AT RISK OF IRRATIONALLY BEING
PLACED ON THE REGISTRY.
THIS BILL SIMPLY ALIGNS
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
SPECIFIED VOLUNTARY ACTS WITH
OTHER EXISTING REQUIREMENTS.
REGISTRATION FOR YOUNG LGBTQ
PEOPLE WHO POSE NO RISK TO THEIR
COMMUNITY.
ONLY COMPOUNDS THE SOCIETAL
BARRIERS THAT TO HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT THE LGBTQ PEOPLE
ALREADY FACE.
SB ONE FORTY FIVE IS A SENSIBLE
AND NECESSARY BILL.
WE THANK SENATOR WINNER FOR
ADVANCING THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AS WELL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YOU CAN
COME TO THE MIKE.
I JUST INDICATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
JANICE BALOCHI ALLIANCE FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL SEX OFFENSE LAWS.
DONNIE FOR RUNNING CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THAT WAS TERRACE RESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO AND SUPPORTED.
CHANCE OVER STING ALLIANCE FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL SEX OFFENSE LAWS
STRONG SUPPORT.
STEVE CANTRELL'S INDIO
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT.
STRONG SUPPORT CREEK INTRO.
ALEX TUITION CITRUS HEIGHTS I
SUPPORT.
JAMIE TO FOR A CONCORD
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
YOUR SILENCE AN AWFUL
CALIFORNIA'S SUPPORT.
MIKE GRIFFITHS FROM FRESNO
COUNTY AND SUPPORT.
THERE AGAIN ALL A FORMAL REPORT.
YOU'RE A CONNOR FROM YOLO COUNTY
SUPPORT.
MIKE MATANYA THE GROVE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORT.
CHARLES LOPEZ OUTGROWTH STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
LOS SANTOS ORANGE COUNTY IN
SUPPORT -- WILLOWS ROOM ZAVALA
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
RICHARD NICOLAS SACRAMENTO
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MONA MAY ONLY A SEARS OIL
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SAID THE MINE ORANGE COUNTY IN
SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
FAIRY HANNAH LOS ANGELES COUNTY
STRONG SUPPORT.
MARINE CORPORAL KINDA JAMES IN
DRESS WHEELER SAN DIEGO COUNTY
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
ELIZABETH REYES.
THOSE WITH FREEZE PASADENA
CALIFORNIA.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY STRONG
SUPPORT.
LIKE A DOCTOR OFF ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
FRANK ARNETT RIVERSIDE COUNTY
STRONG SUPPORT.
RUSTLER CONSENT PORT.
SABRINA CONCERN.
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
THREE'S MáS SACRI SUPPORT.
BOB MARLEY SAN PEDRO CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY A REALLY ABOVE THOSE
CELL CALABASAS I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
CLIFF MáS SANTA CRUZ SUPPORT.
GINA REALLY BUT SO FROM
CALABASAS I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
BLESS LOZANO SOME OF THEIR
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
BORN HAWKINS FORGE COUNTING
STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO MAY HAWKINS ORANGE COUNTY
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
TARA COACHING NOW SACRAMENTO
STRONG SUPPORT.
AARON BROWN CENTER ST CISCO
WE ARE HERE IN EL DORADO COUNTY
I URGE YOU TO
URGES SUPPORT SENATOR WINNERS
BILL THANK YOU.
WELL I'M SURE IT'S CISCO STRONG
SUPPORT.
KRISTIN DEANGELO SWAP SACRAMENTO
STRONG SUPPORT.
JAMES BIRCH REPRESENTING -- THE
SAINT JAMES INFIRMARY AND THE
ANTI PLEASED HER PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT BALKANS.
MY GOAL SANTA CLARA AND SUPPORT --
GLADDEN REPRESENTING FREED
PREDICATION STRONGLY SUPPORT.
EUGENE DAY FREEDOM TO EDUCATION
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
PEARL CALLAHAN WITH SACRAMENTAL
SWAP WITH SONG SUPPORT.
CRITICALLY SUNNYVALE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
ELLEN JOHNSON ACTS ALL STRONG
SUPPORT TECHNICALITY.
JAMES JOHNSON SWAP SACRAMENTO
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
CITY BLOCK LOS ANGELES SUPPORT.
ADAM HOCHBERG BURBANK CALIFORNIA
I SUPPORT.
ALLEN SALAS DOWNEY CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT.
M. A. SMITH SACRAMENTO COUNTY A
PM MCDANIEL SACRAMENTO COUNTY I
SUPPORT.
JUSTIN SMITH STUDIO CITY
CALIFORNIA HIGH SUPPORT.
DAVID WHAT HAD PASADENA
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORT.
RATIO BLOOM SACRAMENTO COUNTY
STRONG SUPPORT.
JANUARY TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
WILLIAM THE REALISTS ORANGE
COUNTY SACRAMENTO COUNTY STRONG
SUPPORT.
TIM MOORE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
ERIN HANEY ON BEHALF OF CUT
FIFTY WE SUPPORT.
FRANKLIN Z. GROVER BEACH
CALIFORNIA AXLE BOARD MEMBERS
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MARK JENKINS CITY OF LOS ANGELES
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ALEXANDER GETTING -- CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER AND BOARD MEMBER
OF AXLE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JIM CRAIG FROM SONOMA COUNTY
STRONG SUPPORT.
I AM BUYING CAM FROM SACRAMENTO
AND SUPPORT.
AND RICHARD ROLE IN THE
CLASSROOM TEACHER FOR THIRTY
THREE YEARS MANDATED REPORTER.
I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND THERE ARE WITH EUROPE FROM
SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THE ROLE WOULD YOU REVEREND ARE
ALL GONE COUNTY ON PLEASE -- A
YOUNG FOODS -- SAPPORO THE THESE
ARE THE SYSTEM OF THE THE THE
CRIMINALS YOU THANK YOU -- JASON
MORE -- SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SUPPORT.
RAFEAL SELLERS ARE ME VALLEY
MARIN COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
LEE LET THEM SEE STANISLAUS
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THEN DEMPSEY OUR COUNTY
SUPPORTED.
DAVID ADLER FROM SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
DAVE HOW ALAMEDA ACCOUNTING
STRONG SUPPORT.
ROGER ANY CUT FROM MODESTO
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSMAN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR QUALITY JUSTICE FOR
US.
DAVID AARON EL DORADO COUNTY
IT'S TIME IT'S TIME FOR EQUAL
TREATMENT UNDER THE LAW PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES. OH
SORRY.
GO TO DO THAT.
WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THERE MAY BE SOME
OPPOSITION HERE SO.
HI IS THERE ANY -- OP OF ANYONE
ERE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
[inaudible]
PART.
SEEING NONE WE CAN NOW HAVE OUR
DISCUSSION.
LIKE TO KNOW ALL RIGHT SO I I DO
HAVE SOME COMMENTS [inaudible]
I'M.
SIR WIENER I WANNA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COURAGE TO
HAVE.
BROUGHT THE BILL I THINK IT WAS
TWO YEARS AGO NOW.
THAT FIRST CORRECTED ARE SIX
REGISTRY -- CALIFORNIA AND IN.
SO OFTEN WE AS A STATE ARE
TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
BUT WE OVER CORRECT.
ANDWE IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF OUR
ONE SIZE FITS ALL SIX REGISTRY
RULES.
WE REALLY PUT A TERRIBLE BURDEN
ON NOT ONLY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BUT ON PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE.
AND NO ONE HERE WANTS TO HAVE.
SEXUAL PREDATORS VIOLENT SEXUAL
OFFENDERS.
ARE YOU KNOW OTHER CATEGORIES OF
TO BE -- TO HAVE ACCESS TO
EITHER KIDS OR WE WANT TO HAVE.
THEM ON RIDGE STREET WE WANT TO
HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT BE ABLE TO
MONITOR THAT REGISTRY -- AND AS
OUR WITNESS FROM LA COUNTY
REFERENCE YOU WANT. TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO REALLY -- WHEN WE SAY
MONITOR MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
FOLKS ARE IN THE PLACE WHERE
BECAUSE PART OF THE REGISTRY IS
THAT YOU MUST INDICATE WHERE YOU
LIVE AND ALL THOSE THINGS -- BY
OUR RIDICULOUS ONE SIZE FITS ALL
RULES AND BY NOW THIS
DISCRIMINATORY AND I'M SURE
THEY'RE STILL MORE THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE CORRECTED.
WE HAD SUCH A LARGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT WE ARE NO LONGER IT
WASN'T IT WAS NO LONGER REALLY
USEFUL FROM A PUBLIC SAFETY
POINT OF VIEW.
WHICH MAKES NO SENSE SO I WANT
TO REALLY THANK YOU.
AND THEN THIS CORRECTION.
IS ALSO ESSENTIAL BECAUSE WE
HAVE SITUATION NOW WHILE THIS
CORRECTION DOESN'T.
IMPACT THIS PER SE.
IF YOU'RE MANDATORY REPORTER
WHICH TEACHERS ARE.
AND YOU YOU CAN HAVE A LOT TO
STUDENTS IN YOUR SENIOR CLASS
THAT ARE.
EIGHTEEN AND YOU CAN HAVE
STUDENTS IN YOUR CLASSES THAT
ARE IN SAME SEX RELATIONSHIPS
ONCE EIGHTEEN ONCE NOT.
IN YOUR THEN IN THIS GRAY AREA
IT'S IT BECAUSE TECHNICALLY
UNDER THE LAW.
IF A PERSON IS UNDER EIGHTEEN
THEY ARE NOT CONSENSUAL.
SO.
AND NOW CLEARLY THIS DOESN'T
REMOVE.
THE ONUS ON A MANDATORY REPORTER
BUT IT CERTAINLY.
LIMIT THAT PROSECUTION ON THE
SAME SEX -- INDIVIDUALS -- OR
EVEN FOR THAT MATTER ON
HETEROSEXUAL AND COUPLES BECAUSE
OF THE BIZARRE DISTINCTION.
I CAN'T HELP BUT THINK ABOUT THE
CLINTON -- WHATEVER WILL LEAVE
THAT ALONE LEWINSKI SIT
CIRCUMSTANCE BUT SO WE HAVE
THESE BIZARRE DISTINCTIONS WHICH
REALLY GREW OUT OF A PREJUDICE
AND HAVE NO.
NO BEARING NOW SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THIS.
I WOULD -- SAY THAT WE ALSO
PROBABLY NEED TO CORRECT.
IN THE FIRST BILL WHERE WE
CREATED THE TEARS WE PROBABLY
SHOULD HAVE HAD THE ABILITY TO
BE.
RE TIERED AUTOMATIC VERSUS THE
INDIVIDUAL HAVING TO PETITION
FOR IT SO MAYBE WE CAN LOOK AT
THAT IN THE FUTURE BUT TODAY WE
ARE JUST DEALING WITH.
CHANGING THIS DISCRIMINATORY
TORY PRACTICE TOWARDS THE
DEFINITION OF INTERCOURSE.
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING IT.
AND YOU MAY CLOSE.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS
AND I KNOW TWO YEARS AGO WHEN WE
DID THE THE TEAR REGISTRY
BECAUSE THESE KIDS THAT THE
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD WHO HAS SEX
WITH -- THE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD --
AND HAS TO THEN GO ON THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY -- WERE AND
THAT THAT WOULD BE A LIFETIME
REGISTRY -- AND AND NOW -- ONCE
THAT BUILD WE DID TWO YEARS AGO
GOES INTO EFFECT ON IN A COUPLE
YEARS -- TOO LONG BUT BETTER
LATE THAN NEVER I'LL STILL BE A
TEN YEAR REGISTRY.
AND WHAT THIS BILL -- THIS BILL
IS ABOUT A FEW THINGS IT'S ABOUT
GETTING RID OF A HIGHLY
IRRATIONAL -- DISTINCTION AND ON
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY --
DISTINCTION THAT AFFECTS REAL
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND THAT CAN
REALLY RUIN PEOPLE'S LIVES --
BUT IS ALSO PART OF A BROADER
EFFORT THEY WERE ENGAGING IN --
TO TRY TO KEEP OUR LGBT YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE SAFE AND THE SOCIETY
TELLS LGBT YOUNG PEOPLE IN SO
MANY WAYS WAYS WHETHER TEENAGERS
OF CHILDREN.
DECIDED TELLS AND THAT THEIR
LIFE HAS NO VALUE -- THAT THEY
ARE -- THAT THEY SHOULD JUST GO
AWAY AND THAT'S WHY WE SEE THE
OBSCENE SUICIDE RATES AMONG LGBT
YOUTH.
OBSCENE RATES OF BULLYING AND
THEN WE SEE CRIMINALIZATION OF
LGBT YOUNG PEOPLE AND AND WE WE
GOT TO MOVE AWAY FROM THAT WE
GOT TO KEEP THESE KIDS.
SAVE WE HAVE TO CONVEY TO THEM
IN NO UNCERTAIN TERMS THAT THEIR
LIVES HAVE VALUE AND THAT WE
WANT THEM TO BE HAPPY AND
HEALTHY MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THIS FILL.
DON'T HAVE A MOTION -- MOVIE
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION.
OF WE WILL DO THE ROLL CALL
RIGHT NOW BUT OBVIOUSLY WILL
HAVE TO BE HOLDING IT OPEN.
I SINCE WE ARE MISSING SOME
MEMBERS BUT LET'S DO THE ROLL
CALL.
OKAY AS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD JACKSON
MITCHELL MORALE [inaudible]
WIENER.
WIENER AYE TO THE BILL WILL BE
HELD OPEN.
THANKS VERY MUCH -- ALL OF THE
WITNESSES NOT ONLY DOES VIEW
STATE THE TABLE BT EVERYONE
ELSE WHO CAME AND SPOKE.
AND WILL NOW GO TO YOUR NEXT
BILL SENATOR WIENER.
WHICH IS UP BY TEN OF FOUR AND
IT'S SB
.
TWO THREE THREE THANK YOU FOR
SURE.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR -- AND I'D LIKE
TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US
AND FOR AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS.
ON THE BILL -- COLLEAGUES ARE
SENATE BILL -- TWO THIRTY THREE
IS A OF ITS OF I SHOULD VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL -- TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE KEEPING A SEX
WORKERS -- SAFE AND HEALTHY --
IT DOES SO IN TWO WAYS -- FIRST
OF ALL SB TWO THIRTY THREE
INSURERS THAT SEX WORKERS I FEEL
SAFE COMING FORWARD TO REPORT.
VIOLENT CRIMES -- WITHOUT THE
FEAR THAT THEY THEMSELVES WILL
BE ARRESTED FOR SEX WORK OR DRUG
POSSESSION -- CRYING OUT RIGHT
NOW -- MANY SEX WORKERS DO NOT
COME FORWARD TO REPORT VIOLENT
CRIMES.
OUT OF FEAR THAT THEY THEMSELVES
ARE WILL BE ARRESTED WE KNOW
THAT OUR SEX WORKERS ARE AT
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE RISK OF
BEING VICTIMIZED -- IN TERMS OF
VIOLENT CRIMES WHETHER IT'S RAPE
OR ASSAULT OR KIDNAPPING ROBBERY.
AND PARTICULARLY WITH THE RECENT
CHANGES IN FEDERAL LAW.
MORE A MORE SEX WORKERS -- ARE
BEING FORCED TO ENGAGE IN SEX
WORK ON THE STREETS EVEN IF THEY
WOULD PREFER TO DO SO -- IN A
SAFER ENVIRONMENT SUCH AS ONLINE
THEY NOW OFTEN HAVE NO CHOICE.
BUT TO OUR WORK ON THE STREET --
AND HAVE THAT INCREASED RISK OF
VIOLENCE -- AND THE LAST THING
WE SHOULD DO IS -- TELL THEM
THAT IF YOU COME FORWARD AND
REPORT.
A ROBBERY ARRAY PUTS OUT READ
THAT YOU MAY BE ARRESTED US OF
THE BILL WILL PROHIBIT OF THE
ARREST OF SEX WORKERS FOR SEX
WORKER -- SIX WORK RELATED
OFFENSES OR DRUG POSSESSION
OFFENSES IF THEY ARE COMING
FORWARD TO REPORT -- SPECIFIED
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT FELONIES.
ON IT -- ISN'T SERIOUS ABOUT
CRIMES.
IN ADDITION -- WE HAVE A AND A
RELATED PROBLEM MORE WE WANT.
SEC FOR OCCURS TO BE ABLE.
TO LOOK AFTER THEIR OWN SEXUAL
HEALTH.
A AND TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
AGAINST HIV AND OTHER SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS BECAUSE
SEX WORKERS ARE AT INCREASED
RISK.
OF INFECTIONS.
AND CURRENTLY A SEX WORKER --
CAN BE ARRESTED AND AS PART OF
THE PROBABLE CAUSE -- THE POLICE
CAN SITE THAT THE SET BUT THE
PERSON IS CARRYING MULTIPLE
CONDOMS -- SO WE'RE SENDING A
SIGNAL THAT IF YOU CARRY CONDOMS
WITH YOU TO PROTECT YOURSELVES.
YOU OF THAT CAN BE USED AGAINST
YOU AS PROBABLE CAUSE TO ARREST
YOU -- WERE IN COURT AS EVIDENCE
OF SEX WORK -- AND AGAIN WE WANT
SEX WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES PROTECT THEIR
SEXUAL HEALTH.
A AND WE SHOULD NOT BE SENDING A
SIGNAL BY CARRIER CONDOM
RECURRING A FEW CONDOMS WE'LL
GET YOU ARRESTED SO THE BILL --
PROVIDE SIDE -- POSSESSION OF
CONDOMS IS NOT EVIDENCE TO
SUPPORT PROBABLE CAUSE AND COULD
NOT BE INTRODUCED IN COURT -- AS
EVIDENCE OF SEX WORK -- SO --
THAT IS A BILL -- COLLEAGUES --
IT'S LONG OVERDUE -- I WENT ALSO
I RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLYMEMBER LAURA
FRIEDMAN WHO -- CARRIED A BILL
LAST.
GREAT WITNESSES YOU MAY PROCEED.
ON A REAL SENATORS.
MY NAME IS PEARL CALLAHAN.
IDENTIFY AS A SURVIVOR OF SEX
TRAFFICKING.
AS WELL AS SOMEONE WHO IS
ENGAGED IN SURVIVAL SEX.
AND HAS WORKED AS A CONSENSUAL
SEX WORK.
I WASRAISED IN THE INNER CITY
OF SACRAMENTO AN AREA CALLED OAK
PARK.
MY FATHER WAS A SHARECROPPER
FROM TEXAS AND HE RELOCATED HERE
FOR A BETTER LIFE.
MY MOTHER LEFT WHEN I WAS YOUNG.
AND HE BY HIMSELF REYES NINE OF
US.
BY WORKING THREE MINIMUM WAGE
JOBS.
I SHARED A TWIN BED WITH TWO OF
MY SISTERS IN EACH MONTH WHICH
STRUGGLE TO HALF OF WE ALWAYS
HAD MORE MONTH AT THE END OF THE
MONEY.
WHEN I WAS SIXTEEN YEARS OLD?
I DID SOMETHING THAT I SAID I
WOULD NEVER DO I GOT PREGNANT.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT I WAS GOING
TO DO AND I KNEW THAT THERE WAS
NO WAY.
THAT MY FATHER COULD EVEN
SUPPORT ONE MORE PERSON.
SO I HAD TO FIND A WAY TO
SUPPORT MY SON.
WELFARE WAS NOT AN OPTION.
MY FATHER TAUGHT ME.
THAT WE HAD TO WORK FOR
EVERYTHING WE GOT.
SO THAT WAS MY RESPONSIBILITY.
BECAUSE OF MY AGE IN MY
SITUATION HAD VERY LIMITED
RESOURCES TO DRAW FROM AND SO.
I ENTERED THE SEX TRADE.
ONCE IN THE TRADE.
I BECAME A TARGET FOR PREDATORS.
TO BE EXACT [inaudible]
SILENT.
WAS A MECHANISM.
SO THAT I COULDN'T REACH OUT AND
REPORT ANYTHING.
DOES IN NO TIME I WAS CAUGHT
THEY CALL IT BEING CAUGHT.
AND I BECAME A TRACKING THE
TRAFFICKING VICTIM.
I WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT A
GRAPHICALLY.
VIOLENT INCIDENT THAT HAPPENED
TO ME.
WHEN I WAS TRYING TO ESCAPE MY
CAMP?
OR TODAY THEY CALL THEM
TRAFFICKERS.
AND WHY I FEEL SO STRONGLY IN
PASSING BILL.
SB.
TWO THIRTY THREE I JUST GOTTEN
AWAY FROM MY PANTS.
AND MOVED INTO A WITH A SMALL
HOUSE IN A REALLY NICE
NEIGHBORHOOD THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THAT.
I MEAN I WAS LIKE SO HAPPY I WAS
OVER THE MOON AND I WAS WITH MY
FRIEND.
THAT ALSO ESCAPED [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
LIFE IS REALLY GOOD.
MY BROTHER AND HIS GIRLFRIEND
CAME OVER TO VISIT AND TO
CELEBRATE OUR NEW MOVE AND AS
BEING IN THE NEW HOUSE AND
EVERYTHING.
AND MY TWO FRIENDS PATENT BILL
THEY WERE ALSO THERE THEY ARE
THE ONES THAT HELPED US TO
ESCAPE.
AND SO WHILE WE WERE THERE BEING
HAPPY AND JUST TALKING AND
CELEBRATING.
THERE WAS POUNDING AT THE DOOR.
SO MY FRIEND AND I GOT UP.
WENT TO THE LIVING THE PEOPLE
THE PEOPLE TO SEE WHAT IT WAS
AND IT WAS FRANKIE SHE WAS
ANOTHER GIRL THAT WAS WITH
JOHNNY WE DO HER.
SHE WAS SOBBING AT THE DOOR SHE
WAS CRYING AND SAYING THAT
JOHNNY IT GOING CRAZY THAT HE
HAD BEATEN HER AND SHE NEEDED
SOME HELP.
WE CRACKED THE DOOR OPEN AND AS
SOON AS WE CRACKED THAT DOOR.
HE KICKED IT AT IT WAS KICKED IN.
I REMEMBER SEEING A GUN COMING
THROUGH THE DOOR.
THAT I WAS BEHIND THE DOOR
WHAT'S IT KICK THAT IN ME AND MY
FOR AT THEN I SAW AN ARM
ATTACHED TO THAT GOING TO
REALIZE THAT IT WAS JOHNNY.
MY FRIEND AND I RAN OUT THAT
DOOR.
WE RAN ACROSS THE STREET AND WE
CROUCHED BEHIND A CAR.
MY BROTHER HIS GIRLFRIEND HAD
ALSO RUN OUT LATE WE SOLVE THEM
RIGHT NOW.
WHEN WE READ WE WERE ACROSS
BEHIND THAT CAR WE THAT'S WHEN
WE HEARD THE GUNFIRE?
IT SEEMED LIKE IT WAS FOR EVER I
KNOW WAS JUST A FEW SHOTS BUT IT
SOUNDED IT JUST SEEMED LIKE IT
WENT OFF FOR EVER.
IT WAS SO EERILY QUIET.
WHEN WE CAME FROM BEHIND THAT
CAR WE WERE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT?
IF WE SHOULD GET OUT OR NOT
BECAUSE WHAT IF HE'S THERE WHAT
IF YOU KNOW HE'S GOING TO BE
LOOKING FOR US.
SO WE STOOD WEEK CROUCH BEHIND
THAT CAR FOR QUITE AWHILE AND WE
GOTTA.
AND WE WALKED TOWARDS THE HOUSE.
WE FINALLY WORKED UP THE NERVE
TO GO BACK INTO THE HOUSE.
WE WALKED SLOWLY. TO THE BACK OF
THE HOUSE TOWARDS THE BACK DOOR.
IT WAS A SIGHT I WILL NEVER
FORGET.
BLOOD WAS SPRAYED ALL OVER THE
LAUNDRY ROOM DOOR.
FLOOR AND WALLS.
SMEARED ON THE DOOR NEAR THE
LATCH WHERE THEY WERE SITES OF
STRUGGLE TRYING TO GET OUT THE
DOOR BECAUSE WE HAVE THE SAFETY
LATCH ON IT WAS PAINTED IN DEEP
RED.
IT LOOKED LIKE SOMEBODY HAD BEEN
KILLED THERE BUT WE COULDN'T
FIND A FRIEND.
PATENT BILL WHERE WHERE THE WE
SLOWLY MOVED OUT THAT BACK DOOR
AND WE COULD HEAR SIRENS.
WE NEVER CALL.
911- BUT THE NEIGHBORS HAD.
WE DISTURB THEIR PEACE.
THIS BEAUTIFUL WONDERFUL QUIET
NEIGHBORHOOD.
THERE WAS NOBODY IN THE BACKYARD
AND FOR A MOMENT WE WERE JUST
LIKE.
INCREDULOUS LIKE WHERE ARE THEY
WHERE IS EVERYBODY.
WE LOOKED OVER THE NEIGHBOR'S
FENCE WAS JUST WILL SMALL THREE
FOOT WHITE PICKET FENCE.
AND MY FRIEND BILL WAS LAYING ON
HIS.
BACK AND HE'D BEEN SHOT.
PAT WAS NOWHERE TO BE FOUND.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE WITHIN MOMENTS
WE HAD POLICE ALL OVER OUR HOUSE
WE HAD PARAMEDICS THAT WITH A
HELICOPTER HOVERING ABOVE WITH
THE SEARCHLIGHT.
AND THE REST REALLY WAS A BLUR.
THE POLICE THEY QUESTIONED US.
BUT WE COULDN'T TELL THEM IT WAS
JOHN.
WE KNEW THAT BECAUSE HE KNEW
WHERE TO FIND US.
IF WE TALKED.
HE WOULD KILL US.
IT WASN'T LIKE THE POLICE EVEN
REALLY TOOK A SERIOUS.
WE WERE MORE LIKELY TO GET
ARRESTED OURSELVES SO WE WEREN'T
WE WERE TOO AFRAID WE WERE GOING
TO SAY ANYTHING.
OUR SILENCE OUR SILENCE WAS ONE
OF THE MOST PAINFUL.
PARTS OF THAT EXPERIENCE NOT
BEING ABLE TO SAY ANYTHING.
BUT THAT WAS THE ONE THING THAT
KEPT ME AND MY FRIEND
[inaudible]
ALIVE.
AND WE WANTED TO BE FREE.
MY PAST EXPERIENCE WITH THE
POLICE WAS CLEAR.
I WOULD GET ARRESTED.
I WOULD GET IN TROUBLE IF I
REPORTED ME.
AND I JUST COULDN'T TAKE IT
ANYMORE I WANTED IT TO BE OVER.
PATTON BILL THEY WERE SHOT THAT
INCIDENT.
BILL WAS SHOT IT WAS THANK GOD
IT WAS JUST THE CLEAN THROUGH
AND THROUGH.
BACK THROUGH THE CHEST AND PAT
HE WAS SHOT IN HIS HEAD THROUGH
HIS HEAD.
BOTH MEN THEY LIVED AND SURVIVE.
BUT OUR SILENCE THE SILENCE. TO
LIVE THROUGH THAT AND NOT KNOW.
AND TO KNOW THAT THERE IS NO
HEALTH.
ON THE OTHER END NO HELP AT ALL
NO HELP.
THAT SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO
ANYBODY.
IF I WERE FREE TO REPORT
JOHNNY'S TRAFFICKING ME
[inaudible]
THREATENING ME.
BLACKMAILING ME TWISTING ME
RIGHT FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
THEM MY FRIENDS WOULD HAVE BEEN
SHOT.
NONE OF THAT WOULD HAVE EVER
HAVE [inaudible]
THAT'S WHY [inaudible]
THIS SB. TWO THIRTY THREE BILL
IS SO IMPORTANT. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE THAT ARE TRULY
VICTIMS HAVE A VOICE.
THEY'RE NOT SILENT MORE.
INCIDENCES LIKE WHAT I JUST
DESCRIBED HAPPEN ON A DAILY
BASIS.
APPRECIATE IF YOU COULD.
I'M SORRY.
AS A AS A MEMBER OF SOFT SWAP
SACRAMENTO I DO OUTREACH AND SO
NOTHING IS CHANGED.
I UNDERSTAND THE UNATTENDED
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF OUR
SILENCING BUT I JUST WANT THIS
BILL PASSED SO THAT THOSE PEOPLE
THAT ARE STILL OUT THERE THAT
DON'T HAVE A VOICE.
HAVE SOMEBODY TO SPEAK FOR THEM
[inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
THANK.
THANK YOU PRO.
SITUACIóN PRITCHETT ALL THE
EFFORTS OF SEX OFFENDERS -- TO
GET THIS BILL AND MANY LIKE IT
PASSED HONORABLE COMMITTEE.
IN TWENTY TWELVE HUMAN RIGHTS
WATCH ISSUED AN GROUNDBREAKING
REPORT ON THE USE OF CONDOMS AS
EVIDENCE AFTER CONDUCTING
INTENSIVE RESEARCH IN SAN
FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES NEW YORK
AND WASHINGTON DC.
THE REPORT INCLUDED A TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN SURVEY THAT
FOUND THAT 60% OF LGBTQ YOUTH
SEX WORKERS FEARED CARRYING
CONDOMS BECAUSE THEY COULD LEAD
TO TROUBLE WITH THE POLICE.
IT ALSO INCLUDED A TWENTY TWELVE
STUDY THAT FOUND THE JUST OVER
HALF THE SEX WORKERS SURVEYED
HAD GONE WITHOUT CONDOMS DUE TO
FEAR OF ARREST.
AS A RESULT OF THE STUDY THREE
OF THE FOUR CITIES INVOLVED HAVE
TAKEN SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO
PROHIBIT THE USE OF CONDOMS A
SEVENTH.
THE HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH REPORT
AND MANY LIKE IT PROVIDE AMPLE
EVIDENCE OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
COSTS OF A POLICY THAT ALLOWS
FOR THE USE OF CONDOMS AS
EVIDENCE.
IT'S PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD IF
CONDOMS CAN GET YOU ARRESTED
YOU'RE GAMBLING WITH YOUR
FREEDOM EVERY TIME YOU CHOOSE TO
USE THEM.
THIS VERY CLEARLY DISCOURAGES
SEX WORKERS FROM CARRYING
CONDOMS GRACING GREATLY
INCREASING THE RISK FOR SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS AND
UNWANTED PREGNANCIES AND IS
DIRECTLY AT ODDS WITH MANY OF
OUR STATE'S PUBLIC HEALTH
INITIATIVES.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICE OF AIDS FOR
INSTANCE PROVIDES CONDOM TO SEX
WORKERS AS AN AT RISK FOCUS OF
ITS CONDOM DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM.
THE SPELL OF A CONTRADICTION WE
COULD POSSIBLY HAVE OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT PROVIDING
CONDOMS TO A POPULATION OF SEX
WORKERS AND THEN HAVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARRESTING THOSE SEX
WORKERS FOR THE POSSESSION OF
WHAT MAY BE THOSE VERY SAME
CONDOMS.
SOMETHING'S GOT TO GIVE IN
WITHOUT A COMPELLING PUBLIC AND
INTEREST IN HAVING SEX WORKERS
FEEL FREE TO CARRY CONDOMS ONE
WOULD IMAGINE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE SPIRIT OF THIS PROVISION.
HAVE AN EQUALLY EARLY SIMILARLY
COMPELLING NEED FOR THE USE OF
CONDOMS IS EVIDENT.
WE HAVE NOT YET HEARD SUCH A
NEED ARTICULATED.
IN FACT IT APPEARS THAT THE
OPPOSITION FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
FAILED TO EVEN ACKNOWLEDGE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONSIDERATIONS
APPLY.
INSTEAD IT FOCUSES ON THE
ASSERTION THAT MATTERS OF
EVIDENCE AND PROBABLE CAUSE ARE
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND JUDICIAL
INTERPRETATION AND IN THE WORDS
OF THE CDA.
START A A NOT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
BUT THEY KNOW AS WE DO AND AS
THIS COMMITTEE DOES THAT
LEGISLATIVE INVOLVEMENT IN
EVIDENTIARY MATTERS IS ENTIRELY
APPROPRIATE WHEN A STRONG PUBLIC
INTEREST IS AT PLAY.
AND THEY KNOW AS WE ALL DO THAT
MATTERS OF PUBLIC HEALTH ARE
CONSIDERED A VERY COMPELLING
PUBLIC INTEREST.
AND FINALLY AS THE CDA
RECOGNIZES IN THEIR LETTER OF
OPPOSITION THE POLICY ISSUE HERE
HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED
SUCCESSFULLY IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHICH HAS LED TO THIS BILL BEING
ENDORSED BY THE SAN FRANCISCO'S
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
POLICE DEPARTMENT CITY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
AGAIN WHAT THIS BILL ASKS FOR
THE COMMON SENSE SOLUTION TO A
PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEM.
WE THANK SENATOR WINNER FOR HIS
WORK WITH SAINT JAMES INFIRMARY
ON THIS BILL AND FOR CONTINUING
TO PURSUE SEX WORKER CENTER
SOLUTIONS TO MATTERS THAT HAVE
BEEN TRADITIONALLY BEEN
ADDRESSED WITHOUT THEIR INPUT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND I THINK GOOD MORNING HAVE
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ACROSS YOUR
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND ALSO WE HAVE THE
FREE SPEECH COALITION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
MAXINE DUGAN OF THE EROTIC
SERVICE PROVIDERS LEGAL
EDUCATION AND RESEARCH PROJECT
AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL.
KRISTIN DEANGELO THE SEX WORKERS
OUTREACH PROJECT SACRAMENTO WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
SPELL.
TARA COCHIN AL SEX WORKERS
OUTREACH PROJECT SACRAMENTO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
RACHEL WEST U. S. PROSTITUTES
COLLECTIVE PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL VIOLENT ATTACK IS ANOTHER
THAT SEX WORKERS ON GUN REPORT
RAPE AND VIOLENCE AND SAID THEY
GET AWAY WITH IT.
AND THIS BILL WILL MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE THANK.
SAMMY MARTIN FOR EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ERIN HANEY FOR CUT FIFTY IN
SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
MANAGER MEMBERS MIKE MULLIGAN
BEHALF OF THE SITTING COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO'S WITH NOTED -- IN
SUPPORT.
JAMES JOHNSON SEX WORKER OUT
REACH PROJECTS AT SACRAMENTO
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
I NEED A ROGERS ON ME AFTER THE
ACLU AND SUPPORT.
YEAH MIKE DANIELS SAT COUNTY I
SUPPORT.
JUST CANNELLA NEWMAN'S CENTER
INTERN CISCO SUPPORT.
DAVID HERE AND PRIVATE CITIZEN
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LESLIE CALDWELL PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION I'M STANDING UP NOW
WE DID FILE A LETTER IN
OPPOSITION WE ARE IN --
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE CO SPONSOR
I THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT.
IN SPIRIT WE DEFINITELY WANT TO
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS.
SEEING NINE THERE I THINK THAT
WAS THEOPPOSITION REGISTERED
BUT IS THERE ANYONE ELSE READ --
OPPOSITION.
THE FIFTY TO OPEN UP.
ONE THE OTHER [inaudible]
ONE THEIR FINAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY BUT MORNING.
MEMBERS TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE IT'S RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
WE HAVE NO OBJECTIONS TO
COUNTIES HAVING THEIR OWN
POLICIES BECAUSE POLICIES
CONTENT TO THE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUAL CASES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE ASSESSMENT
OF WHETHER AN ITEM.
IS EVIDENCE SHOULD BE MADE BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THE COURTS ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS BECAUSE EACH CASE IS
UNIQUE.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
PROVIDES THAT ALL EVIDENCE IN A
CRIMINAL CASE IS ADMISSIBLE
EXCEPT BY TWO THIRDS VOTES OF
THE LEGISLATURE.
WHICH DEMONSTRATES A
CONSTITUTIONAL PREFERENCE FOR
ADMISSIBILITY -- ALSO PROVIDES
IMMUNITY FOR DRUG CRIMES
PROSTITUTION AND COMMITTING A
LEWD ACT IN PUBLIC TO ANYONE
REPORTING SPECIFIED CRIMES
WITHOUT ANY CORROBORATION.
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE OPPOSE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MUCH LOWER ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY AND
OPPOSITION -- TO SENATE BILL TWO
THREE THREE ON WE BELIEVE THAT
WHILE THIS BILL PURPORTEDLY
ATTEMPTS TO HELP ON CRIME
VICTIMS IT CREATES A SIGNIFICANT
INCENTIVE. TO DRUG OFFENDERS AND
DOES ENGAGING IN PROSTITUTION TO
CLAIM THAT THEY ARE VICTIMS OF A
VIOLENT CRIME TO AVOID ARREST.
PERHAPS MORE PROBLEMATIC IN THIS
BILL IS THE INAPPROPRIATE CHEFS.
ON THAT A GRAYSON NATURE VARIOUS
PHASES OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM THIS BILL PROHIBITS PEACE
OFFICERS.
FROM ENFORCEABLE ENFORCING THE
LAW AND MAKING AN ARREST SPACE
ON THE CLAIM OF A CRIMINAL
SUSPECT EVEN IN THE FACE OF
EVIDENCE TO THE CONTRARY.
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
ALREADY ACCOMMODATES PROTECTION
FOR PEOPLE SB TWO THIRTY THREE
SIX TO PROTECT AS SOME A SENATOR
WIENER MENTIONED -- US
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN BILLS
FROM LAST YEAR.
EVIDENCE OF VICTIMHOOD CAN BE
CONSIDERED IN THE CONTEXT OF
CHARGING DECISIONS ARGUED IN
CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS AND OFFERED
AS A FACTOR IN MITIGATION.
PEACE OFFICERS MUST BE ALLOWED
TO ACT BASED ON THE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
I SHOULD NOT BE PROHIBITED FROM
ENFORCING THE LAW SIMPLY BASED
ON THE CLAIM OF A PERSON WHO
COULD HAVE A STRONG INCENTIVE TO
BE LESS THAN.
TRUTHFUL.
ADDITIONALLY PROHIBITING THE
POSSESSION OF A CONDO FROM
PROVIDING A BASIS FOR PROBABLE
CAUSE DETERMINATIONS OR BEING
ADMITTED AS EVIDENCE TAKES
INFORMATION AWAY FROM PEACE
OFFICERS.
PROSECUTORS JUDGES AND JURIES
WHEN ALL THOSE ENTITIES HAVE
RESPONSE RESPONSIBILITIES TO
ASSASSIN ADDRESS SITUATIONS WITH
A TO TALLY OF CIRCUMSTANCES
AVAILABLE AND IN MIND.
ON FOR THOSE REASONS WE SPEC
FULLY ASK FOR YOU KNOW VOTE
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT -- COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
I'M.
CENTER WINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR --
A WITH RESPECT TO THE OPPOSITION
I WHAT YOU KNOW I I I THINK WHEN
YOU LOOK AT HOW THESE THINGS
ACTUALLY PLAY OUT.
OF WHAT WILL WE SEE FOR MANY
YEARS IS SEX WORKERS DON'T WANT
TO COME FORWARD -- AND AND
REPORT CRIMES -- AND WE NEED TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO DO THAT WE
NEED TO ENCOURAGE THEM.
TO A CARRY CONDOMS AND PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
AND THE BILL SIGNING STRIKES A
GOOD BALANCE IN PARTICULAR WITH
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS -- THAT WE
WORKED ON WHAT THE COMMITTEE --
VERY CLEAR THIS IS AND NARROWLY
FOCUSED -- BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION -- WE
DEFINITELY WANT SEX WORKERS TO
FEEL-- YOU'LL NOT ONLY
CONFIDENT BUT WE ONE HALF CRIMES
AGAINST SEX WORKERS REPORTED.
AND I THINK THAT THE ISSUES
RAISED BY THE DA'S I'M SURE
YOU'LL BE AND WORK DISCUSSION TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY WAY. TO
ADDRESS OR NOT BUT I THINK THAT
THIS IS.
IN A POSITIVE DIRECTION AND
APPRECIATE YOUR WITNESSES
TESTIMONY NOT BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY.
SO DO A ROLL CALL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE FLOOR SKINNER.
HI SKINNER HI MORE LOCK.
WELL LOOK NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL
MORALE.
NO AROUND NOW WIENER AYE WIENER
AYE.
RIGHT SO WE WILL KEEP THE BILL
ON HOLD BECAUSE WE ARE MISSING
MEMBERS AND APPRECIATE AND NOW
WE WILL.
HEAR FROM -- SENATOR SKINNER ON
ITEM ONE SB FORD
.
THANK YOU I MISTER VICE CHAIR
MEMBER.
WHO -- SB.
FORTY TWO IS A CONTINUATION OF A
BILL THAT I INTRODUCED AT THE
END OF SESSION LAST YEAR.
WHICH I KNEW WE WERE GOING TO
MOVE ON JUST BECAUSE IT WAS THE
END OF SESSION BUT I'M VERY
HAPPY TO BE BRINGING IT BACK
BEFORE US TODAY.
AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
TO DEAL WITH THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE -- IN OUR COUNTY IF IS
FACILITIES OBVIOUSLY MA'AM MANY
MORE PEOPLE ARE BEING HELD NOW
IN OUR COUNTY FACILITIES DUE TO
REALIGNMENT -- AND ARE COUNTY
FACILITIES RELEASE PEOPLE ARE
BSED ON THE TIME OF THE DAY
PROCESS THAT RELEASE.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENED IS THAT WE
HAVE HAD [inaudible]
TRAGICALLY PREVENTABLE DEATHS --
IN MY OWN DISTRICT A YOUNG WOMAN
JESSICA ST LOUIS WAS RELEASED
FROM SANTA RITA JAIL AT ONE
TWENTY FIVE IN THE MORNING.
SHE WAS GIVEN A PART TICKET.
PART IS THE TRANSIT -- THE LIGHT
RAIL TRANSIT IN THE AREA IS NOT
FAR FROM SAN REDUCE JAIL I HAVE
MYSELF WALKED IT FROM SATA RITA
TO PART. FOR PARTIES NOT OPEN IN
BEGIN OPERATING TWO HOURS AFTER
THIS YOUNG WOMAN WAS RELEASED.
THE AREA BETWEEN THE SANTA RITA
JAIL AND SUPPORT STATION IS BY
AND LARGE ISOLATED.
AND THERE'S NOTHING AROUND INTO
YOU GET RIGHT TO THE BART
STATION WHERE THERE IS THEN SOME
RESIDENCES BUT BETWEEN.
SANTA RITA JAIL AND THAT NOTHING.
AND WE ALREADY KNOW THAT THERE
ARE PREDATORY PEOPLE THAT.
HANG OUT NEAR JAILS HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS IN OTHERS BECAUSE
THEY'RE HOPING THAT WHEN A
PERSON'S RELEASED THEIR
VULNERABLE THAT THEY MIGHT.
MAYBE THEY CAN -- ENGAGING IN
THEIR TRADER WHO KNOWS WHAT.
BUT IN THIS INSTANCE.
YES GOOD SAINT LOUIS WAS FOUNDED.
RIGHT NEAR THE BART STATION.
AND WHAT EIGHT BEING RELEASED
WITH ONLY A BART TICKET.
RIGHT NOW UNDER THE LAW YOU
DON'T LET'S SAY YOU ARE -- WHEN
YOU ARE -- PUT INTO THE FACILITY
LET'S SAY YOU'RE IN POSSESSION
OF A CELL PHONE SOME OTHER
THINGS THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT.
TO HAVE THAT CELL PHONE --
CHARGED SO WHEN YOU'RE THEN
RELEASED THE THAT CELLPHONE MAY
BE DEAD.
AND YOU MAY HAVE NO ABILITY TO
CHARGE IT THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT.
TO ALLOW YOU TO MAKE A PHONE
CALL TO ARRANGE -- FOR SOME --
TRANSPORT HOME THERE'S YOU HAVE
NO MONEY -- IN MOST CASES AND SO
BASICALLY WERE CREATING AN
EXTREME VULNERABILITY SO THE
PURPOSE OF MY BILL IS TO END
LATE NIGHT RELEASES AND TO
ENSURE THE COUNTY JAILS OFFER
BASIC SERVICES SO THAT PEOPLE
CAN GET HOME SAFE.
FREE PHONE CALLS ACCESS TO CELL
PHONE CHARGERS TRANSPORTATION
COUNTY SUPPORT SERVICES WERE
SAFE PLACE TO WAIT UNTIL IT IS
NORMAL BUSINESS HOURS -- SO I
WOULD LIKE MY WITNESSES -- TO TO
NOW -- SPEAK WE HAVE -- CREATE
GOMEZ FROM THE YOUNG WOMAN'S
FREEDOM CENTER YOUNG WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER IS THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL.
AND THOMAS TURNER WHO IS THE
FATHER OF JESSICA ST LOUIS THE
YOUNG WOMAN I DESCRIBED.
IT'S JUST A CANNELLA NORTH
YEOMAN'S FREEDOM CENTER.
ON THE SECOND WE SWITCH STAFF ON
SO I'M JUST GOING ON AND THE
DECORATIVE DIRECTOR OF THE YOUNG
WOMAN'S FREEDOM CENTER.
AND I AM HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THE GETTING HOME -- SAFETY
ACT SENATE BILL.
SB.
FORTY TWO AND IT I JUST WANNA
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHO
THIS IS THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY
IMPACT ARM I AM ALSO PART OF THE
STORAGE FRIEDMAN COALITION I'M A
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PERSON.
AND A GROUP OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED
ON WOMEN AND GIRLS FROM THE
STATE -- WHO ARE FIRMLY
INCARCERATED -- IN SPECIFICALLY
AS AS A WOMAN -- BEING RELEASED
IN IN THE MIDDLEOF THE NIGHT
WITH NO SUPPORT WITH NO ACCESS
TO A PHONE -- WHEN WHEN WE HEARD
ABOUT THE TRAGIC DEATH OF
JESSICA ST LOUIS AND WERE ON
BUILDING IN COMMUNITY WE
ACTUALLY GOT HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF CALLS AND MESSAGES
FROM WOMEN ACROSS THE STATE?
WHO HAD BEEN PHYSICALLY AND
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED UPON RELEASE
COULD BEEN RELEASD -- IN JUST.
PAPER AT SUITS -- WHO DIDN'T
HAVE ACCESS TO CALLS ON AND?
ALSO FOR AMEND THIS DOESN'T JUST
IMPACT WOMAN ON ALSO YOU SEEN --
MOTHERS -- ELDERLY MOTHERS WHO
ARE GOING TO PICK UP THEIR SONS
DON'T KNOW WHAT TIME THEY'RE
GETTING OUT HAVE YOUNG CHILDREN
IN THE BACKSEAT. FOR HOURS
BECAUSE THERE'S NOWHERE ELSE FOR
THEM TO GO WHILE THEY'RE WAITING
FOR THAT FOR THEIR CHILD TO BE
RELEASED IN THE CHILDREN OF
SCHOOL THE NEXT DAY.
AND SO SIMPLE SOLUTIONS ARE LIKE
CENTER CENTERS SKINNER SAID
ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION ACCESS
TO ADEQUATE -- SUPPORT
CONNECTION TO SUPPORT SERVICES --
PHONE CALLS YOUR ABILITY TO HAVE
YOUR CELL PHONE CHARGE I KNOW I
KNOW.
ABSOLUTELY NOBODY'S PHONE NUMBER
BY HEART -- EXCEPT FOR MY OFFICE
BECAUSE I WASN'T CHANGES IN
TWENTY SIX YEARS.
ON AND SO AND AND THESE THIS
SIMPLE I'M SOLUTION ACROSS THE
STATE COULD SAVE.
SOME LIVES AND MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM.
SAFER SO WE'RE IN -- IN SUPPORT
OF OF THIS BILL IN IT AND THE
LAST THING I JUST WANT TO SAY IS --
YOU KNOW WE HAD STORIES OF WOMEN
WHO WERE TRAILED BY TAXI DRIVERS
AND DRIVERS WHO WERE WAITING
OUTSIDE OF SANTA RITA JAIL AND
OTHER JAILS ACROSS THE STATE
THING I WILL GIVE YOU A RIDE FOR
SEXUAL FAVORS.
AND SO WE'RE THINKING ABOUT HOW
DO WE CREATE COMMUNITY SAFETY
AND AS A FORMALLY INCARCERATED
WOMEN I KNOW THAT -- THOSE
CRITICAL CONNECTIONS IMMEDIATELY
UPON RELEASE ARE SUPER IMPORTANT
FOR MY OWN REENTRY AND TO HELP
CREATE SAFER COMMUNITIES
[inaudible]
MISTER TURNER.
GOOD MORNING GOD COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CHAIR PERSON -- I COME
THE DATES IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FORTY TWO IF I MAY BE ABLE TO
SHARE WITH YOU PHí
PERSPECTIVE.
I COME ALSO.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MY WIFE --
NEEDED TURNER.
JULY TWENTY EIGHTH WAS
[inaudible]
VERY TRAGIC.
DAY FOR US.
WE HAVE PRIDED OURSELVES. FOR
EVERY CHILD THAT WITH HAS EVER
COME.
WE ALSO NOW HAVE OUR OWN TRUE TO
BEFALL SECURE BUT WE'VE PROVIDED.
A SAFE.
WAY OF COMMUNICATION FOR EACH
AND EVERYONE OF THEM TO BE ABLE
TO REACH OUT TO US.
NO MATTER WHAT SITUATION THEY'RE
IN [inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY.
THIS DID NOT HAPPEN.
AT THE CELEBRATED THEIR HOW
DOLLARS A RELEASE I'M A DOLLAR A
DOLLAR WAS RELEASED.
AND GOLLY OUR NOT GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY.
THE CONTACT THE PARENTS.
SHE CERTAINLY KNEW NUMBER
BECAUSE SHE CALLED US SO MANY
TIMES.
I KEEP A SPECIAL PHONE BY MY BED.
O THAT EACH ABOUT CHILDREN CAN
REACH US.
BUT THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN.
SHE HAD NO OPPORTUNITY. TO MAKE
A PHONE CALL.
SHE WAS GIVEN [inaudible]
A TICKET.
THAT WAS REALLY USELESS.
BECAUSE THE SYSTEM WAS A RUNNING.
SHE WAS AXED TO EXIT
[inaudible]
THE FACILITY.
AND TO A VERY UNSAFE ENVIRONMENT.
I FEEL THAT TODAY THE SAME WAY
THAT THE CORONR CALLED ME. TO
TELL ME THAT MY DAUGHTER
[inaudible]
WAS THERE.
I FEEL LIKE THE SAME PHONE CALL
COULD BEING GIVEN TO HER. TO
TELL ME THAT SHE WAS A LIFE.
AS SHE WAS RELEASED.
I ONLY LIVE TWENTY MINUTES FROM
SELL RETAIL.
ADAM FORTUNATELY I WOULD BROKE
EVERY LAW PROBABLY IN SPEEDING.
TO BE THERE FOR MY TILE.
BUT THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
SO ALL TODAY.
I HOPE AND PRAY YOU FIND IN YOUR
HEART. TO BE ABLE TO PASS THIS
BILL.
BECAUSE HOW MANY MORE.
YOUNG MAN YOUNG WOMEN.
WILL HAVE TO SUFFER AND DIE
[inaudible]
BEFORE [inaudible]
THIS.
TRAGIC THINGS CORRECTED.
I THINK IT'S VERY EASY.
THERE'S JUST A FEW THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE DONE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S VERY HARD.
SO ALL TODAY.
I COME TO YOU FROM A PARENT.
THE HAS LOST.
A CHILD.
WHO HAS LOST?
SOMEONE VERY DEAR TO THEM
[inaudible]
EVERY BIRTHDAY [inaudible]
EVERY HOLIDAY.
NOW HAS BECOME.
A DARK SHADOW [inaudible]
SO PLEASE.
FIND IT IN YOUR HEARTS. TO PASS
THIS BILL.
SO THAT WE CAN STOP THE
SENSELESSNESS.
OF PEOPLE BEING HARASSED.
PEOPLE BEING KILLED.
PEOPLE SUFFERING AND FAMILY
SUFFERING.
I ASK YOU TODAY.
PLEASE DO SO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER TURNER WITH
GRIEF FOR YOUR LIFE.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DANIEL TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT --
HERE'S THIS BILLY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MIKE A DOCTOR OFFON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
AARON HANEY ON BEHALF OF CUT
FIFTY IN SUPPORT.
JAMES PERCH ON BEHALF OF THE
ANTI POLICE TERROR PROJECT IN
SAINT JAMES INFIRMARY IN FULL
SUPPORT. ONE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA.
HEALTH NETWORK.
ALSO ON THE HAVE A VILLAGE
CONNECT IS IN REAL STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
BECAUSE INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
LET OUT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT.
ESPECIALLY FROM.
JUST ONE DAY OVER.
AND I'M IN THE OUT IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT THE NEXT DATE I
THINK THREE O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING NO WAY TO GET HOME.
PLEASE.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NORMAN NELSON RESIDENT OF YOU'LL
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE CAN MAKE SOME ROOM AT THE
TABLE.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JESSICA.
GOOD MORNING -- I'M CHAIR AND
SENATORS LUCIA MUCH LOWER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO SB --
FORTY TWO FIRST I'LL LET ME SAY
MY DEEPEST SYMPATHY. FOR THIS
GENTLEMAN AND HIS LOSS I CAN'T
IMAGINE WHAT THAT MUST BE LIKE --
BUT WE MUST IMPOSE BASED ON THE
COSTLY AND BURDENSOME
REQUIREMENTS ON COUNTY JAILS
RELATIVE TO IN MAKE REALLY SAYS.
SOME OF WHICH WOULD BE
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE AND
EFFECTIVELY IMPOSSIBLE WITH
WHICH TO COMPLY.
WELL COUNTY JAILS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CARE OF
INMATES WHILE IN PHYSICAL
CUSTODY THE REACH AND
RESPONSIBILITY OF PUBLIC
ENTITIES CAN ONLY EXTEND SO FAR --
SHERIFF'S ALREADY YOU OFFER A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM TO IN MAKES.
A THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO STAY
IN CUSTODY.
STUDIO FACILITY FOR UP TO
SIXTEEN ADDITIONAL HOURS OR
UNTIL NORMAL BUSINESS HOURS
WHICHEVER IS SHORTER.
IN ORDER TO OFFER INMATES THE
ABILITY TO BE DISCHARGED TO A
TREATMENT CENTER -- DURING
DAYTIME HOURS.
HOWEVER SB FORTY TWO WILL
REQUIRE THE SHERIFF TO ALLOW THE
PERSON TO STAY IN JAIL OR OFFER
A SAFE PLACE TO STAY IF THE
INMATE DECLINES RELEASE DURING
EVENING AND EARLY MORNING HOURS.
SUCH A MANDATE CREATES SPACE AND
COST CHALLENGES WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS A SAFE SPACE IN
JAIL WOULD BE WE WOULD HAVE TO
KEEP AWAY FROM OTHER INMATES.
FURTHER IF THE PERSON DOES NOT
FEEL SAFE ENOUGH TO LEAVE THE
FACILITY BUT DECLINES THE OPTION
TO STAY.
SB.
FORTY TWO REQUIRES THE SHERIFF
TO PROVIDE FREE TRANSPORTATION
TO LOCATION OF THE PERSON'S
CHOOSING WITHIN THE COUNTY OR
WITHIN A HUNDRED MILE RADIUS
WHICHEVER IS FURTHER. FOR
GEOGRAPHICALLY LARGE COUNTIES
SMALL OVERALL COUNTIES WITH
STAFFING LIMITATIONS AND
COUNTIES THAT RELEASE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF INMATES ON
A DAILY BASIS.
THIS UNFUNDED MANDATE WOULD
CRIPPLED THE PROVISION OF OTHER
SERVICES AND TURN PEACE OFFICERS
AND SHERIFFS STAFFING TO DRIVERS
WHO SPEND THEIR DAYS TRAVERSING
THE COUNTY AT THE WHIM OF
RECENTLY RELEASED INMATES.
SEVERAL OF THE BILL'S MANDATES
ALSO CREATE MASSIVE LIABILITY
FOR COUNT COUNTY GOVERNMENTS.
BY REQUIRING TRANSPORTATION TO
ON THE LOCATION OF THE INMATES
CHOOSING PUBLIC STAFF COULD BE
FORCED TO UNWITTINGLY.
DR AN AT RISK IN MAY TO THE DRUG
DEALERS LOCATION FOR EXAMPLE.
PROVIDING A RELEASED IN MADE
THREE DAY SUPPLY OF ANY
NECESSARY MEDICATION CREATES
RISK TO THE RELEASED PERSON AND
OTHERS.
SINCE THERE IS NO LIMITATION ON
THE TYPE OF MEDICATION THAT MUST
BE GIVEN TO THE PERSON.
AND NO ABILITY TO SUPERVISE
APPROPRIATE.
LEADERS RELEASE INMATES.
SB FORTY TWO IS ALSO INTERNALLY
INCONSISTENT WHILE THE FINDINGS
AND DECLARATIONS BE MOLDED
NOTION THAT LATE NIGHT RELEASES
SUBJECT WOMEN. TO PREDATORS WHO
ARE FAMILIAR WITH COUNTY JAIL
NOT JAIL NIGHT RELEASE PRACTICES
I WAS JUST MENTIONED.
THE BILL REQUIRES THIS SHERIFF
TO MAKE THE RELEASE SANDERS
RELEASE PROCESSES AND RELEASE
SCHEDULES OF A COUNTY JAIL
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC AND POST
THEM ONLINE.
WELL WE UNDERSTAND A DESIRE TO
KEEP PERSONS RECENTLY.
RELEASED FROM CUSTODY STE.
SAFE THIS BILL IMPOSES A SERIES
OF EXPENSIVE UNWORKABLE MANDATES
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE I
REQUEST YOU NOBLE AND THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WE'LL START WITH SENATOR
MITCHELL AND SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MISTER
CHAIR -- WHEN IT'S THE PERFECT
TIME I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL?
QUESTION OF THE OPPOSITION I WAS
STRUCK BY YOUR COMMENT ABOUT AN
EXPECTATION THAT -- SHERIFF'S
WOULD BECOME DRIVERS WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY IS IT CURRENTLY
TO TRANSPORT INMATES TO A COURT
FOR COURT PROCEEDINGS.
THAT'S CERTAINLY THE DEPARTMENT
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
AND DO YOU HAVE A SPECIAL UNIT --
THAT THAT ENGAGES IN THAT IN
THAT TRANSPORT.
YES CENTER SOME OUTSIDE SOME
SHARE DEPARTMENTS TO YES.
BUT NOT ALL NOT ALL THOSE WHO
DON'T HAVE A SPECIAL UNIT HAD A
TRANSPORT INMATES TO COURT WELL
THEY STILL HAVE SHERIFF DEPUTIES
TO TAKE CARE BYE THAT THEY MIGHT
HAVE A SPECIAL AND LARGER
COUNTIES HAVE GOT IT SHOWS.
OKAY THAT.
SOLD THERE IS AN EXPECTATION
THAT SHERIFF'S TRANSPORT IN MY
CORRECT OKAY -- SECONDLY -- I
HEARD ALL THE OPPOSITION AND
WHILE MOST OF IT DEALT WITH WITH --
FISCAL CONCERNS I APPRECIATE
THIS IS NOT A FISCAL COMMITTEE.
YOU KNOW I'M I'M CURIOUS AS TO
WHETHER IF EITHER IN CONCERT
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
IF THERE'S ANYTHING THE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION HAS COME UP WITH ARE
GIVEN ANY THOUGHT TO ABOUT A
MORE APPROPRIATE WAY IN WHICH TO
RELEASE IT MIGHT -- OR WE ARE
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO DISCUSS --
THAT WITH THAT AUTHORS OFFICE
AND CONTINUE TO CONVERSATIONS
WITHIN OUR ASSOCIATION BUT
ABSENT THE BILL GIVEN THE NUMBER
OF DEATHS AND JUST THE ISSUES
WE'VE SEEN ACROSS THE STATE.
YOU ALL HAVE NOT PRO ACTIVELY
COME UP WITH IDEAS ARE POLICIES
OF SUGGESTIONS IN TERMS OF HOW
YOU CAN KEEP.
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE.
SAFE UPON THEIR RELEASE WELL
EACH COUNTY HAS THEIR OWN
PRACTICES SO AS AN ASSOCIATION.
ON IN ANY CONSIDERATION GIVEN I
APPRECIATE THE THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED ANY AS I LISTEN TO
YOU I THOUGHT LOW GFR SHARE FROM
OUR TRY TO AVOID THOSE COSTS AND
GIVEN.
THE LEVEL THE THE THE THAT
LEVERAGES THE WHAT'S THE WORD I
WHAT THE POWER THE AUTHORITY A
SHERIFF MAY HAVE -- WOULD YOU
HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS AROUND
COSTS IF THE SHERIFF USED HIS OR
HER DISCRETION AND RELEASE THE
ONE TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT
HOURS EARLY.
THERE REALLY STATE THEN YOU
WOULD HAVE THE EXTRA COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH CARRYING THEM
OVER YOU KNOW TWENTY FOUR HOUR
CYCLE OR TO THE NEXT DAY.
AND THAT BEEN CONSIDERED AT ALL
NOW THAT AGAIN THAT WOULD BE UP
TO EACH INDIVIDUAL SHERIFF AND
RIGHT NOW THEY HAVE THEIR THEY
HAVE DISCRETION.
AND THE VOLUNTARILY CAN DO DO
THAT SO WE DON'T SEE WHY YOU
WOULD NEED TO BE AND MANDATE.
AND AGAIN I MANDATE IS NOT JUST
THIS BILL MANDATING IS ALL THE
OTHER LEGISLATION THAT MANDATES.
THAT THEY ALL NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED TOGETHER AS FAR AS
BUDGET IS CONCERNED I'M CLEAR
AND I THINK THAT THIS THE STATE.
OFTEN YOU KNOW WE WE WOULD
PREFER NOT TO HAVE TO MANDATE
BUT IN INSTANCES WHERE THERE ARE
COUNTIES WHO HAVE FALLEN SHORT.
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE LOST THEIR
LIVES IN VICTIMIZED I'M ASSUMING
THOSE A COUNTIES WHO DON'T HAVE
THE VOLUNTARY PROGRAM WHERE THE
THIS THE SHERIFF CHOOSES TO USE
HIS OR HER DISCRETION?
IN TERMS OF TIME WE NEVER LEAVE
THAT'S WHAT FORCES US AS THE
STATE INTO THE MANDATE BUSINESS
BECAUSE THERE'S A LACK OF
CONSISTENCY AND CLEARLY -- LACK
OF SAFETY I APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSES -- AND AGAIN AT THE
PERFECT TIME OF LIKE -- TO MOVE
THE BILL PLEASE THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL SENATOR
BRADFORD.
I THINK YOU AND I WANT TO
COMMEND THE SENATOR OUT SKINNER
FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE FOR IT
THANKS TO COMMONSENSE MEASURE
THAT'S LONG OVERDUE.
AND I'M FRANKLY INSULTED AT THE
RESPONSE THAT THE CALIFORNIA DA
HOUSE IN REGARDS.
TO THE FISCAL COST BUT WHAT IS
THE FISCAL COST OF A LIFE.
AND I SIT HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING A FAMILY WHO LOST
THEIR DAUGHTER PATRICIA
RICHARDSON THAT YOU SHOULD BE
VERY FAMILIAR WITH.
SHE WAS A YOUNG AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMAN WHO WAS RELEASED AFTER ONE
AM.
FROM THE SHERIFF'S CUSTODY IN
MALIBU ALONG TO MASCO CANYON.
ONE THE MOST DARK.
DESOLATE WORLD YOU CAN FIND
ANYWHERE IN LA COUNTY.
AFTER ONE AM.
FORD FAMILY NOT TO FIND HER FOR
YOU DEAR AFTER THE FACT.
IN BITS AND PIECES BECAUSE SHE'D
BEEN RAVAGED BY ANIMALS COYOTES.
AND HOW DO YOU JUSTIFY LETTING
ANYONE GO AFTER ONE AM
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY ARE
WHETHER TO AND URBAN AREA OR
RURAL AREA.
AND TO SIT HERE AND SAY IT'S
ABOUT FISCAL COST IT COSTS YOU
NOTHING TAKE CAPTOR THERE FOR
ANOTHER EIGHT HOURS AND TELLS
THE DAYLIGHT.
IT COSTS YOU NOTHING TOLD OUR
AFFORD HER PHONE CALL TO HER
FAMILY JUST LIKE MISTER TURNER
WHO WOULD HAVE BEEN THERE.
AT AS SOON AS HUMANLY POSSIBLE
TO PICK HER UP A YOUNG LADY WHO
WAS RE ARRESTED ONLY FOR ODD
BEHAVIOR AT A RESTAURANT SHE HAD
COMMITTED NO CRIME.
AND SHE LOST HER LIFE SO TO SAY
THIS IS ABOUT FISCAL.
CONSTRAINT ON THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
I SAY SHAME ON THE SHARES
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
I WOULD LIKE TO TO THE SECOND AT
LEAST A PORTION OF THAT I DON'T
KNOW MY COUNTY STILL DOESN'T.
BUT THEY OF ONE OF MY COUNTIES
WOULD LET PEOPLE OUT TWELVE
THIRTY ONE O'CLOCK AT NIGHT
THEIR JAIL IS IN THE MIDDLE OF
NO WHERE.
AND I COULD NEVER UNDERSTAND WHY
THEY WOULD DO THEIR WHAT DO THEY
THINK THOSE PEOPLE GOING TO
HITCH A RIDE OR THERE'S A BUS OR
I MEAN.
THIS IS THE KIND OF ATTITUDE I
THINK THAT MAKES PEOPLE REALLY
QUESTION THE GOOD FAITH OF OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT SOMETIME SO I
THINK IT REALLY BEHOOVES.
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DEMONSTRATE.
THAT IT ALSO HAS A LEVEL OF
COMPASSION AND HUMANITY THAT ALL
HUMAN BEINGS TO SERVE.
AND WHEN THIS KIND OF THING
HAPPENS I'M HOPING THAT WE HAVE
STOPPED THAT PRACTICE IN.
IN ONE OF MY COUNTIES.
EACH TEACHER FROM THE EXIST AND
IT REALLY DOES IT'S NOT
SURPRISING THAT PEOPLE END UP
HIT BY CARS FOR EXAMPLE MY
COMMUNITY ON THE ONE ã ONE
FREEWAY THAT'S THE ONLY AVENUE
THEY HAVE TO EVEN TRY TO CATCH A
RIDE SOMEWHERE.
WHERE TO BE WALKING ALONG THE
FREEWAY BECAUSE IT'S LET?
ME IN.
THESE ARE JUST THESE ARE JUST.
COMPASSIONATE THINGS THAT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE NEED A HECK
OF A LOT OF MONEY TO DO THEM BUT
IT'S AN ATTITUDE IN AND AND AND
OUTLOOK THAT I THINK.
NEEDS TO BE.
RIVER RE EVALUATED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS YOU KNOW THEY
SHOULD BE WORKING WITH US AND
NOT -- DEFYING THOSE LEVELS OF
HUMANITY THAT I THINK WE ALL ARE
ENTITLED TO EXPECT.
CENTERS CAN OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER BRAZIER.
I THINK WHAT YOU'VE HEARD IS
THAT.
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL.
IS TO PREVENT AVOIDABLE DEATHS.
WE DO NOT NEED.
MISTER TURNER SHOULD NOT HAVE
HAD TO COME HERE.
ON IN THE FAMILY OF THE YOUNG
WOMAN THAT SENATOR BRADFORD
REFERENCED SHOULD NOT HAVE HAD
TO DEAL WITH WHAT THEY DEALT
WITH.
CERTAINLY THE SPONSORS AN IRA
AWARE THAT.
WE WILL HAVE TO BE DOING SOME
NEGOTIATIONS ON THE CONTENT OF
THE BILL DO COSTS.
AND SO THEIR POT PARTS THAT MAY.
BE MODIFIED.
BUT AT MINIMUM.
BEING ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
FREE CALLS AT MINIMUM BEING ABLE
TO KNOW THAT YOUR CELL PONE IS
CHARGED.
AT MINIMUM VARIOUS THINGS THAT
ARE IN HERE.
I MAKING SURE THAT ALL COUNTIES
WOULD OFFER THE ABILITY TO STAY
TILL.
I'M DAYLIGHT HOURS WHILE OUR
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION REP
MENTIONED THAT YOU KNOW MANY
COUNTIES DO.
IT IS NOT REQUIRED SO THAT IS
ELECTIVE AND I'M SURE THERE ARE
SOME COUNTIES THAT DON'T.
SO -- WE OBVIOUSLY WILL BE
HAVING THOSE DISCUSSIONS IF WE
ARE SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING THE
BILL TO APPROACH -- BUT I DO NOT
WANT A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE ANYONE
LIKE MISTER TURNER HAS TO BE.
COME TO SACRAMENTO AND TESTIFY
UNTIL SUCH AS THIS.
SO WE WANT TO FIX OUR PRACTICE
IN WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR MITCHELL'S
MADAM SECRETARY RIDGE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE MOORLACH AYE
MOORLACH AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE [inaudible]
WIENER.
PASSES FIVE ZERO AND WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN.
THAT TAKES US TO OUR FINAL BILL.
SENATOR SKINNER WE HAVE SB
.
THREE NINETY FOUR THANK YOU I'VE
MISSED RIDE SHARING MEMBERS.
SO SB THREE NINETY FOUR WILL
ALLOW.
WITH THIS AGREEMENT SO REQUIRES
THE AGREEMENT BY THE JUDGE THE
DA AND THE PUBLIC DEFENDER.
IT WOULD ALLOW. FOR A DIVERSION.
PROGRAM FOR A PRIMARY CARE GIVER
WHO IS CHARGED WITH THE KIDS A
CRIME -- AND AGAIN AS I
INDICATED THIS WOULD REQUIRE
AGREEMENT BY THE JUDGE THE DA
AND THE PUBLIC DEFENDER.
NOW THE POINT WHY SAID THE
PRIMARY CARE GIVER WHILE WE ARE.
CONCERNED OF COURSE ABOUT THOSE
PEOPLE.
OF A PARENT OR A CUSTODIAL
INDIVIDUAL OF CHILDREN THIS
COULD BE SOMEONE WHO IS THE
PRIMARY CARE GIVER TO AN ELDERLY
RELATIVE OR TO A DISABLED PERSON.
AND THE POINT BEING IS THAT.
WE CREATE GREAT COSTS TO THE
STATE.
WHEN WE HOLD PEOPLE WHO ARE
OTHERWISE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
CARE OF INDIVIDUALS WHO THEN
HAVE NO ONE TO CARE FOR THEM?
BUT EDITION WAVE WE TAKE
CHILDREN THERE ARE VERY SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES TO CHILDREN TO HAVE
INCARCERATED PARENTS.
ONLY 15% OF CHILDREN WITH
INCARCERATED FATHER EVER EARN A
COLLEGE DEGREE.
ONLY 2% OF CHILDREN WITH
INCARCERATED MOTHER EARN A
COLLEGE DEGREE THAT'S COMPARED
240% OF THE POPULATION AT LARGE.
ALSO CHILDREN OF INCARCERATED
PARENTS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
THEMSELVES BECOME INCARCERATED
SO WE WANT TO BREAK THAT CYCLE
IF IT IS POSSIBLE CLEARLY.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE A DANGER.
TO OUR THE SOCIETY NEED TO BE
INCARCERATED AND WE WERE IN WE
WOULD NOT SEE SUCH AN AGREEMENT
BY A JUDGE JUDY A AND P. D..
THAT WOULD BE PROVIDED BY THIS
BILL IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES BUT
CERTAINLY IF WE CAN ALLOW FOR
DIVERSION IN APPROPRIATE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT IS WHAT THE
BILL IS TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
SO WITH THAT I WILL ALLOW MY
WITNESSES TO SPEAK.
I HAVE -- ASHLEY CARTER.
ASHLEY FOR QUALITY AND ASHLEY
CARTER WHO IS FORMALLY
INCARCERATED FOR DAUGHTER ASIA.
WHO -- AS I MENTIONED IS THE
DAUGHTER OF ASHLEY AND THEN --
THOSE ARE MY WITNESSES.
HI MY NAME IS ASIA AND MY FAMILY
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME I DON'T
KNOW WHAT I WOULD DO WITHOUT MY
FAMILY AND I AM PROUD TO BE A
CARD TO THOMAS AND I KNOW A LOT
OF PEOPLE.
WHO WOULD SAY THE SAME THING
BECAUSE YOUR FAMILY WHO IS WHO
YOU COULD TURN TO IN A CRISIS?
WHEN I WAS THREE YEARS OLD AND
MY MOTHER WENT TO PRISON HAVING
YOUR MOTHER TAKEN AWAY FROM THE
SOMATIC REGARDLESS BUT IT'S EVEN
WORSE WHEN YOU'RE ONLY?
THREE GROWING UP I WOULD TRY TO
RELATE TO OTHER KIDS BUT WHEN
KIDS WE'LL FIND OUT MY PARENTS
RAMPAGE AND I WILL GET BELIEVE
AT EVERY SCHOOL I WENT.
TO I AM VERY TRUSTING IN GENTLE
IN PEOPLE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
SO I WOULD SHARE MY STORY WITH
MY SO CALLED FRIENDS AND THEY
WOULD SAY THAT THEY UNDERSTOOD
AND THEN THEY WOULD TURN AROUND
IN THE MIDDLE CLASS AND SAY
THAT'S WHY YOUR DAD IN PRISON.
BECAUSE THEY KNEW WOULD HURT ME
I WAS ONLY IN SECOND GRADE AT
THE TIME.
I WOULD GET SO EXCITED WHEN MY
NANA WOULD TAKE ME TO GO SEE MY
MOTHER WHEN I GOT THERE TO VISIT
HER I WOULD RUN INTO HER ARMS
AND SHE WOULD CALL ME SO TIGHT I
COULDN'T.
I ALMOST COULDN'T BE.
THEN WE WOULD SIT DOWN AND TALK
IN PLACE FLAPJACK CRAZY A SINGLE
FISH.
WE WOULD TAKE OUR PICTURES AND
TALK SOME MORE BEFORE IT WAS
TIME TO LEAVE.
NO MATTER HOW LONG THE VISITS
LASTED IT WAS NEVER ENOUGH TIME.
THERE ISN'T EVER ENOUGH TIME IN
THE WORLD WITH YOUR MOTHER I
SUPPOSE SHE NOT ONLY A FEW HOURS
EVERY THREE MONTHS IF THAT.
AFTER VISITING THERE'S A FEELING
THAT COMES OVER YOU WHEN YOU'RE
WALKING THROUGH OUT THE GATE.
LEAVING THE PRISON WALKING TO
THE CAR AND WHEN YOU REALIZE
IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO GO AND YOUR
PARENT IS COMING WITH YOU IT'S
LIKE POURING SALT IN AN OPEN
WOUND.
WHEN MY MOM WAS GONE EVERYDAY
THINGS THAT I WOULD NORMALLY DO
WITH HER?
INSTEAD I HAD TO DO IT BY MYSELF
OR WITH MY NANA IN THAT WOULD
HURT.
BECAUSE CHILDREN NEED THEIR
MOTHER AND IT'S BEEN THIS WAY
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF TIME AND
THERE'S NOTHING THAT CAN CHANGE
THAT.
I BELIEVE THAT IF MY MOM HAD AN
OF WENT TO PRISON A LOT OF
THINGS WOULD BE DIFFERENT.
MAYBE SHE WAS THERE TO TELL ME I
WAS PRETTY EVERY DAY LIKE I SEE
HER DOING WITH MY LITTLE SISTER
NOW.
I WOULD HAVE BETTER SELF ESTEEM
I WOULD THINK THAT I'M GOOD
ENOUGH I WOULD THINK THAT I'M
GOOD ENOUGH IN THAT IT'S OKAY TO
BE MYSELF NO MATTER WHO'S AROUND
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO HIDE MY
TOOTH.
IN MY TRUE FEELINGS IN ORDER TO
BE ACCEPTED.
OUR RELATIONSHIP AND OUR BOND
WOULD BE STRONGER YOU WOULD KNOW
SO MUCH MORE ABOUT EACH OTHER
AND WE WILL GET ALONG MORE.
I PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE
NIGHTMARES OF GOING TO PRISON
MYSELF.
MY MOM DIDN'T KNOW ME WHEN SHE
CAME HOME AND I DIDN'T KNOW HER
AND WE'RE STILL LEARNING THINGS
ABOUT EACH OTHER EVERY DAY.
WE BOTH KIND OF ROMANTICIZED A
REUNIFICATION THAT'LL BE EASIER
AND CLEANER BUT THAT'S THE THING
ABOUT REUNIFICATION IT'S MESSY
SENATE AND HARD BUT IT'S WORTH
IT.
NO MATTER WHAT WE NEED ARE MOM.
YOUR MOM TO BE THERE WHEN YOU
FALL OFF YOUR BIKE WHICH GRAY
PUNY OR IF YOU'RE GETTING
BULLIED AT SCHOOL.
YOUR MOM IS SUPPOSED TO BE THERE
BUT IF YOU TAKE THAT AWAY YOU OF
NOTHING THE PERSON BEING
CONVICTED AND GOING TO PRISON
ISRAEL ISN'T THE ONLY ONE THAT
HAS TO SUFFER.
FROM DEALING WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND IF THE PEOPLE THAT LOVE THEM
THEIR FAMILY AND THEIR FRIENDS
AND ESPECIALLY THEIR CHILDREN I
HOPE THAT THIS BILL PASSES
SELECT CHANGE SO MANY LIVES AND
KEEP OTHER KIDS FROM
EXPERIENCING THE SAME KIND OF
PAIN THANK YOU [inaudible]
RICHARD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ASHLEY CARTER --
I'M FORMERLY INCARCERATED WOMAN.
VERY NEAR AND DEAR.
YEAH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AS I
CAN GET THROUGH A TEST.
I DON'T THINK THAT I AM UNIQUE
IN THE SENSE THAT WHEN MY
DAUGHTER ASIA WAS BORN.
I HELD HER IN MY ARMS LOOKED HER
IN HER EYES.
AND FOR HER THAT I WOULD PROTECT
HER WITH EVERY FIBER OF MY BEING.
I PROMISED HER THAT SHE HAD
NOTHING TO BE OF IT UP.
BECAUSE MAMA WOULD TAKE CARE OF
HER AND NEVER LEAVE HER SIDE.
AND I LIED.
WHEN ANGEL WAS EIGHT MONTHS OLD
HER FATHER AND I WERE INDICTED
ON DRUG CHARGES?
I WAS FACING TEN YEARS I HAD NO
PRIOR CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS AND I
HAD NEVER BEEN MORE SCARED IN MY
LIFE.
THE THOUGHT OF ME HAVING TO
LEAVE MY DAUGHTER TERRIFIED ME.
WHAT PARENT EVER DREAMS OF NEVER
BEING ABLE TO HOLD THEIR CHILD
AGAIN?
MAKE THEM PANCAKES IN THE
MORNING.
I TEACH THEM HOW TO TIE THEIR
SHOES -- OR EVEN SCOLD THEM FOR
NOT CLEANING THE ROOM LIKE
YOU'VE ASKED THEM TO DO A
HUNDRED TIMES THAT DAY.
THOSE WERE THE SCENARIOS THAT
WOULD PLAY OUT OF MY HEAD ON A
DAILY BASIS.
I WOULD WATCH HER GROW TRYING MY
HARDESTTO TAKE AS MANY MENTAL
SNAPSHOTS AS I POSSIBLY COULD
KNOWING THAT ONE DAY.
ALL I WOULD HAVE OF MY DAUGHTER
WOULD BE THOSE MEMORIES.
I SPENT THE SUBSEQUENT THREE
YEARS FIGHTING FOR NOT ONLY MY
LIFE BEFORE MY DAUGHTER'S LIFE
AS WELL.
I WAS DETERMINED TO SHOW THE
COURTS THAT I KNEW I HAD MESSED
UP AND I WAS NOT ONLY WILLING.
BUT I WAS ABLE AND DETERMINED TO
DO THE RIGHT THING. TO SOMEHOW
PROVE THAT EVEN THOUGH I HAD
MADE THESE BAD CHOICES I WAS NOT
A BAD PERSON.
MY LIFE UP UNTIL I BECAME A
MOTHER HAD BEEN FILLED WITH
CHAOS.
POVERTY UNCERTAINTY POOR CHOICES
AND ABUSE PERMEATED MY DAILY
EXISTENCE.
I HAD NO CLUE WHO I WAS OUTSIDE
OF THOSE DYNAMICS.
I WAS COMPLETELY DISCONNECTED
NOT ONLY FOR MYSELF.
BUT FROM ANY SENSE OF FAMILY
PURPOSE AND COMMUNITY.
THERE WAS A MUCH IN LIFE THAT I
CARED ABOUT BECAUSE MY LIFE
EXPERIENCE UP UNTIL THAT POINT
HAD TAUGHT ME THAT NOT MUCH IN
LIFE CARED ABOUT ME.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHO I WAS ANYMORE.
I WORK TWO JOBS TO PROVIDE FOR
MY DAUGHTER AND MY MOTHER WAS
DISABLED AND LIVING WITH US AT
THE TIME.
I QUICKLY BECAME A RECOGNIZED
EMPLOYEE AND BEGAN MOVING UP THE
RANKS WITHIN THE COMPANY FROM MY
WORKED.
I THOUGHT THEIR OPINION ATTENDED
REGULARLY I ENROLLED IN
COSMETOLOGY SCHOOL.
AN INDUSTRY THAT I HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN PASSIONATE ABOUT BUT NEVER
HAD ENOUGH FAITH IN MYSELF TO
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH.
NOT NOT ONLY DID I EXCEL
PROFESSIONALLY AND ACADEMICALLY
BUT ALSO SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED
ELECTRONIC MONITORING DRUG
TESTING AND COMPLIED WITH EVERY
OTHER PRE TRIAL STIPULATION WITH
NOT ONE SINGLE VIOLATION IN
THREE YEARS.
I COMPILED LETTERS OF SUPPORT
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
AND ORGANIZATIONS THAT I WORKED
WITH PETITIONING THE COURTS TO
ALLOW ME TO REMAIN AT HOME TO
CARE FOR MY DAUGHTER AND MOTHER.
POLICE OFFICERS EVEN SHOWED UP
TO MY HEARINGS IN SUPPORT.
IT MADE NO DIFFERENCE.
ALTHOUGH I HAD COMPLETELY
CHANGED MY LIFE FOR THE COURTS
IT WAS TOO LITTLE TOO LATE.
I WAS TOLD THEY COULDN'T LET ME
GET AWAY.
I HAD TO PAY FOR WHAT I HAD DONE.
THE REALITY OF THE MATTER IS I
WASN'T THE ONLY ONE THAT ENDED
UP PAYING WITH THAT SENTENCE.
UPON GOING TO PRISON MY MOTHER
AND DAUGHTER BECAME EASY TARGETS
FOR HOME INVASION.
MY MOTHER WAS TIED UP AND BEATEN
FRONT OF MY DAUGHTER WHO WAS
BEING RESTRAINED WITH THE GUN TO
HER HEAD.
THIS BECAME WORD THIS BECAUSE
WORD ON THE STREETS WAS THAT I
HAD WENT TO PRISON FOR SELLING
DRUGS.
SO THERE HAVE TO BE STASHES OF
MONEY IN THE HOUSE.
AFTER THE HOME INVASION MY
MOTHER AND DAUGHTER WERE NO
LONGER ABLE TO STAY IN THAT HOME.
MY MOTHER WHO WAS NOW DEALING
WITH THE PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL
ISSUES STEMMING FROM THE ATTACK
WAS FORCED TO MOVE INTO A LOCAL
SHELTER WITH MY DAUGHTER.
HERE AT THE SHELTER MY DAUGHTER
WAS AGAIN VICTIMIZED BY ANOTHER
RESIDENT OF THE FACILITY.
HERE I WAS THE MOTHER WHO LOOKED
INTO HER BABY SITES.
AND SWORE TO PROTECT HER.
WITH NO NO WHERE TO BE FOUND
DURING MOST VULNERABLE MOMENT.
I HAD LET THE MONSTERS GET.
AB.
AND THERE WAS NOTHING I COULD DO
ABOUT IT.
I WAS POWERLESS.
I SHARE THESE STORIES WITH YOU
TODAY BECAUSE BOTH OF THE WICKS
THAT I CARRY WITH ME EVERY DAY.
THE PAIN AND THE GUILT OF HOW
DIFFERENT HER LIFE COULD HAVE
BEEN.
IF I COULD HAVE JUST BEEN THERE
FOR HER.
THE DESTRUCTION AND HURT THE
SEPARATION DUE TO INCARCERATION
CAUSES CANNOT EVER ADEQUATELY BE
DESCRIBED WITH WORDS.
THIS PAIN IS ONE THAT I CAN ONLY
COMPARE TO DEATH BECAUSE ON SO
MANY LEVELS EVERYONE INVOLVED
SUFFERS SO MUCH LOSS.
ANY REPROBATE DAMAGE.
WHEN I WAS RELEASED I HAD NO
IDEA THAT THE HARDEST PART OF
OUR SEPARATION WOULD LAY BEFORE
US?
I NO LONGER KNEW WHO MY CHILD
WHAT.
WE WERE STRANGERS.
IMAGINE NOT KNOWING YOUR CHILD'S
TEACHERS NAME WHAT THEIR
FAVORITE COLOR IS OR SOMETHING
AS SIMPLE AS NOT KNOWING HOW TO
MAKE A PEANUT BUTTER AND JELLY
SANDWICH THE WAY THEY LIKE.
THE ATTACHMENT WAS A BY PRODUCT
OF INCARCERATION BECAUSE I KNEW
NO OTHER WAY TO GET TROUGH THE
PAIN OF NOT THE SCENE.
HOLDING OR WATCHING MY DAUGHTER
GROW UP ON A DAY BY DAY BASIS
THAN TO DETACH MYSELF FROM HER.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE STILL
DEAL WITH TO THIS DAY.
THE EFFECTS OF MY INCARCERATION
ON OUR FAMILY ARE STILL REELING
SIX YEARS POST RELEASE.
AND IF I'M BEING TOTALLY HONEST
WITH YOU I'M NOT SURE WHEN THEY
WILL EVER GO AWAY.
A BILL FOR JUST THREE NINETY
FOUR WOULD WOULD HAVE GIVEN ME
THE VERY OPPORTUNITY SAID I WAS
TRYING SO DESPERATELY. TO PROVE
TO THE COURTS I WAS WORTHY OF I
WASN'T ASKING TO GET OFF SCOT
FREE.
I WAS JUST ASKING FOR A CHANCE
TO PROVE THAT I WAS CAPABLE OF
MORE.
THAT I WAS WORTHY OF MORE.
AND THAT SHE WAS WORTHY OF MORE.
A LIFE WITH A LITTLE LESS RAUMA.
AND THE MOTHER KEPT WITH HER
DAUGHTER.
WE CAN CONTINUE TO LET THE
TRADITION OF YESTERDAY.
THEY TAKE THE FATE OF OUR FUTURE --
WE CAN CHALLENGE OURSELVES
ELEVATOR POLICIES AND STRATEGIES
SENATE AROUND TRUE RESTORATION
AND REHABILITATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU MISS CARTER.
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
OR SHOULD WE TAKE WITNESSES IN
THE AUDIENCE ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
AIR CARRIERS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
JANUARY TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL WITH THOSE WITH THE
ARTHUR RECIDIVISM COALITION OF
PROUD CO SPONSORS FROM SUPPORT.
NORMA COMPOUND FROM THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI AM SELENA CHEAPER WITH THE
AIR SEE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
VIDEO PORN REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
JAMES PURCHASING JAMES INFIRMARY
IN THE ANTI POLICE TERROR
PROJECT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
FULL SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TO HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WE CAN MAKE SOME ROOM AT THE
DESK PLEASE.
TIFFANY MACKEY'S ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
ALTHOUGH THIS BILL GIVES
PROSECUTORS DISCRETION TO CREATE
A FORMAL DIVERSION PROGRAM.
THE JUDGE CAN OVERRIDE THE
PROSECUTORS TERMINATION AND
INDIVIDUAL CASES.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED THAT
CERTAIN MISDEMEANORS SUCH AS
CONTACTING A MINOR WITH THE
INTENT TO COMMIT SEXUAL SOLD
WILL BE SUBJECT TO DIVERSION
UNDER THIS PROGRAM.
WE HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH THE
SPONSOR AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON
POSSIBLE AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS.
IF YOU MISS MATTHEWS ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WELL THE DALE.
OF THE MOTION TO WAIVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MY COLLEAGUES.
SENATOR JACKSON.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TEST.
IT'S REALLY VERY COMPELLING.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH HUMAN BEINGS HERE
AND TO THE DA'S ASSOCIATION.
I KNOW THAT THE BILL PROVIDES A
LOT OF DISCRETION THE DA'S IN AT
THE FRONT AND I THE I I
APPRECIATE THERE MIGHT BE SOME
ADDITIONAL BILLS THAT YOU'LL
TAKE A GET.
THE DISH ALL CRIMES THAT THAT
MIGHT THE YOU KNOW NEED TO BE
TWEAKED BUT I JUST THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE PROSECUTION
SHOULD BE EXCITED ABOUT FIFTY
MORE.
POWER IF YOU WILL BUT IT'S A
POWER TO TRY.
TO BE MORE FLEXIBLE IN
ADDRESSING THE FACT THE PEOPLE
DO MAKE BAD CHOICES BUT THEY
AREN'T NECESSARILY BAD PEOPLE.
AND WE ARE I I THINK THAT THIS
IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO COME IN
AND WORK HOLISTICALLY WITH
PEOPLE AND SO.
I KNOW WE HAVE A MOTION AND I
JUST WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALSO FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY WITH US.
WE HAVE YOUR LIGHT ON THE TO A
SPEAKS YOU DON'T MIND I WHERE
CHAIR LOVE I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE I'M UNDERSTANDING THE QUEUE
I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I JUST WANT TO SAY TO THE
AUTHORED IT'S AN IMPORTANT BAIL --
AND I HOPE THAT AS YOU GO
THROUGH TO THE PROBES COMMITTEE
THAT YOU ASKED DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND OTHERS.
IF THEY CAN -- GIVE AN ESTIMATE
ON OUR OUR FOSTER CARE NUMBERS.
AND OTHER GOVERNMENTAL
INTERVENTIONS THAT OCCUR AS A
RESULT OF THE CIRCUMSTANCE THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM FROM THIS
FAMILY WHO WAS BRAVE ENOUGH TO
SHARE THEIR PERSONAL STORIES
TODAY.
AS WE FIXATE ON THE COST OF
SOMETHING WE SHOULD ALWAYS OOK
AT THE THE LONGER TERM.
PERHAPS ON AN UNINTENTIONAL YET
VERY WILL COST TO STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHEN FAMILIES
ARE RIPPED APART AS A RESULT OF
BAD CHOICES A LONG TERM
INCARCERATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
YOU'RE WELCOME SENATOR MITCHELL.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION DO WE
HAVE A CLOSING STATEMENT
[inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU BYE SIR MORE LIKE AN
MEMBERS.
WHEN I PERCENT OF THE BILL IT
WAS RATHER -- CLINICAL AND
DISPASSIONATE BECAUSE I GAVE YOU
SOME EXAMPLES.
AROUND WITH THE LIKELIHOOD OF A
CHILD OF INCARCERATED HERE WOULD
TO GO TO COLLEGE BUT I THINK
THERE'S WE HEARD FROM OUR
TESTIMONY.
THAT WOULD BE THE LEAST OF THE
INCARCERATED.
OF THE CHILD'S WORRIES OF THE
INCARCERATED PARENTS.
AND HI I CAN IN ANY WAY.
COMMUNICATE WHAT WAS
COMMUNICATED BY THE WITNESSES I
THINK IT CLEARLY STANDS FOR
ITSELF AND I MYSELF AM VERY
EMOTIONAL AS RESULT OF HEARING
IT BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS THE
RIGHT DIRECTION FOR SO MANY
REASONS.
AND I ACTUALLY AM VERY PROUD OF
THE SPONSORS FOR CONSTRUCTING IN
A WAY THAT DID
YOU KNOW I PROBABLY AFTER
HEARING SUCH TESTIMONY WOULD
HAVE GIVEN LESS DISCRETION TO
SOME OF THE AGENCIES BUT I DO.
I UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO IF PUBLIC
SAFETY IS OUR CONCERN SO -- I
THINK IT WAS WELL CONSTRUCTED
AND I ASKED FOR EUROPE.
Q. MADAM SECRETARY ONE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL NOW SHE HAS THE
PAST TO THE FLOOR SKINNER.
THERE ARE MORE LACK [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
IT'LL AYE MORALE [inaudible]
WIENER.
IT IS THREE BOATS AND WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR CENTER SKINNER
.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA LOOK THE
CALL NOW WE MAY HAVE TO LIFT IT
TWICE BUT AT LEAST WE CAN -- TRY
TO DISPOSE OF SOME OF THESE SO
LET'S START I'M GONNA GO IN
ORDER I IT WILL SB FORTY TWO I
WANNA LOOK TO CALL OF SB ONE
FORTY ONE BATES DO WE HAVE
ANYONE YES WE DO HAVE SOMEONE
MISSING SO.
SB -- ONE FORTY ONE BATES NOW
HAS -- FIVE VOTES IN FAVOR NONE
OPPOSED LET'S DO THE MISSING
MEMBERS.
YES AS AMENDED JACKSON JACKSON
AYE MORALE.
MORALE HIGH EXCELLENT -- SB ONE
FORTY ONE IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO NOW WE WILL GO TO SB.
ONE FORTY FIVE SENATOR --
WINNERS BILL.
IT IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
AT THE MOMENT THERE ARE TWO AYE
VOTES AND NOT OPPOSED LET'S DO
THE MISSING MEMBERS.
AT BRADFORD JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL MITCHELL I
THE ONLY.
ARRESTING OKAY SORRY.
NO WORRIES OKAY.
US SO WE STORE HOLD THAT BILL
OPEN -- NOW LET'S GO TO SB TWO
THIRTY THREE SENATOR WIENER IT'S
DO PASSES AMENDED AND THE VOTE
RIGHT NOW IS THREE IN FAVOR TO
KNOW.
I'M MISSING MEMBERS JACKSON.
HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE.
THE BILL IS NOW OUT.
FIVE TWO ON THE OTHER BILLS
THREE THIRTY NINE AND TWO FIFTY
SEVEN WERE ON CONSENT.
OF WE DO HAVE -- YES -- MARK.
YES YES WILL DO THE CONSENT NOW.
HIGH MORALE HIGH.
QUALITY OKAY WE WILL STILL HAVE
TO LEAVE CONSENT OPEN BECAUSE WE
NEED MISTER BRADFORD ON IT.
ALL RIGHT SO NOW WILL GO TO SB --
THREE NINETY FOUR I SKINNER THE
BILL CURRENTLY IS AT THREE ZERO
READ THE ABSENT MEMBER.
MORALE. THREE NINETY FOUR NOT
VOTING OKAY ALL RIGHT NO WORRIES --
WE WILL STILL HOLD THAT OPEN --
THAT'S WHEN THEY OPEN YEAH YEAH
YEAH OKAY -- NO WORRIES -- THE
MURDERS THAT ONE'S OUT.
BROWN'S MISSING BRADFORD -- YEAH
HE'S NOT HERE SO I'M NOT RE
OPENING THAT.
YEAH SO SB. FOUR THIRTY THREE IT
IS MISTER MORNINGS IT'S DO
PASSED RULES THE VOTE IS
CURRENTLY AT FOUR ONE MISSING
MEMBERS JACKSON.
HI JACKSON AYE MORALE.
BY MORALE HI.
RIGHT THE BILL NOW OUT FIVE TWO
ONE NOTICE BEFORE THIRTY THREE
SIXTY ONE POLICIES [inaudible]
OKAY -- YEAH THAT WAS CONSENT
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT -- WE WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ON SB FIVE FOUR
FIVE HILL.
IT IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
ROLL CALL.
SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE JACKSON
AYE JACKSON AYE -- EIGHT THEN --
SB FIVE EIGHTY WILK DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- TO IT WAS --
THERE WERE NO OPPOSITION IS NOW
AT FIVE NOTHING. FIVE ZERO SORRY
GO HEAD MISSING MEMBERS JACKSON.
HI JACKSON AYE MORALE.
GREAT THE VOTES OUT.
SEVEN ZERO AND THEY THINK YOU
ARE ALL OFF THE HOOK AND WE WILL
JUST OR WELL WAIT FOR MISTER
BRADFORD AND MISTER WIENER.
SEVEN SIXTEEN SEVEN SIXTEEN
POINT.
THE MITCHELL BILL.
I THOUGHT WE DID.
YES.
SIX OKAY POLICIES THREE OF THAT
PAGE SOMEHOW GOT BACK.
TO YOU GOOD [inaudible]
GOOD MONITORING [inaudible]
RIGHT.
YEAH YEAH I WOULD NEVER ALLOW
THAT TO HAPPEN ONE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SB SEVEN
SIXTEEN VOTERS CURRENTLY FOUR
TWO ZERO IT IS DO PASSED TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE JACKSON
JACKSON AYE MORALE.
AROUND HIGH GREAT WE'LL HOLD IT
FOR MISTER BRETT.
NOW WE HAVE ONE OTHER.
ONE SB -- FORTY TWO WE WILL IT
IS NOW -- FIVE TWO ZERO CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MORALE.
AROUND NOW.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO NOW I'M JUST READ
FOR WILL CALL IT THE ONES YOU
YOU WERE MISSING FROM OKAY.
RESEARCHERS.
OKAY SO THE FIRST ONE IS SB ONE
FORTY FIVE WIENER DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE.
RIGHT THAT BILL IS NOW OUT.
SIX ZERO OKAY WILL GO -- TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
MISTER BRADFORD BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I RIGHT EXCELLENT CAN
CENTER.
CAN SEND CALENDARS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO WE'LL NOW GO TO SB.
THREE NINETY FOUR THE VOTE IS
SKINNER THE VOTE IS -- THREE TO
CENTER BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I WAS SORRY.
THE ROLL.
BUT WE WERE KEEPING THAT ONE
OPEN BECAUSE SENATOR WIENER
HASN'T BUT YES LET'S GO TO THE
NEXT ITEM.
RIGHT WILL NOW GO TO SB FOUR
TWENTY NINE MR NIELSEN DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT
VOTE IS THREE KNOWS TWO EYES --
GO AHEAD.
BRADFORD -- FOR NO SKEWS ME FOR
KNOWS TO ICE NOW BRADFORD ROLE.
AT FOR NOT VOTING.
THE BILL FAILS.
TO OKAY SB FOUR TWENTY NINE
FAILS.
TO TO FOR RATE THE LENGTH.
OF ALL RIGHT SO SB FIVE FORTY
FIVE SENATOR HILLS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT VOTE
IS.
SIX ZERO RECORD.
BRADFORD HI RIGHT NOW IS BE FIVE
FORTY FIVE SEVEN ZERO AND IT'S
OUT.
AND NOW WE GO TO THE FINAL BILL
YOU'RE MISSING FROM WHICH WAS SB
SEVEN SIXTEEN SENATOR MITCHELL
IT'S DO PASSED EDUCATION THE
CURRENT VOTERS. SIX ZERO
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE THE VOTE NOW IS
SEVEN ZERO IN THE BILL IS OUT.
FOR NOW WE ARE ONLY WAITING FOR
SENATOR WIENER THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER BRADFORD.
JUST FROM HER PHONE.
ONE A BOAT
THE ROLE ON A COUPLE
OF BILLS LET'S START WITH SB
FORTY TO THE CURRENT VOTE IS
[inaudible]
FIVE ONE WIENER -- WIENER.
FIVE SIX TO ONE IT'S NOT THAT
VOTERS OUT SIX ONE THAT SAYS BE
FORTY TWO AND NOW WE WILL GO TO
SB THREE NINETY FOR THE CURRENT
VOTE IS. FOR TWO FOUR FOUR ZERO
POLITIES APOLOGIES ENVY MEANS
NOT VOTING.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS OUR ZERO
WIENER.
WIENER AYE RIGHT HELP.
SB THREE NINETY FOUR IS NOW OUT.
FIVE ZERO AND IS OTHERWISE WE
HAVE SENATOR WINNER AND
EVERYTHING JUST MAKE SURE JUST
MAKE SURE DID I MEAN WE DON'T.
SELL IT WITH.
YOUR WINTERS THERE ARE RIGHT.
YEAH AND THE CASHIER WILL NOT
MAKE YOU NEED.
HIS MISTAKES IN OR WHAT HE
ANNOUNCES.
SO.
WE ARE.
NOW DURING THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POLICY COMMITTEE THANK YOU